ON HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES YOU
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE REVIEWS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AGAIN.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FIVE FOUR FOUR OH
EIGHT FOUR AGAIN THE ACCESS
EIGHT FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID TO
STICK FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AS THE CHAIR I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE TO CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTED HEARINGS
IN THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER IT'S CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
DISTURBANCE OR ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW. USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PAY SO THAT ALL AND
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
IN THE FOLLOWING FILE ITEMS ARE
ON A CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
NUMBER ONE SB FIVE TWENTY FIVE
BY CENTER GROVE AND ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
CENTER HERTZBERG. THERE ARE TWO
ITEMS WILL NOT BE HEARING TODAY
IS THEY'LL BE HELD OVER TO- THE
FOLLOWING HEARING THOSE ARE
ITEMS NUMBER THIRTEEN SB SIX
SIX FOUR BY CENTER ALAN. AND I
AM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB SEVEN ONE
EIGHT BY SENATOR BATES. THE
BILLS WILL BE HEARD IN FILE
ORDER SO I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT CENTER WIENER NO LONGER
COMES AT THE END OF EVERY
HEARING. THE ORDER MAY BE
MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE BILL
ABILITY OF BILL AUTHORS TO
PRESENTS AND THE NEED TO
COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA IN
A TIMELY MANNER. BEFORE YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS- I
SEE A NOTE THAT WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. FOR BILL
TESTIMONY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTHOF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. ISAAC COMMITTEE
CHAIR WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY. EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY MYSELF AS THE CHAIR. SO FOR
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- PERMIT UP TO
TWO WITNESSES. FOR TWO MINUTES
FOR WITNESS ARE ACTUALLY A
MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT TO
COMMONSENSE HER NAME. THE
AFFILIATION AND A POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. I DO HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY HOWEVER BECAUSE WE HAVE
A DEFINITIVE END TIME FOR THE
HEARING. I MAY LIMIT THE TOTAL
TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS ON A BILL
TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEES ABLE
TO COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERYONE ALSO HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY SUBMIT TESTIMONY ON
ANY BILL BEING HEARD TODAY ON
THE- AND IN THE COMMITTEE ON
THE CUFF COMMITTEE WEBSITE SO
IT'S CERTAINLY FOR YOU WISH TO
GIVE MORE DETAIL TESTIMONY ARE-
YOU'RE UNABLE TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY PLEASE GO TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND PROVIDE
YOUR COMMENTS THERE. SO WITH
THAT C. TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
ACTUALLY WE HAVE TO HAVE ENOUGH
FOR A QUORUM- YEAH RIGHT OKAY
SO WITH THAT I'D MAKE NOTE THAT
I BELIEVE WE POTENTIALLY HAVE A
QUORUM PRESIDENT. SO- SO
CONSULTANT BEFORE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILLS
PLEASE LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN CAN HEAR MELENDEZ EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ GROVE HER
TADO HERE HURTADO HERE LEYVA.
LIMON ROTH ROTH HERE RUBIO
RUBIO HERE WIENER. PRESENT
WINNER HERE. OKAY THE COR A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU- AND CONSULT. ALL
RIGHT SO WE WILL NOW BEGIN WITH
THE FIRST BILL ITEM NUMBER ONE
S. B. ONE TEN BY CENTER WIENER.
WE WILL PRESENT FROM YOUR DESK
YES THANK YOU. THANK YOU TOM
THANK YOU FOR THE. OKAY THERE
WILL PRESENT FROM THE PODIUM
OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE SIT TOO MUCH SO IT'S NICE TO
STAND FOR A WHILE. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES WITH THEIR FEEDBACK
RESERVE JUST A LITTLE BIT. WHAT
YOU KEEP TALKING WILL SEE I
THINK THAT YOU'RE JUST AN EDGE
BUT IT PERSISTS WILL TAKE A
PAUSE BUT WHAT IS CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- FOR
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY
APPRECIATE A- SENATE BILL ONE
ISN'T. SENATE BILL ONE TEN OKAY
THAT'S BETTER OKAY. CORRECT
SENATE BILL ONE TEN THE
RECOVERY INCENTIVES ARE GONE IS
A HARM REDUCTION PUBLIC HEALTH
BILL THAT SIMPLY REQUIRES A
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
INTERVENTIONS BE REIMBURSABLE.
BY MEDICARE ALL OF THE BILL
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS NOT IN VIOLATION
OF STATE ANTI KICKBACK LAWS FOR
HEALTH TREATMENTS. CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS A SCIENTIFICALLY
PROVEN FORM OF BEHAVIORAL
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION THAT
USES POSITIVE INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO OBTAIN FROM
DRUG USE AND TO REMAIN IN DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAMS- THE- THE
VA- THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY-
CURRENTLY USES CONTINUE TO
MANAGEMENT IN THE VA HAS DONE
SO SUCCESSFULLY. FOR ABOUT A
DECADE- ACROSS CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY DURING COVERT
NINETEEN SUBSTANCE USE
HOSPITALIZATION DUE TO DRUG USE
AND OVERDOSES ARE ALL
SKYROCKETING OVERDOSE DEATHS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE GONE OFF THE
CHARTS- LAST YEAR ALMOST FORTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS DIED OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS. FIVE MATH IN
PARTICULAR- IS RAVAGING OUR
COMMUNITIES IN MY OWN
DISTRICTS- MATH IS INVOLVED IN
A MAJORITY OF OVERDOSE DEATHS
AND MATH RELATED HOSPITAL
VISITS HAVE JUMPED OVER 6100%
BETWEEN. TWENTY ELEVEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN. BECAUSE CURRENT
NO IN- FOR METHOD WE HOPE THAT
TO SOME POINT IN THE NEAR
FUTURE BUT AS OF NOW THERE'S NO
MEDICAL INTERVENTION- WE MUST
TURN TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS TO SAVE LIVES AND
HELP PEOPLE TO ABSTAINED. BY
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT IS A
PROVEN METHOD TO REDUCE
SUBSTANCE USE THAT IS A KEY
TOOL AND INTERESTING AND
ADDRESSING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PARTICULARLY FOR MATH
AND OTHER STIMULANTS. AS AN
EXAMPLE A CLINIC THAT OPERATES
A DRUG TREATMENT PROGRAM- IT
MAY OPERATE A CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT INTERVENTION PROGRAM
IN WHICH A PARTICIPANT COULD
RECEIVE GIFT CARDS OR VOUCHERS
IN EXCHANGE FOR NEGATIVE URINE
TESTS OR TREATMENT
PARTICIPATION ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. I PERSONALLY KNOW
SOMEONE IN SAN FRANCISCO'S A
VERY PUBLIC ABOUT THIS WHO IS
BADLY ADDICTED TO MATH AND HE
PARTICIPATED IN A CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WHERE YOU
WOULD URINATE A COP EVERY WEEK
AND EVERY TIME THE TEST WAS
NEGATIVE HE RECEIVED SEVEN
DOLLARS. THAT WAS ENOUGH OF AN
INCENTIVE TO KEEP HIM ON TRACK
AND HE'S BEEN SOBER. FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME NOW- BY CREATING
A- INCENTIVE FOR PATIENTS TO
STOP USING DRUGS AND RETURNS A
DRUG TREATMENT. CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS A STRONG TOOL
THAT PROVABLY IMPROVES HEALTH
OUTCOMES- THIS WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THE PARTICULAR
AS WE COME OUT OF THE PEN AND
US. HELP PEOPLE- STOP USING AND
STOP- AND GET HEALTHY- WE KNOW
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS MADE
ADDICTION WORSE HAS MEETINGS IT
DEPRESSION OTHER MENTAL HEALTH-
WORSE- WE NEED TO TAKE
PROACTIVE. STEPS I WOULD TO
ALSO NOTE THAT RECENTLY THE
BINDING HARRIS. ISSUED A
STATEMENT ON A DRUG POLICY
PRIORITIES FOR THE FIRST YEAR
OF ADMINISTRATION- I WANT TO
QUOTE IN THAT FROM THE PLAN ONE
OF THE OBJECTIVES THIS CALL I
AND ADDRESS POLICY BARRIERS
RELATED TO CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT INTERVENTIONS FOR
STIMULANT USE DISORDER AND
EXPLORE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MOTIVATIONAL INCENTIVES AND
DIGITAL TREATMENT FOR ADDICTION
ESPECIALLY STIMULANT USE
DISORDER LEVINE ADMINISTRATION
IS ADVOCATING FOR EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE. TODAY
THIS PROVEN INTERVENTION- SB
ONE TENDS NOT ESTABLISH ANY
PROGRAMS ARE SET UP PARTICULAR
FORMS OF CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
BUT SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT IT'S
LEGAL AND AUTHORIZES MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION OF QUALITY
CALIFORNIA CALPERS THREE SIXTY-
AND OTHER- REALLY ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ADDICTION
ORGANIZATIONS- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE TYRONE
CLIFFORD THERE WAS A COUNSELOR
AT THE STONE WALL PROJECT WHICH
IS A PROGRAM OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION. AND
DR STEVE I SHOP TALK A
PSYCHOLOGIST AND DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR BEHAVIORAL AND
ADDICTION MEDICINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER- MODERATOR
PLEASE- BRING ON TO LINE TYRONE
CLIFFORD- FROM THE STONE WALL
PROJECT IN THIS EXAMPLE THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION AND
STEVE SHOPTALK SEVENTY SILLY
DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY MEDICINE.
HAVE YOU PLEASE BRING THEM ON
THE LINE. AND. FOR THE SECOND
ISSUE A TRADITION FROM I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT CONTINUE TO MANAGE
CRYSTAL CONSECUTIVE I'M SORRY
TENSIONS GENERALS WHAT'D SAY
AND THEY REFERRED ME THE PROPER
PROGRAM IS TO CONTINUE TO
RECALL. BY STAR DOING THAT
PROGRAM. IT'S ONLY SIX WEEKS.
BY TWENTY SIX MINUTES AND.
REALLY MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
LIFE GOOD BATES AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT OF LOOKING- CENTER
DEPRIVE GRAMMAR ABLE TO LAW I
BUT TO FOR YEAR. AND SINCE THEN
I'VE ON BACK TO SCHOOL. ONE
ACCOUNTS OF MICE IN THE AT
WORKING THE PARK. THE COUNSELOR
FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND- IT REALLY
MADE A BIG IN MY LIFE. BEFORE I.
WHAT MADE CHANGES IN THEIR
LIVES THAT SMALL INCENTIVE
STARTING AT TWO DOLLARS GOING
UP A QUARTER PROTEST- LEGALIZE
DRUGS WITH FUND TO BE ABLE TO.
PAY PHONE BILLS THAT COULD KEEP
APPOINTMENTS- BUY FOOD TO HELP
PAY FOR THE BUILDING EVEN RAT.
I'M. AT NO POINT I FELT LIKE TO
ME THE PEOPLE I WAS WORKING
WITH WAS A BREACH IN THE
PROGRAM- IF WE DON'T GET CASH
THAT'S ALL GIFT CARDS- MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BY COMING IN AND
HAVING A NEGATIVE TEST. I'M.
YEAH I GUESS THAT'S ALL THEY
HAVE TO SAY JUST YET. I BELIEVE
ARMY DUCKS IN A CONTINUE TO
MANAGEMENT- IF I COULD I WOULD
BE THE POSTER CHILD FOR. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NOW LET'S MOVE ON THE SHOPTALK
YES PLEASE BEGIN YEAH THIS IS.
YEAH THIS IS DOCTOR STEVE SHOP
SO I'M A PROFESSOR OF FAMILY
MEDICINE HERE UCLA- ACTUALLY
HELPED DEVELOP THE PRODUCT
PROJECTS IN SAN FRANCISCO ABOUT
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS AGO- I
THINK THE TWO THINGS I WANT TO
SAY IS TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE THE CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS A TREATMENT. IT'S
NOT JUST PAYING PEOPLE TO DO
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO IT ANYWAY.
IF NOW YOU'VE- EXECUTIVE WHILE
MARK TWAIN STIMULANT ABSTINENCE
AND THAT'S THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PERIOD OF FORTY EIGHT TO
SEVENTY TWO HOURS EACH TIME.
IT'S AN EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS DEVELOPED BY
RESEARCHERS MANY OF WHOM ARE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OR SO IT'S TIME THAT
THIS TREATMENT COMES INTO THE
TREATMENT SYSTEM. IT'S FLEXIBLE
IT CAN BE USED DELIVERED USING
VOUCHERS OR CAN BE DELIVERED
USING A FISH BALL- IT IT IT IS
EVIDENCE BASED AND ALL OF THE
DATA ARE CONSISTENT TO SHOW IT
WORKS. PERFECT SIZE OF THIS
TREATMENT IS THAN THE MODERATE
TO HIGH EFFECT SIZE RANGE POINT
QUARTER POINT SIX. WHICH IS
ABOUT THE SAME EFFECT SIZE FOR
MOST ANTIBIOTICS BETTER TREAT
USED TO TREAT INFECTIONS- THIS
STANDARD IS AROUND THE WORLD
I'VE DONE WORK WITH CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IN SOUTH AFRICA AND
THE SAME LEVEL OF THE FACT.
THAT IF CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
WERE A MEDICATION IT WOULD BE
THE STANDARD OF CARE- AS NOTED
ALREADY IS THE STANDARD OF CARE
IN THE VA AND WE NEED TO BRING
IT FORWARD. AND RAMP IT UP.
THIS SHOWS WE CAN. MANAGED
WORKS RELEASING
NEUROTRANSMITTERS CAN
INCENTIVES ARE SPENT THAT'S
IMPORTANT. AND WHAT WE SHE'D
SEEN IS THE CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT HELPS REVERSE THE
KEY PART OF ADDICTION TO
METHAMPHETAMINE THAT INVOLVES
MAKING DECISIONS OF RISK THAT
IS AVOIDING DRUGS. FOR LONG
TERM GAIN OUTCOMES ESPECIALLY
IN THE CITING A RECENT LOSS
THANK YOU SO THE TAKE HOME IS
THERE'S A NEW WAVE OF
METHAMPHETAMINE ADDICTION WITH
FEDERAL OUT THERE THAT'S
DESTROYING OUR LIVES AND IT'S
TIME TO BRING THIS ESSENTIAL
TREATMENT ONLINE CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITHOUT THE DEER FROM WITNESSES
WHO ARE INSTITUTIONAL
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT A NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION ONLY.
START WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S MOVE THROUGH TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING UPS WE HAVE TWENTY FORTY
HERE WELL I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY ON MY IMAGE HERE-
JUST CONFIRMING THAT- LET'S
MOVE ON TO TELEPHONIC LINE.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
TWO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
ONE TEN. AND AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF SB. ONE
TEN. AND LEAD ME ON IF YOU ARE
N SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE TEN. AND
AT THIS TIME WE DO OF ABOUT
THIRTEEN IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY.
PLEASE BEGIN IT AND WE WILL
START WITH NUMBER NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ARMAAN
MORE FOR SB THIRTY SEVENTY
NINE. HEY PLEASE. WAIT FOR THAT
ONE WHERE AGAIN THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TEN. EXLINE.
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AS PAUL
YODER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU Q. NEXT LINE.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF OF PEAR
THERAPEUTICS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE NEXT
WITHIN THE NUMBER ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRITICAL COOPER ON BEHALF OF A
DELAY HEALTH IN LOS ANGELES
APPROACH- SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
THE NEXT IN THE NUMBER ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD AND.
THAT'S THE ENTRANCE BROWN SAID
NATIONAL FIXATION. WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. SB ONE TEN
EACH YEAR THANK YOU NEXT. WELL
NOW GOING TO NUMBER ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
COSPONSORED THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO THE ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN HOLDEN MAY SHOWER
AND THE HOUSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVE IS A
COSPONSOR AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU EXLINE.
WELL NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
HAVE ALONG WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
PHOENIX IS NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE CHAIR MEMBER SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WON FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT IS MERRY
MARKET HAVE A FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN FROM UCLA CALLING TO
VOICE CONCERNS. OKAY WE HAVE
NOT GOTTEN TO OPPOSITION YET SO
YOU MAY WANT TO WAIT TILL WE
GET TO THAT POINT- NEXT LINE.
NEKOGA NUMBER ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK AS THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ACTUALLY THE NUMBER ONE OH
THREE PLEASE CUT. SHARE MEMBERS
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF WHAT
ONE THE COSPONSORS CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
EVERY AFFECTED EVERYDAY WE ARE
JUST EIGHTY NINE POSITIONAL NAY
NAY MARSEILLE'S POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU ASSUME YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS LINE. THE
NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL
EDIGER REPRESENTING THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
IN CALIFORNIA WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TEN PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN OUR QUEUE TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. AND NEXT WILL BE LINE
ONE FIFTY EIGHT- ONE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI IN
THE SAME WAY TO SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION AND I'M MORE
CALLING IN THE CROWD COSPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NOFURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
CHECK THANK YOU MODERATOR WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AT THE MOMENT WE
HAVE NO. WE DO NOT HAVE SOMEONE
REGISTERED AS A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS TO TESTIFY SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
WE'LL START WITH PUBLIC GALLERY
SAYING ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN KNOWN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
TELEPHONIC LINE TO PEOPLE%
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE TEN.
AND NOW IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. HE HAD ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION SB. ONE TEN. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NONE IN THE
QUEUE OKAY THANKS- PARDON ME
LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE IS JOINING
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT YEAH THERE
WAS ONE PERSON WHO. OKAY SO
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY FIVE
IN THE WRONG ROOM ASKING SORRY
THIS IS MERRY MARGIE'S I WANT
TO MAKE SURE FOR THE RECORD
THAT I AM WITHDRAWN FROM THIS I
GOT PUT IN THE WRONG ROOM FOR
THE RUN BILL. OKAY SO. BUT
PERSONALLY IN THE POSITION I'M
IN FAVOR SIGNED IN THE WRONG
ROOM OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY OTHER.
WOULDN'T ARE DANIELLE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP ONE
TEN. AT THE TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
THANK YOU MODERATOR NOW WILL
BRING IT BACK TO TOO MANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SIR
EGGMAN IS MOVED THE BILL CENTER
GROVE. YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
JUST A FEW QUESTIONS- ON THE
SURFACE SENATOR WIENER I THINK
IT'S I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL-
BECAUSE I THINK INCENTIVES WILL
HELP INDIVIDUALS- YOU KNOW GET
OFF DRUGS LEAD TO MORE
PRODUCTIVE LIFE. I'M CONCERNED
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INFORMATION
HERE ABOUT THE INCENTIVES LIKE
I MEAN IS IT A FIVE DOLLAR GIFT
CARD THEY STAY CLEAN FOR THIRTY
DAYS OR IS IT A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IF THEY STAY CLEAN FOR
A WEEK SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF
INCENTIVES AND WHAT THE
PARAMETERS SURROUNDING THAT. SO
THE BILL DOES NOT LIKE
MICROMANAGE THE EXACT CONTOURS
OF THE PROGRAM'S DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TO A DIFFERENT WAY.
WAYS THE BILL HAS TWO THINGS
FIRST OF ALL IT'S A SAYS THAT
IT'S LEGAL WHAT WE THINK IT. WE
THINK IT ALREADY HAS BUT- THERE
IS SOME AGENCIES THINKER IS
NOT. ON AND THEN IT AUTHORIZES
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT- AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. IS ACTUALLY ALREADY
LOOKING AT THIS- POSITIVE ABOUT
IT AND T. H. SEE- SOMATIC CAL
WOULD SET A REIMBURSEMENT
SCHEDULE. AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THAT WILL CONTAIN- COPS IN
OUR PRESUME THAT IT WOULD BE
TEN CAPS. BUT IN TERMS OF THESE
PROGRAMS WORK I MENTIONED- THAT
AT THE BEGINNING. OF THE
SOMEONE. I KNOW IN SERVICES GO
WHO WAS VERY ADDICTED TO METH.
HE WORRIES HE WOULD KEY IN A
CAR OR HAVING YOUR NAY. COP
EVERY WEK AND IT WAS NEGATIVE
HE WOULD GET SEVEN DOLLARS-
THERE ARE OTHER PROGRAMS- I'M
AWARE OF WHERE THEY'LL GET. A
TWENTY OR THIRTY DOLLAR GIFT
CARD SAID A SAFE WAY- THERE-
THE- YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM I
BELIEVE THE PROGRAM OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION. COBB
SALAD SOMETHING LIKE THREE
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS. OVER A MULTI MONTH
PERIOD SO TYPICALLY THESE ARE.
PAYMENTS SECOND AS LOW AS
SEVENTY TEN DOLLARS OR MAYBE
TWENTY THIRTY DOLLARS AND YOU
GET IT LIKE ONCE A WEEK
TYPICALLY MAYBE ONCE A WEEK
OVER A PERIOD OF MONTHS. ON
IT'S NOT A PERMANENT PROGRAM
THE PROGRAM AND- AND IT'S
PROBABLY CUTS. OUT AROUND A FEW
HUNDRED DOLLARS. M. I. APRIL
THAT I. SEE ANY OF THE IN THE-
I SEE IF OR CEILING- FOR THE
REMEMBER THE REIMBURSEMENT OR
THE AWARD I DIDN'T SEE A FLOOR
OR A CEILING. AND I DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING ON M. ON A TERMINATION
DATE OR A DATE THAT WERE. YOU
KNOW WOULD GO ON FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS AND OBVIOUSLY
SO- AND I KNOW THAT'S YOUR
INTENT. I JUST I AM. I LIKE THE
IDEA BUT I HAVE TO VOTE ON THE
BILL BEFORE ME AND IT I JUST
DON'T SEE THAT IN THE BILL. I
AM. WE I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE TO INCLUDE THAT
LEVEL OF MICROMANAGEMENT IN THE
BILL DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WORK IN
DIFFERENT WAYS- DH CS WILL HAVE
EVERY ABILITY TO DEFINE
CONTOURS OF REIMBURSEMENT IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW MAXIM MORE
MINIMUMS- ANDS- AND SO I DON'T
I DON'T THINK THAT'LL BE AN
ISSUE AND I WOULD PERSICO.
UNCOMFORTABLE INCLUDING THAT
LEVEL OF MICROMANAGEMENT IN THE
BILL WERE SIMPLY SAYING BROADLY
THAT MEDIC CAL IS AUTHORIZED TO
DO THIS- AND THE MEDIC CAL WORK
OUT ALL THE DETAILS ABOUT WHAT
THE REIMBURSEMENT WILL LOOK
LIKE THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE AND THE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THE BILL. OKAY SAYING NONE-
RIGHT SAY NONE AT SERRA WINNER
AT APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- AGAIN AS YOU
POINTED OUT THIS IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACH- I LISTEN MAKE
NOTE THAT- BELIEVES INTENDED TO
BILLS TO CLARIFY BECAUSE OF
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
ABOUT WHETHER. OUR MEDICAL
PROGRAM CAN ACTUALLY DO THIS
AND- THIS- BILL DOES CLARIFY
THAT QUESTION. WELL O I
APPRECIATE THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL'S DOING- WOULD WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY AS FROM
A VOTE OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH-
SO THIS BILL IS A BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS--CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S. EGGMAN
RIGHT EGGMAN I AND SALAS HI AND
SALAS I GREW. HER TADO. LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE LIMóN ROTH HI
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. SO THE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE AGAIN BY CENTER WIENER.
THESE AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY NINE- PROHIBITS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SYSTEM. FROM ENTERING INTO ANY
CONTRACT WITH ANOTHER HEALTH
FACILITY. THAT LIMITS THE
SERVICES THAT YOU SEE
PHYSICIANS- AND OTHER PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE. TO
PATIENTS- BASED ON NONCLINICAL
OFTEN DISCRIMINATORY
RESTRICTIONS ON CARE. IN OTHER
WORDS THE BILL WILL ENSURE THE
UC PHYSICIANS. AND PROVIDERS
EVEN IF THEY ARE AN AFFILIATED
HOSPITAL. CAN PROVIDE WHATEVER
TREATMENT THEY THINK IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT PATIENT.
WITHOUT BEING BOUND BY NON
SCIENCE BASED- TREATMENT
RESTRICTIONS. ARE YOU SEE
HEALTH SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE
BEST HEALTH SYSTEMS IN OUR
NATION AND FRANKLY THE WORLD.
HAS WORLD RENOWNED LEADERSHIP
AND REPRODUCTIVE. AND LGBTQ TWO
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE. ARE YOU
SEE YOU SEE TRULY EMBODIES
CALIFORNIA PROGRESSIVE VALUES
AROUND HEALTH CARE ACCESS.
UCHEALTH IS ALSO THE FOURTH
LARGEST HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU SEE RECEIVED
NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN. STATE
FUNDING- AND PLAYS A CENTRAL
ROLE IN TRAINING THE NEXT
GENERATION. OF PHYSICIANS.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
TREATED BY UC. PROVIDERS EVERY
YEAR. AND ONE OF UC'S CORE
VALUES IS INCLUSIVE HEALTH
CARE. THE NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE
THE MATTER HOW MARGINALIZED YOU
ARE. NO MATTER WHAT. NO MATTER
THAT SOCIETY MAY HAVE WRITTEN
YOU OFF YOU WILL GET HEALTH. IN
PARTICULAR. IN PARTICULAR YOU
SEE POVIDES STRONG ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE. HEALTH CARE AND
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE. DESPITE
THE CORE VALUE USE HEALTH HAS A
INTO PHILLY BECAUSE- EARLY
PLANS TO SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND
THESE CONTRACTS OVER TIME WITH
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THAT
IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON MEDICAL
CARE THAT ARE NOT BASED ON
SCIENCE OR ANY CLINICAL
CRITERIA. THESE RESTRICTIONS
CAN BE BASED ON POLITICAL VIEW
FOR EXAMPLE HOSPITAL MANAGEMENT
IS POLITICALLY OPPOSED TO
CERTAIN PROCEDURES IT CAN BE
BASED ON RELIGIOUS VIEWS FOR
EXAMPLE BISHOP HAS DETERMINED
THAT CERTAIN HEALTH CARE
VIOLATES RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE OR
OTHER RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE NOT
BASED IN SCIENCE OR CLINICAL
DECISION MAKING. AS PART OF
UC'S CONTRACT WITH THESE
HOSPITALS YOU SEE PHYSICIANS
AND NURSES AND MEDICAL STUDENTS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM PERFORMING
CERTAIN HEALTH CARE WHEN YOU
SEE PATIENTS WHEN THEY'RE
PRACTICING AND IS AFFILIATED
HOSPITALS SO YOU SEE THE
PHYSICIAN PUBLIC EMPLOYEE. IS
BOUND BY THOSE NON SCIENCE
BASED RESTRICTIONS. ON
SPECIFICALLY OF THE RESTRICTIVE
CONTRACTS AT UC HEALTH HAS
ENTERED INTO EXPLICITLY PREVENT
YOU SEE DOCTORS AND STUDENTS
FROM FOR EXAMPLE. BY TREATING A
MISCARRIAGE ON THE IN AND THE
SITUATION WHERE IT IS
CONSIDERED TO BE QUOTE UNQOTE
AN ABORTION IF THERE'S STILL A
FETAL HEARTBEAT AND REQUIRING A
PARENT TO CERTAIN TURMOIL UNTIL
THE HEARTBEAT STOPS- PROVIDING
EMERGENCY CONTRACEPTION TO
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
FORMING A TUBAL LIGATION- WALL
A WOMAN IS HAVING A C. SECTION-
PERFORMING SURGERY TO ADDRESS
AN ECTOPIC PREGNANCY AND YOU'LL
HEAR SOME TESTIMONY ABOUT THAT
SITUATION TODAY. INSERTING AN
IUD INTO A WOMAN PROVIDING
SPECIFIC CARE TO TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE DENYING
HYSTERECTOMIES AT HOSPITALS
WITH RESTRICTIONS. TO
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS EVEN THOSE
HOSPITALS THAT REGULARLY PERMIT
HYSTERECTOMIES FOR OTHER
PATIENTS. THESE RESTRICTIONS
AND DANGER LIVES THEY DENIED
BASIC HEALTH CARE OF THE UC
POSITION POLICE IS APPROPRIATE.
THIS CONTRACTING PROCESS HAS
BEEN DONE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
WITH LIMITED PUBLIC INFORMATION
ON THE IMPACT OF THESE
CONTRACTS ON BASIC PREVENTATIVE
CARE AND URGENT CARE. THESE
DECISIONS HAVE LEFT PATIENTS
ADVOCATES AND LAWMAKERS AND
EVEN PHYSICIANS IN THE DARK ON
WHAT THESE CONTRACTS MEAN FOR
PATIENT CARE. OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED YOU SEE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE SIGNED AN OPEN
LETTER EXPRESSING THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THESE
DISCRIMINATORY RESTRICTIONS ON
UC PRACTITIONERS. AND
FACILITIES WITH NONCLINICAL NON
SCIENCE BASED HEALTH CARE
RESTRICTIONS TONIGHT BASIC CARE
AND THIS HAS TO CHANGE OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY AS ALWAYS
HARMS LOW INCOME PEOPLE. ON
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
CALLERS OBIANO SEE OPPOSITION
LETTERS WE RECEIVED AND THE
LETTER OF CONCERN FROM YOU SEE
HAS NOT BEEN STRAIGHTFORWARD IF
YOU READ THE LETTER QUICKLY YOU
WOULD THINK THAT THEY'RE SAYING
THAT THERE'S NO RESTRICTIONS
WHATSOEVER. AND IT BARELY
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT MAYBE THERE
IS BUT THESE ARE SEVERE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE ABILITY OF
YOU SEE PRACTITIONERS TO
PROVIDE CARE THAT THEY NEED. I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS BILL
WAS NOT A RUSH BILL. THE UC HAS
HAD YEARS AND YEARS TO REMEDY
THIS PROBLEM THERE HAVE BEEN
WORKING COMMITTEES AND ROUND
TABLES AND ALL SORTS OF
DISCUSSIONS FOR YEARS BECAUSE
THIS HAS BEEN A KNOWN ISSUE.
AND TODAY YOU SEE HAS NOT
RESULTED YOU SEE DID MAKE A
CHANGE TO AND THE SO CALLED GAG
RULE BECAUSE IT USED TO BE THAT
THESE HOSPITALS WOULD EVEN ARE
YOU SEE PRACTITIONER. WOULD NOT
EVEN BE ALLOWED TO TELL TO TELL
A PATIENT THAT THEY MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER A TUBAL LIGATION OR
SEE GENDER AFFIRMING CARETHEY
WEREN'T EVEN ALLOWED TO SAY IT
OR MAKE A REFERRAL THAT AT
LEAST HAD ENDED AND THAT'S
GOOD. BUT THEY STILL CAN'T
PROVIDE ON THE ACTUAL
TREATMENT. AND SO YOU KNOW WE
WE'VE BEEN GOING ON AND AROUND
AND AROUND AND AROUND THE
COMMUNITY HAS OF YOU SEE FOR
YEARS NOW AND NOTHING. OR VERY
LITTLE HAS CHANGED AND WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT IF WE
DON'T SET A POLICY IN PLACE
NOW. WE KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW A
VERY TINY PERCENTAGE OF YOU SEE
PATIENTS ARE SUBJECT ARE A PART
OF THESE AFFILIATIONS AND SMALL
NOW. BUT IT'S GOING TO GROW AND
NOW IS THE TIME TO SET THE
GROUND RULES AND TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT YOU SEE VALUES THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES. MEAN THAT
PEOPLE GET THE ACCESS TO CARE
THAT THEY NEED AND THAT WE
DON'T BIND. ARE YOU SEE
PRACTITIONERS ARE WITH THESE
NON SCIENCE BASED RESTRICTIONS.
ON THIS LEGISLATION SENATE
SPONSOR BY A CALL CAL. NAY ROLE
PRO CHOICE IT CAN. PLEASE TELL.
AND IT IS BY THE PARA HEALTH
ACCESS. AND A LARGE NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS. FOCUSED ON
REPRODUCTIVE AND LGBTQ
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR NOT
THE DOCTOR JODY STEINHAUER WHO
IS A PROFESSOR OF OUT OF STOCK
STAR TREK'S CONCHOLOGY AND
REPRODUCTIVE SCIENCES. AND
DIRECTOR OF THE DIXIE CENTER
FOR GLOBAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AS WELL AS MADDY WHO- WHO ELSE
JUST USE HER FIRST NAME WHO IS
A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY WHO
HAS BEEN IMPACTED. BY THESE
POLICIES- AND- THANK AND WE
ALSO ELIZABETH KILL FROM THE
ACLU WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE AT
CERTAIN TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
COME UP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO LINE DR JUDY STEIN
OUR AND MADDIE- BASICALLY WE OF
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES BUT
THERE'S A TOTAL FOUR MINUTES-
SO- DOCTOR SIGN ARE YOU BECAUSE
YOU BEGIN I WILL GIVE A TWO
MINUTE WARNING YOU GET TWO
MINUTES BUT- THAT HE- EVERY
SECOND AFTER THAT AND TAKES
AWAY FROM MATTIE'S TESTIMONY
TIME SO KEEP THAT IN MIND. SO
WITH TE MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES-
SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE BEGIN
WITH- DOCTOR JODY STEINHAUER
AND THEN FOLLOWED BY MADDIE SO
DR STEIN OUR. HI MY NAME IS DR
JODY STEINHAUER I'M AN
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGIST AND
DIRECTOR OF THE BIG THE CENTER
FOR GLOBAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO. I THINK YOU SEE
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES
BEGINNING WHEN I WAS AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ENTERING
MEDICAL SCHOOL RESIDENCY AND
GRADUATE TRAINING IN RESEARCH
AND EDUCATION. I STATE IT YOU
SEE BECAUSE OF THE VALUES THAT
GROUND OUR WORK WE PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF EVIDENCE BASED
CARE TO ALL PATIENTS. I'M
TESTIFYING BECAUSE I'M
DISTRESSED BY YOU COULD
CONTRACT THAT REQUIRE YOU SEE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO LIMIT THE
CARE WE PROVIDE PATIENTS WHICH
NOT ONLY CONTRADICTS OUR VALUES
BUT ALSO HARMS TRAINEES AND
THEIR FUTURE PATIENTS. ARE YOU
SEE TRAINING NOT ONE PATIENT
CENTERED EVIDENCE BASED CARE.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT IN CLINICAL
ENVIRONMENTS THAT RESTRICT THEM
FROM PROVIDING BASIC STANDARD
OF CARE TREATMENTS. WE KNOW
FROM STUDIES AT MY COLLEAGUES
AND I HAVE DONE. THE PEOPLE
TRAINED IN HOSPITALS THAT
RESTRICT THEM FROM PROVIDING
FAMILY PLANNING CARE DO NOT
LEARN THE BASIC SKILLS THEY
SHOULD. THE STUDY SAID THAT
MANY MEDICAL STUDENTS GRADUATE
WITHOUT KNOWING HOW TO COUNSEL
SOMEONE ABOUT ALL CONTRACEPTIVE
OPTIONS. AND MANY OF THE YOUNG
RESIDENTS DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE PLACING AN IED OR.
DOING POSTPARTUM STERILIZATION.
BECAUSE MOST TRAIN STATE
HEALTHCARE. I AM WORRIED ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON THEIR FUTURE
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS. AMPLE WHEN
SOMEONE WANTS TO PUT PRINCIPLE
LIGATION ACTIVISION WHO TRAINED
IN A RESTRICTED SETTING MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE IT I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT HALF OF
WOMEN WHO AREN'T ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR DESIRED POSTPARTUM
STERILIZATION. APPLE BECAUSE OF
RESTRICTED HOSPITAL POLICY I
HAVEN'T UNINTENDED PREGNANCY
WITHIN ONE YEAR. EVERYONE
DESERVES ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST
QUALITY OF CARE WHICH IS NOT
GOING TO FUTURE THE DC CARE IN
WHICH WE GIVE LEICESTER CARE TO
UNDERSERVED PATIENTS AND WE
SHOULD NOT PUT OUR YOUTH THE
CLINICIANS AND TRAINEES IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY ARE FORCED
TO PROVIDE SUBSTANDARD CARE
SHE- ASKED SB THREE SEVEN NINE
TO ENSURE YOU SEE REMAIN TRUE
TO OUR VALUES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANNOUNCED BRING ON MADDY.
ON THE LINE. ANY ANY YES PLEASE
BEGAN. HELLO CARE AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NOT IN ON THE TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
LIFETIME CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
BORN AND RAISED IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY IN JULY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AFTER SPENDING OVER
FOUR HOURS WAITING IN CRIPPLING
PAIN IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM HM
HOSPITAL THE ONLY E. ARE
WORRIED THAT THEY WOULD
DISCOVER THAT I WAS PREGNANT.
AFTER EVEN MORE. OUR OF TESTING.
AND PRODDING MY DOCTORS
DETERMINED THAT I HAD SEVERE
INTERNAL BLEEDING CAUSED BY A
RUPTURED ECTOPIC PREGNANCY AND
WOULD REQUIRE EMERGENCY
SURGERY. BUT THEN I CONTINUE TO
WAIT. ONLY AFTER HOURS IN
DELAYS WHEN IT BECAME EVIDENT
THAT MY CONDITION WAS RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING THE ABLE TO GET A
LIFESAVING CARE THAT NEED. THE
NEXT DAY WALKED PROCESS THE
TRAUMA I UNDERWENT. SURGERY I
ALSO MY SURGERY HAD BEEN
DELAYED ESPECIALLY I HAVE BEEN
TOLD THAT IT WOULD MERGING.
ONLY THEN DID I LEARN THAT
ACCORDING THANK JOSEPH TALK
POLICY SURGERY WAS CONSIDERED
AN ABORTION. IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT DESPITE THE FACT THAT MY
RECORD THE LOOKING INTO PUBLIC
HOURS AND INTERNAL BLEEDING AND
PAIN. I KIND CONSERVE KERR WITH
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED DUE DUE
TO THE RESTRICTIVE POLICIES THE
THING JUST. CALL MY EXPERIENCE
WAS FAR MORE TERRIFYING PAINFUL
AND TRAUMATIZING THAN ANYONE.
IN MY SITUATION SHOULD HAVE.
BUT I LEARNED THAT OTHER ABOUT
SIMILAR EXPERIENCE WE CAN
RECONNECT AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE INCLUDING ABORTION
IS A RIGHT. NOT A LUXURY
RESERVED FOR THOSE LUCKY ENOUGH
TO LIVE IN AN AREA WITH
MULTIPLE HEALTH CARE OPTIONS. I
LIKE SHOULDN'T BE PUT AT RISK
BECAUSE OF A HOSPITAL'S
NONMEDICAL IDEOLOGICAL
RESTRICTIONS. AND THE STANDARD
OF CARE I RECEIVED SHOULDN'T
DEPEND ON WHETHER I LIVE IN
HUMBOLDT- LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I'MTHANKFUL THAT I WAS
ALTERNATELY GIVEN THE TREATMENT
I NEEDED BUT ESSENTIAL RECORD
REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE WILL NOT AND
SHOULD NOT BE TOO LATE. THE
BILL I'M HERE TO SUPPORT TODAY
IS BEING OPPOSED BY THE VERY
SAME HOSPITAL. HARPER
RESTRICTION LIKE MUCH MATIC
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE IN
DANGER. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WORLD RENOWNED FOR
ITS LEADERSHIP AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTHCARE SHOULD NOT PROJECTED
PROVIDER CITY KIND OF HARMFUL
RESTRICTIONS. I IMPLORE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
AND ENSURE EQUITABLE INCLUSIVE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL WHO SEEK
CARE FROM YOU. SEE PROVIDER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. WELL NOW ON TO ADDITION
WITNESSES AND SO. SB THREE
SEVENTEEN. AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
BEGIN OF THE PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NO IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
IN LATE IN GERMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR S.
B. THREE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE SEVEN NINE. AND AT
THIS TIME SURE- WE DO HAVE
LOOKS A MORE THAN THIRTY IN THE
QUEUE. HEY. SO I'M I'M JUST
GONNA SAY- THIS IS WE'VE DONE
WITH OTHER BILLS-IT WELL GIVE
ESSENTIALLY TOTAL FIFTEEN
MINUTES AND OF COURSE GIVE THE
OPPOSITION THE SAME AMOUNT FOR
THE- IN ADDITION- ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AND IF YOU WERE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY- THEN PLEASE
GO TO OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND TO ENTER YOUR
TESTIMONY THERE AND AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY FOR
THE- FOR THE TESTIMONY RIGHT
NOW SO. PLEASE MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE WITNESSES.
ABSOLUTELY WILL START WITH
NUMBER NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YOU WHAT. REPUBLICANS ON THE
PATIENT BOTH UC DAVIS AND UC SS
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT LINE GOOD BYE.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
YES CLEAN PALETTE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT WE NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER LAWRENCE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT WE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I'M A TEACHER MEMBERS KATHY
BROWN OFTEN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
TIME. NIX'S NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA COSPONSORED
THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS CAN
MUSTER COMEY HAPPEN AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE THREE SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. TEXAS NUMBER ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MOLLY RICKS AND WHAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXUS ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN MEMBERS DIED APRIL AT THE
FD W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK EXTRA
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TENURE COACH OF THE LAST BEHALF
OF URGE YOU NOT TO REPRODUCTIVE
AND GENDER EQUITY INSTRUCTS THE
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SYMBOL
THE RAMA WHAT THE VITAMIN GROUP
ON BEHALF OF COMPASSION AND
CHOICES ACTION NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXUS NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JACKI TURN ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANKS TO NUMBER
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LEVINE TRAINING EARLY ABORTION
FOR COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. TEXAS NUMBER ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHANNON OLIVERI HOPING TO
RECORD NEW ROUTE BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA A PRACTICE SPONSORED
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE STRONG
SUPPORT IN THE ON BEHALF OF
BOYS BUT THE PROGRESS. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON EMILY ACABAR ON
BEHALF OF THE FEMINIST MAJORITY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. J. J. JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. SIX OF NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS CATHERINE CALLING AND
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
ADVOCATES FOR LOW INCOME HEALTH
CARE ACCESS. JOHN THE COURT
ITSELF THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. NEXUS NUMBER
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOME
OF THE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REMEMBER
BACK IN PERSON I'M ECS ACT IN
KOREAN- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS%
MEREDITH JOHNSON I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA AND ALSO A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. TEXAS NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DOCTOR BACK IN
JACKSON I'M A PROFESSOR AND THE
ASSOCIATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
THE OBGYN RESIDENCY AT UCSF AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO NUMBER
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BRIDGET CALLAHAN
N. ON BEHALF OF MEDICAL
STUDENTS FOR CHOICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS FOX OF
COLTON I'M A MEMBER OF THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY PROGRESSES AND
WE ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. THANKS TO BE
NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SALIM THAT
IN COURT I NEED DALY GRADUATE
STUDENTS AND A MEMBER OF NARAL
PRO CHOICE AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT WE NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CAITLYN THE SPARK
THAT I'M A MEDICAL STUDENT USED.
FROM A SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. MIXES NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS READILY AT YOUR AREA
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT UCLA
IMPARTED TO YOU SEE COALITION
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS ONE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS JULIA CAN LAW STUDENT AT UC
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVEN
FRIDAY ON BEHALF OF THAT STATIC
LEGAL SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO NUMBER ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO RAVEN
PATTERSON A PHD P.
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU- ACTUALLY WHERE
AN SB THREE SEVENTY NINE. NEXT
LINE. THE NEXT WE NUMBER ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
NASA TELLING I MEAN IF YOU DO
POLLUTION IN CALLING IN THE
SONG SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA.
SEA LIGHT IN THE VISIBLE AS
WELL. AS THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN.
THANK YOU THANK LINE. ACTUALLY
NUMBER ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DEBBIE
PALICKI AND I'M THAT CONCERNED
CITIZEN LIKE ONE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS
NUMBER ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CATALINA
MCDONALD I'M A STAFF MEMBER AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN MOVED ON THE COURT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. TEXAS
NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MADE YOU CAN. I'M HERE
REALLY HERE AT HOME I WANTED TO
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. EIGHT YOU
CAN. WILL MOVE TO ONE SO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD- THIS IS
ISABEL'S STORY- REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE THIRTY THREE AND- A
FORMER YOU SEE HEALTHCARE-
PATIENTS STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS
NUMBER ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
MARKET BUCKLEY IS AT THE
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY LOOKS
LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF THE Q. X.
LINE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE- PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR- WILL NOW
MOVES TO THE OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TO- WITNESSES WELL ONE
TECHNICALLY IN OPPOSITION THE
OTHER ONE CONCERNS BUT NOT
OPPOSITION BUT I THINK WHEN YOU
SAY CONCERNS THAT'S NOT SUPPORT
SO. WE WILL BRING ON SHELLY
SINCLAIR FROM DIGNITY HEALTH
AND- DR CARRIE BYINGTON FROM
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA EACH
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES- TO SPEAK
SO WE CAN BRING THEM ON THE
LINE AND WE'LL START WITH THE
ACTUALLY SCHLENKER FROM DIGNITY
HEALTH. THE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON SALLY SLINGER WITH
DIGNITY HEALTH. SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE WILL NOT EXPAND
ACCESS TO CARE. HE WILL END
PARTNERSHIPS THAT SAVE LIVES.
IT UNDERMINES RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THAT TRAIN DOCTORS TO
PRACTICE TO THE FULL SCOPE OF
THEIR SPECIALTIES. AND SERVE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. DEVASTATED
A MEDIC CAL SAFETY NET WHICH IS
A LIFELINE FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THERE ARE
MANY MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT FAITH
BASED PROVIDERS AND I'M HERE TO
REPLACE THEM WITH THE BACK.
DIGNITY HEALTH SERVICES
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
ETHNICITY INCOME IMMIGRATION
STATUS SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
GENDER IDENTITY WE CARE FOR THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY IN MANY
WAYS INCLUDING THAT ST FRANCIS
GENDER INSTITUTE THAT SERVES
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND WE HAVE ALWAYS
DELIVERED EXCEPTIONAL CARE TO
CALIFORNIA'S MINORITY AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. WE DO NOT
PROVIDE ELECTIVE STERILIZATION
OR ELECTIVE ABORTIONS BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY RESPECT THE RIGHTS
OF OUR PATIENTS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
PHYSICIANS AND REFERRED THEM TO
OTHER PROVIDERS IT IS A SERVICE
WE DO NOT PROVIDE. AND WE WILL
ALWAYS ACT IMMEDIATELY AND
PROVIDE ANY NECESSARY SERVICE
TO PROTECT THE LIVES OF OUR
PATIENTS WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
NOTHING IN THREE SEVENTY NINE
EXPANDS ACCESS TO CARE FOR
WOMEN LGBTQ PLUS CALIFORNIANS
OR ANYONE ELSE. ELIMINATING UC
PARTNERSHIPS ARE HARMS
PHYSICIAN RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
AND HEALTH SERVICES IN EVERY
DISTRICT. UNDER SEC. THREE
SEVENTY NINE NO ONE WINS AND
EVERYONE LOSES PLEASE VOTE NO
TO PROTECT ACCESS EQUITY AND
QUALITY HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S BRING ON- DR CARRIE
BYINGTON FROM UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR CARRIE BYINGTON
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SYSTEMS I
JOIN YOU TODAY TO SHARE THE
UNIVERSITY CONCERN TECHNICIAN
ON SB THREE SEVENTY NINE. I
THANK BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR FOR ENGAGING DIRECTLY
WITH YOU SEE. YOU SEE HEALTH IS
AN ACADEMIC HEALTH SYSTEM
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF ALL PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AT SUCH WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ELIMINATING
DISCRIMINATION EXPANDING ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CARE AND
ENSURING PERSONAL HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS REMAIN IN THE HANDS
OF PATIENTS AND THEIR
PROVIDERS. THE UNIVERSITY IS
OPPOSED TO THE USE OF NON
MEDICAL POLICIES TO DETERMINE
PROPER CARE. AGE RESTRICTIONS
ARE IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH MY
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A PHYSICIAN
AND AS THE LEADER OF YOU SEE
HEALTH. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
PROHIBITING YOU SEE THE
FILIATION WITH POLICY BASED
APOLOGY RESTRICTED INSTITUTION
WILL NOT CHANGE THE PRACTICES.
CERTAINLY NO PERSON WILL
RECEIVE MORE CARE OR BETTER
CARE IF OUR DELINEATIONS ARE
DISCONTINUED. TO THE CONTRARY
LOW INCOME AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WILL HAVE LESS ACCESS TO CARE
WE BELIEVE THIS IS UNFAIR IN
SOME INSTANCES WILL BE LIFE
THREATENING AND EXACERBATES
HEALTH DISPARITIES. ENGAGEMENT
RATHER THAN ISOLATION OFFERS
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
CARE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT RELY ON
YOU SEE AS A SAFETY NET. IF
YOU'RE TAKING A NUMBER OF
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS THE GOAL OF
THE AUTHOR WE HAVE AMENDED OUR
CONTRACT WITH POLICY RESTRICTED
PROVIDERS TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
OUR PHYSICIANS AND TRAINEES ARE
PROTECTED IN THEIR ABILITY TO
ADVICE PRESCRIBE REFER AND KEEP
ACTIVE AND EMERGENCY WE HAVE
REAFFIRMED THAT OUR PROVIDERS
CAN ACT CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT AND THE
WISHES OF THEIR PATIENTS. THERE
IS NO GAG ORDER. WRESTLER
CONCERN AT THE THREE SAN NINE
NOT IN PUBLIC HEALTH WE CANNOT
ABANDON THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PATIENTS AND FAMILIES IN
SEVENTY SEVEN LOCATIONS WITH
NON FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS ACROSS
THE STATE. THE BLACK THE PAN ON
A HIGH QUALITY CARE YOU SEE
PROVIDE. ACCURATE BANKS
BENEDICT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE AGAIN IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
AND LATER GERMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. S. B. THREE
SEVEN NINE. AND AT THIS TIME WE
DO OF ABOUT FOURTEEN IN THE
QUEUE OKAY PLEASE BEGIN. HEY WE
WILL START WITH NUMBER ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
THE CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE AND
PEACH THE PRIVATE DENTAL
PRACTICE COMMUNITY HOSPITALS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
SIX OF THE NUMBER ONE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY
FINISHED FOURTH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXUS NUMBER TWO OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ROBERT BYRD I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH PRO LIFE SENTENCES GO AND
OPPOSED THIS BILL AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MERRY MARDI
SIMONCELLI MEDICINE PHYSICIANS-
AND PLAYED AT UCLAHEALTH AND
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS SERIOUS
CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL. THANK
YOU EXLINE. NEXUS NUMBER ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CLICK ABOUT PLAN AN
ALUMNI OF UC BERKELEY AND I PUT
THE BILL. THANK YOU EXLINE.
NEXUS NUMBER SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS DOCTOR DR A
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AND THE
CARDIOLOGISTS TREATING PATIENTS
SHARING SERIOUS CONCERNS OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT WE
NUMBER ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NATHAN J.
BROWER ON BEHALF OF PROTECTORS
ENDING THE EXPLOITATION OF
WOMEN AND A MEMBER OF THE
RETURNS FOR LIFE. SACRAMENTO
VALLEY CHAPTER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO NUMBER
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FINALLY A TOWNHOUSE PIANO WORKS
OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXUS NUMBER ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ARJUN ALREADY I'M A FOURTH YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU EXLINE.
NEXT TO NUMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN
TESTING AND THEN IMPLEMENTING
ON BEHALF OF THE GREATER
RIVERSIDE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
SIX OF THE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRIGHAM WILLIS I AM A GRADUATE
OF UCLA AND YET THE BY PRESS TO
PEDIATRICS AND DINNER SO SHOULD
BE IN A MEDICAL EDUCATION AT UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY TWO. ZERO AND THE
JENNIFER GRANT ROSA CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND ACTUALLY COMPARED
TO THE COLOR STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE BILL AS IT STANDS RIGHT
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE NEXT
TO BE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME'S
JEREMY WHITE I'M A LIFELONG
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA TEACHERI
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. WHEN I GO
TO NUMBER NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THE
CALIFORNIA HELLO ASIAN IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU EXLINE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERESA
BECAUSE ANAK ATHEIST DEMOCRAT
LGBTQ I A ALLY AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR LIFE HERE
FRANCISCO IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU EXLINE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU-
THEY'LL BRING IT BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS CENTER GROVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CENTERING KERN COUNTY MERCY
MEMORIAL HOSPITALS HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMPREHENSIVE BLOOD AND CANCER
CENTER WHICH IS THE ONLY CANCER
CENTER IN THE ENTIRE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT PARTICIPATES IN
CLINICAL TRIALS. THROUGH THE
UCLA CANCER CENTER- THREE UCLA
CANCER CENTER PROGRAM- MY
CONSTITUENTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE STATE I'M RELY ON
THIS PARTNERSHIP TO GET ACCESS
TO INNOVATIVE CLINICAL TRIALS.
I'M CONCERNED AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT YOUR BILL WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR MAKING KIDS
CONSTITUENTS IN THE
CONSTITUENTS WITHIN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO GET THIS CANCER CARE.
BECAUSE IT LIMITS THEIR- ACCESS
TO FACILITY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
OTHER LOCATIONS- CAN YOU TELL
ME HOW YOU THINK THAT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH A
PREDOMINATELY LATINO
POPULATION- AND- BASICALLY FROM
NORTHERN STOCKTON ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO ALMOST THE- GREAT FINE.
HOW THIS IS GOING TO BENEFIT OF
THE CONSTITUENTS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IF THIS BILL PASSES AND
MERCY MEMORIAL HOSPITAL'S
DON'T. HAVE ACCESS TO THE UC'S
AND STUDENTS. FOR INTERNSHIPS
AND- NOT INTERNSHIPS BUT FOR
RESIDENCIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. EARLIER THIS YEAR. THE
BLEEDING DIRECTOR AND- THE WHAT
WOULD YOU GO AHEAD SPEAKER. SO
IT SOUNDS REALLY DISTORTED YEAH
THERE'S A LITTLE FEEDBACK GOING
ON JUST NEED TO SPEAK CLOSELY
INTO THE MARK FROM THREE OKAY
FOR A BETTER I THINK THAT'S
BETTER OKAY. I'LL DO THAT-
DIGITAL PEOPLE DON'T USUALLY
ASK ANY OF OUR ASPEN GOT SOFTER
BUT I'LL GET LOUDER- THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION OF CENTER
GROVE. TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR ON
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
AND AFFILIATIONS. I ACKNOWLEDGE
WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AFFILIATIONS ARE ARE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR YOU SEE TO
BE ABLE TO EXPAND ACCESS. THIS
IS NOT ABOUT ENDING
AFFILIATIONS ON WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT IS UC NOT HAVING
AFFILIATION CONTRACTS.
LITERALLY PROHIBIT YOU SEE
POSITION TO AT SARAH FROM
PERFORMING CARE THAT THEY THINK
IS NECESSARY. FOR THEIR
PATIENTS. AND SO THE SOLUTION.
IS FOR THOSE CONTRACTS NOT TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF UC
PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE CENTRAL
VALLEY RESIDENTS WITH ALL
APPROPRIATE CARE IT IS NOT IN
THE INTERESTS OF ANYONE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OR ELSEWHERE. TO
GO AND SEE YOUR PHYSICIAN YOUR
UC POSITION. AND THAT POSITION
IS LIMITED IN THE KIND OF CARE
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE TO YOU
THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE. AND
DOT DOT IS WHAT HARMS ACCESS.
TO CARE AND SO IF YOU ARE SET
FOR EXAMPLE- A RESIDENT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN YOUR WOMAN
WHO'S HAVING A C. SECTION AND
YOU WANT TO HAVE A TUBAL
LIGATION. IN CONNECTION WITH
THAT C. SECTION. RIGHT NOW YOUR
UC PHYSICIAN MAY HAVE TO
PERFORM THE C. SECTION. RENDON
FINISHER NINE CLOSE YOU OUT.
AND THEN SEND YOU SOMEWHERE
ELSE TO HAVE A SECOND SURGERY
TO DO THE TUBAL LIGATION WHICH
IS VERY VERY HARMFUL TO A
PATIENT INCREASE RISKS. AND NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
HEALTHCARE AND YET THAT IS
WHAT. THE UC IS FORCING ITS
PHYSICIANS TO DO BY ENTERING
INTO THESE RESTRICTED
AFFILIATIONS SO THAT IS THE
SOLUTION. AND. SO I'VE BEEN TO
A COUPLE HOSPITALS NOT ALL
HOSPITALS FAITH BASED OR NOT
FAITH BASED HOSPITALS OR NOT
PROVIDE ALL THE SAME MEDICAL
SERVICES DOES YOUR BILL REQUIRE
OTHER HOSPITALS TO TAKE ON THE
SERVICES THAT YOUR BILL WOULD
SHUT DOWN IN THESE FAITH BASED
HOSPITALS. IT SEEMS- NOT
EQUITABLE IF OTHER HOSPITALS
THAT THE THAT DON'T PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT THESE- THESE
FAITH BASED OR CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE HOSPITALS PROVIDE- IF
THEY'RE NOT ROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES IT'S KIND OF A AND
COUNTER ARGUMENT TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU KNOW THESE HOSPITALS
PROVIDE EXTENSIVE SERVICES AND
CANCER TREATMENTS CANCER AND
CLINICAL TRIALS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND IF OTHER HOSPITALS IN
THE STATE THAT ARE NOT FAITH
BASED. DON'T PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES IT'S KIND OF COUNTER.
PRODUCTIVE TO THIS BILL IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SHUT DOWN THE
FACILITIES THAT DO PROVIDE THIS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A- WHAT THEY
CONSIDER I THINK A AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF A. I HAVE I
DON'T SEE RULES BUT AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
UNDERSTANDING OF CONSCIENCE I
GUESS- AND SO IT DOES THE BILL
REQUIRE OTHER HOSPITALS TO
PROVIDE THE SAME SERVICES THAT
ARE IN THESE OTHER HOW THE
FAITH BASED HOSPITALS THAT SO
CARE IS CONSISTENT AND WE DON'T
LOSE. ALL THE CARE THAT WE GET
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ON
DISPUTE DURING THE PROMISE THAT
THIS IS GONNA- BECAUSE CENTRAL
VALLEY PATIENTS TO LOSE THEIR
CARE. THE BILL ON REQUIRES DOES
NOT SHUT DOWN ANY FACILITIES.
IT IS NOT PREVENT AFFILIATIONS
FROM HAPPENING. IT SIMPLY
PROVIDES THE UC PHYSICIAN OR
OTHER PROVIDER. ON NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE CARE THAT
THEY THINK. IS APPROPRIATE AND
NOT LITERALLY HAVE YOUR TO I
MEAN IF YOU IMAGINE GOING TO
YOUR DOCTOR AND THE DOCTOR
SAYS. I THINK THAT THIS
PROCEDURE WOULD BENEFIT YOU. I
THINK THAT THIS TREE WILL
BENEFIT YOU. BUT BECAUSE THESE
SCIENCE BASED RESTRICTIONS.
BECAUSE OF THESE POLICY BASED
RESEARCH AND I'M NOT ALLOWED TO
PROVIDE IT TO YOU YOU HAVE TO
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE. BUT THEY TRY
TO FIND SOMEWHERE ELSE TO GET
IT DONE. DOT DOT SINCE IT'S IS
NOT APPROPRIATE AND THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS THAT
THIS ISN'T ABOUT. TELLING
HOSPITALS WHAT WHAT SERVICES
THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE OR NOT
PROVIDE IT'S SAYING THAT IF THE
UC. IT'S GOING TO AFFILIATE.
AND BASICALLY PARTNER WITH
ANOTHER HOSPITAL TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE TO YOU SEE PATIENTS.
THEN THOSE UC PHYSICIANS OR
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEIR OWN MEDICAL JUDGMENT
ABOUT WHAT HEALTH CARE IS
APPROPRIATE AND NOT HAVE THEIR-THOSE DECISIONS MADE FOR THEM.
pNOTHING TO DO WITH CLINICAL
JUDGMENT. I REALIZE THAT YOUR
BILL DOESN'T SAY THAT YOU
AUTOMATICALLY SHUT DOWN THESE
HOSPITALS BUT YOUR BILL DOES
SAY THAT- YOU SEE. THAT
PHYSICIANS WOULD BEGIN CONTRACT
WITH YOU SEE YOU CEASE TO HAVE
YOU SEE. A HOSPITAL FACILITIES
SO NOT HAVING THOSE FACILITIES
ARE NOT HAVING THOSE PHYSICIANS
AVAILABLE FOR AND- RESIDENCIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHEN MOST
OF THESE- MOST OF THE SERVICES
IN THESE FAITH BASED HOSPITALS
ARE LED AND RAN BY UC
PHYSICIANS. WOULD EVENTUALLY I
MEAN I REALIZE THAT YOUR BILL
DOESN'T SAY DIRECTLY SHUT THEM
DOWN BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PHYSICIANS ON STAFF TO RUN
THESE PROGRAMS SO THE PEOPLE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE ACCESS
TO CARE- AND THEN IT DOES
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN OUR
HOSPITALS ARE SIT DOWN SERVICE
AT LEAST WE WOULDN'T BUILD
PROVIDE SERVICES. TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS BECAUSE THE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS WOULDN'T BE
THERE AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE KERRIER HOLDING OVER THEIR
HEAD IS THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO GET YOU SEE QUALIFIED
MEDICAL PROVIDERS IF YOU
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN A PLACE
OF CONSCIOUS. IN MY COLLEAGUES
THAT I SURE THIS KERN COUNTY
WITH SENATOR HER TADO HAS
AUTHORIZED A NUMBER OFBILLS
THAT ACCESS TO SHORTAGE OF
PROVIDERS THAT WE HAVE FOR CARE
SO THAT PEOPLE GET QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE. IN YOUR BILL
LIMITS THAT ACCESS TREMENDOUSLY
WHETHER IT DOES DIRECTLY OR
NDIRECTLY. THESE AND FAITH
BASED FACILITIES ARE THE SPACE
SPACE HOSPITALS WHO TREAT
EVERYBODY EQUITABLY AND THEY
PROVIDE EXCELLENT QUALITY OF
CARE TO THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY ALLOW- NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR CANCER
TREATMENTS IN CLINICAL TRIALS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT LIKE A
PREFERENCE IN THE BEGINNING OF
MY COMMENTS. IT'STHE ONLY ONE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT DOES
IT SO IT DOES LIMIT SERVICE IN
CARE AND- A MEDICAL SERVICES TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH AGAIN ARE
A LARGE POPULATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES WE HAVE THE
LARGEST. A FARMWORKER
POPULATION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH THE FIVE TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
WORLD. THEIR HEALTHCARE WOULD
BE LIMITED WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ADVENTIST HEALTH DIGNITY HEALTH
YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT ARE EXPANDING. AND NOT
HAVING ACCESS. TO THOSE
POSITIONS FROM THE UC'S CENTER
TO DO THEIR INTERN. OR STEAMY
THE- RESIDENCIES AT A HOUSE
THAT LEE. TO OF THE- MOST GREW.
TECH THAT WE HAVE. OUR CONSIDER.
WOULD BE- ON. DECK AFFECTED
INDIAN CENTRAL VALLEY- I DO
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT-
HOSPITALS THAT DON'T PROVIDE
CANCER TREATMENT OR SOME
HOSPITALS DON'T PROVIDE
EXTENSIVE TRAUMA CARE THEY
DON'T HAVE A- OF VALLEY FEVER
CENTER AND NONE OF THOSE YOU
KNOW THAT'S IT IN THE HOSPITALS
AROUND THE STATE NONE OF THEM
PROVIDE THAT KIND OF EQUITABLE
CARE. TO INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
THAT CARE IT'S ALL PROVIDED IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- AND I KNOW
THERE'S CANCER TREATMENT
FACILITIES IN TRAUMA FACILITIES
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE I'M
NOT SAYING THAT- I JUST THINK
THAT. YOUR FRANKLY I'M JUST
YOUR BILL IS SHORT SIGHTED WITH
THE FACT THAT YOU WANT TO FORCE
THESE FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE ABORTION AND
STERILIZATION SERVICES. TO
EVERYBODY WHO WALKS IN THE DOOR
WHEN THERE'S A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ON EVERY CORNER. AND
WHICH BASICALLY IS AVAILABLE TO
ANYONE AND EVERYONE WHO WANTS
IT AND IT'S TOTALLY TAXPAYER
FUNDED- THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE- THAT COMPLETELY. EVIDENT
THAT THAT'S- YOU KNOW THE GOAL
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
IT'S- YOU'RE JUST GONNA LIMIT
ACCESS AND THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
THIS FAITH COMMUNITY THAT
DOESN'T PROVIDE THE SERVICES-
OF CONSCIENCE THAT YOU THINK
AND YOU WANT TO IMPOSE WHAT YOU
THINK AND WHAT YOU WANT- ON
THESE HOSPITALS WHEN THESE
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
ELSEWHERE AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT IN ORDER TO FURTHER THAT
AGENDA YOU WERE GOING TO LIMIT
EXTENSIVELY LIMIT. HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. NOW YOU MAY HAVE THESE
GREAT PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO GO
IN SAN FRANCISCO. BUT THERE
ARE- A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE IN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THEY DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE
TRANSPORTATION. TO DRIVE UP TO
SAN FRANCISCO THEY CAN'T TAKE
THE TIME OFF WORK TO DRIVE TO
UCLA- IN OTHER LOCATIONS TO GET
THIS TREATMENT. AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
AGAINST THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WE
GROW ALL YOUR FOOD. AND WE
PRODUCE ABOUT 70% YOUR ENERGY.
AND FOR YOU TO PASS A PIECEOF
LEGISLATION AGAIN THAT AFFECTS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN SUCH A
DRAMATIC WAY TO LIMIT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR OUR RESIDENTS
IS. BEYOND ME I WISH SHE WOULD
FOCUS ON SAN FRANCISCO BILLS
THAT AFFECT AND PROMOTE SAN
FRANCISCO INSTEAD OF ATTACKING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND ITS
RESIDENTS. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE- CENTER GONZALEZ. YES
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO
ACTUALLY THINK- THE SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IT IS IN MY
OPINION ABOUT HEALTH EQUITY AND
HAVING YOU KNOW I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH WHERE WE
HAVE A VERY LARGE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY VERY VERY SENSITIVE
TO THE ISSUES IN THE NEEDS AND-
MANY OF OUR TRANSGENDER
CONSTITUENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
AND THAT'S THE- GIST OF THIS
BILL I'M HAPPY TO CO AUTHOR. I
WILL SAY THOUGH THAT THERE ARE-
I HAVE DIGNITY HEALTH IN MY
BACKYARD AND I HAVE A GREAT
DIGNITY HEALTH THE LONG BEACH
BECAUSE THEY OFFER SOME OF THE
BEST LGBT Q. KERR- AND HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED BY THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN FOUNDATION SO
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
INSTITUTIONS ALTHOUGH IT IS ST
MARY'S. DIGNITY HEALTH- STILL
PROVIDES INCREDIBLE SERVICE TO
THESE COMMUNITIES AND- I CAN
SEE CONTINUING TO PARTNER IN
THIS SENSE AND NOT LIMITING
ACCESS TO FOLKS THAT NEED IT
THE MOST SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND ALL- BE HAPPY
TO. MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER CHAIR
OKAY THANK YOU THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SERRA GONZALEZ TO
PREPARE TIME- ACTUALLY TADO AND
THEN FOLLOW THE CENTER RAS TO
AT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OPEN TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT'S MY
UNDER THAT THE FOR HE IS A P.
UNIVERSITY. CALIFORNIA QUITE
FRANKLY IN THE CENTER VALLEY.
WE HAVE ONE YOU SEE. WE HAVE
WHEN YOU SEE CAMPUS AND IT
DOESN'T HAVE A MEDICAL SCHOOL
ONE DAY AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE.
HOLDEN- BUT- INSTITUTES AT THE
YOU KNOW ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PROVIDING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM
AN OPPORTUNITY- TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE BY HOLD
THE- OUR OUR INSTITUTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE AND- AND I AM HAPPY
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
I'M AND I THINK THERE'S LKE I
SAID. THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE BY HOLDING
INSTITUTIONS ACCOUNTABLE HAPPY
TO SUPPORTER AND WOULD LOVE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU.
CETERA THANK YOU MISTER YOU
KNOW THIS IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. FRANKLY AN
ISSUE. THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND PERHAPS THE
EFFORTS TO OR THE FACT THAT
IT'S BEING ADDRESSED NOW.
PERHAPS SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE.
BY QUITE SOME TIME AGO. WE DO
HAVE A RATHER UNIQUE SITUATION
WITH THE MEDICAL SCHOOL. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE AND I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY. THANK THE AUTHOR
THE AUTHORS STAFF. THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH- WORKING
THROUGH THOSE RATHER UNIQUE
ISSUES AND- COMING UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT- WHILE YOU SEE
ARE IN THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
WILL MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL. GIVES YOU SEE ARE IN
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE A LITTLE
EXTRA TIME. SINCE WE DO NOT
HAVE A HOSPITAL. ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT MEDICAL SCHOOL GIVES
YOU SEE ARE IN THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. A JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO COMPLY AND DO SO.
SO THANK YOU BOTH I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. THE
OTHER ANY OTHER- CENTER AT. BUT
I THINK YOU AND THANK YOU TO
OTHER- BUT I ALSO REALIZE IN OF
THIS IS AND- AND WE BE SUPPORT
IT TODAY BUT AS OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE STATE I'LL HAVE
A ARE. FOR COUNTY HOSPITAL HAS
AFFILIATE WITH THE WITH USE-
AND I KNOW A COMMERCE GO ON
RIGHT NOW A WITH JOSEPH'S IN IN
JOAQUIN. AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE- ACCOUNTHAAS- AND SO. WE
WILL EVERYONE HAVE ALL THE CARE
THEY- BUT WE ALSO WANT ME VERY
AREFUL THAT WE'RE CUT OFF. TO
BE HEALTH CARE. IN DESIST THAT
PROVIDE- SO MUCH SO MANY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES SIR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK TO THE
AUTHOR- HAVING THE COURAGE TO
BRING THIS FORWARD I YOU KNOW I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BUTLER THERE'S A LOT OF PHAM.
CONCERN ONE READY EITHER I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THE OTHER
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
TRY TO WORK THESE ISSUES OUT
AND WITH THAT AGAIN I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL MOVE IT IF
WHEN APPROPRIATE THINKS I
SHOULD BELIEVE IT'S VERY BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GONZALEZ BUT
THANK YOU- BUT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS. OKAY.
NINE- SO SIR WIENER AYE IT
MONTH FOR OF ALL THANK FOR WHAT.
WITH ME IN MY COMMITTEE- I AND
YEAH THAT. THIS BILL IS CHAO.
FOR YES CERTAINLY WE CONCERNED
ABOUT- PEOPLE BE ABLE TO. CARE
BUT THAT CUTS BOTH WAYS WITH
THE BILL RIGHT NOW- BY OF THE
MAJOR. IS NO YOU DON'T WANT YOU
SEE SAYS. AND OTHER HEALTH FOR.
GOING TO AND- SQUARE TO CANNOT
BASIC PRACTICE THE OF. THAT
THIS IS EXPECTED OF THEM THAT
THEY CANNOT- PRACTICE. FIELD
PROVIDE ALL THE OPTIONS TO- THE
PATIENCE OF THE PATIENT SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT- I APPRECIATE THAT
UC'S OF THESE TAKEN SOME
INITIAL STEPS- WITH-
ESSENTIALLY. BEING SURE THAT
OUR CONTRACTORS AND A GAG
CLAUSE BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND I
THINK THAT- GOOD. HI ACTUALLY
HOPE- I KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE
TO YEARS AWAY WITH THE OUT I
GOT CALL IN YOU SEE. TO HAVE A-
WITH YOU AND YOURS THIS OF THIS
BILL IN TERMS OF WHAT
COMMITMENTS THEY'RE WILLING TO
MAKE. IN CONTRACTS MOVING
FORWARD. AND AS WELL AS
EXISTING CONTRACTS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF NOT
LIMITING. YOU SEE PHYSICIANS
AND HEALTH PROFESSIONALS FOR
FROM FAILED TO PROVIDE THE CARE
THAT THEY BELIEVE IS BEST FOR
THE PATIENTS. BECAUSE THAT
SENDS A WRONG SIGNAL CERTAINLY
I'M YOU KNOW I'M A FORMER UC
PHYSICIAN I- SEE. RESIDENCY
PROGRAM- WE NEED TO TEACH OUR
WE TEACH OUR RESIDENTS ABOUT
ADVOCACY AND IMPORTANCE OF.
ADVOCATING FOR PATIENTS. AND O
WHAT KIND OF LESSON DO WE SEND
WHEN WE TELL THEM WELL YOU CAN
NAVIGATE TO YOUR PATIENTS BUT
WHEN AN INSTITUTION DENIES WHAT
YOU BELIEVE IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENTS. YOU
ARE BASICALLY TOLD TO. TURN
AWAY AND NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT CARE. AND SAME WITH STAFF
MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE MODEL
THAT. SO WHO'S BEEN CERTAINLY
THIS IS A CHALLENGING ISSUE-
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR.
YOU SEE TO. DEMONSTRATE THROUGH
ITS CONTRACTS THE VALUES THAT
OF THE INSTITUTION THAT IT
DOESN'T RESTRICTS MEMBERS OF
ITS OWN FACULTY AND ITS OWN
TRAINEES FROM PROVIDING THE
MATTER WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND IF THAT CONTRACT IS
UNACCEPTABLE TO THAT HOSPITAL
THE HOSPITAL THAT'S AFFILIATING
AND IT'S A HOSPITAL THAT'S NINE
CARE TO THEIR PATIENTS. WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE OF THAT
REFUSES ACCEPT THIS KIND OF
PROVISIONS. SO WITH THAT I URGE
YOU TO TIRED YOU BY AUTHORS
OTHER PEOPLE TO WORK WITH YOU
ET'S TRY TO COME TO A
RESOLUTION- BUT WE NEED TO ALSO
THINK ABOUT THE ROLE EACH OF
THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
PLAY. IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO CARE IN
EVERY PART OF THE STATE. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE WANT TO TRY TO
ACHIEVE. SO WITH THAT. SENATOR
WE KNOW WHICH IS LIKE CLOSE. I
THANK YOU FOR THOSE REALLY-
ELOQUENT AND ON POINT COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I AGREE
WITH YOU WHOLEHEARTEDLY. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
PERSONALLY INVESTED TIME AND AS
I. INDICATED TO YOU- I AM- I
AM- YOU KNOW. WILL BE THRILLED
FOR YOU TO CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED IF YOU HAVE TIME.
BECAUSE WE COULD REALLY USE
YOUR YOUR- JUST EXPERIENCE ON
THIS ISSUE WORKING WITH US
GOING FORWARD- I WANT TO BE
REALLY REALLY CLEAR ABOUT.
SOMETHING WE DID NOT THIS IS
NOT A THE BILL WHERE WE WOKE UP
ONE MORNING. AND SAID WE'RE MAD
ABOUT THESE AFFILIATIONS. OF
LET'S DO A BILL. RIGHT THE HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS. FOR
YEARS. AND WE DO NOT THINK WE
WOULD EVER HAVE TO DO A BILL WE
DON'T WANT TO DO A BILL. FOR
YEARS THE UC COMMUNITY. WAS
WORKING PHYSICIAN'S AND
STUDENTS THAT WERE REALLY IT'S
VERY LOT OF STUFF SETTING
TROUBLING TO THEM THE UC AGREES
TO THESE RESTRICTIONS. THERE
WAS A BAY WERE ADVOCATING WITH
AND GAUGING AND WORKGROUPS AND
DOING ALL SORTS OF WORK FOR
YEARS TO TRY TO GET YOU SEE. TO
MAKE A CHANGE YOU SEE FINALLY
GOT RID OF THE GAG RULE AND I
THAT'S GOOD BUT CAN YOU IMAGINE
UNTIL LAST YEAR. YOU SEE
PHYSICIANS COULDN'T. EVEN TELL
THEIR PATIENTS. YOU MIGHT GO TO
THE DOWN THE STREET. TO GET A
TO BELOW. THEY COULDN'T EVEN
THAT WOULD BE A VIOLATION OF
AFFILIATION AGREEMENTS UNTIL
LAST YEAR THEY FIX THAT
THANKFULLY BUT THAT'S ONLY STEP
ONE. I HAVE PERSONALLY MET
PRESIDENT REAGAN I WOULD BECOME
ZOOM BUDDIES WE'VE BEEN
REGULARLY MEETING ON JUNE WE'RE
AND WE'RE WORKING EXTENSIVELY
WITH UC AND UC WAS SUPPOSED TO
BRING THIS ISSUE TO THE REGENTS
IN MARCH IT DIDN'T HAPPEN. I
DON'T KNOW WHEN IT WILL HAPPEN
BUT THE CONCERN IS THAT THIS
CANCERS GIFTS CAN YOU SEE JUST
KEEPS KICKING IT DOWN THE ROAD
AND NOT WANTING TO DEAL WITH
THAT AND WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IF WE DON'T STEP IN AND SET
STANDARDS. IS THAT FIVE TEN
YEARS FROM NOW. IT'S GOING TO
BE A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF YOU SEE PATIENTS AND
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE RESTRICTED
BY THESE NON SCIENCE BASED
RESTRICTIONS ON CARE. IT IS
TIME FOR US TO STEP IN AND SET
STANDARDS. FONG I WON SAID IN A
NOTE CENTER GROVE'S AFTER SHE
MADE THOSE RATHER INFLAMMATORY
REMARKS AROUND SAN FRANCISCO
WITH A LOT OF INACCURACIES- AS
LEFT I HOPE SHE WILL. THE TAPE
OF I WOULD SAY IF YOU'RE
SITTING RIGHT HERE. THAT COULD
NOT BE FROM THE TRUTH. WE TO
THINK. THAT THIS BILL WILL SHUT
DOWN. HOSPITALS BAGHDAD IS.
CERTAINLY FALL. AND THOSE COSTS
IF THEY WANT TO CONTINUE HAVE
YOU SEE POSITION COME IN WHICH
I WANT YOU SEE AGO THERE. THEY
TOOK THE CONTRACT NOT. THE USE
POSITION THEY DON'T HAVE TO
THEIR OWN POWER. FOR OWN FOR
AND BUT THE USE PHYSICIAN.
THESE PA CAL EMPLOYEES CANNOT
BE REACHED- AND KNOW THIS IS
NOT ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO THIS IS
NOT ABOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S ABOUT FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO CARE. NO
MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE NO
MATTER WHO THEY ARE. WHETHER
PEOPLE LIKE THEM OR DON'T LIKE
FOUND EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS CARE WE NEED TO FIGURE
THIS OUT AND MAKE SURE WE CAN
HAVE AFFILIATION AGREEMENTS
THAT COMPLY. WITH YOU SEE AN
CALIFORNIA VALUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SIX THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER- DEMOS THIS BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SERICA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSING REFER TO COMMITTEE
OF. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL PAN HI CAN I AM MELINDA'S
LINDA'S NO EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
SALAS HI AND SALAS I GROWTH HER
TIE. RETARDED LEAVE. LEYVA I.
ROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE.
THE ROLES. FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL. BY MYSELF BUT MY JOINT
AUTHORS IS- SENATOR KAMLAGER SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW THAT- I ALSO LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCING COMMON
NINETEEN OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR TO FURTHER REFINE THE
LANGUAGE I WANT TO. APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF WORK TO DO AND I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED AS WELL AS I TO GET
IT DONE AND SO THANK YOU. WE
BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE WILL ALSO
HELP ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY HEALTH ACCESS AS
WELL AND I THINK THEY'RE GONNA
SAY SOMETHING TODAY TO THAT
EFFECT SB TWO TOO FAR FOR TWO
TO FIVE WILL PROTECT W. TO
FREELANCE COMMON LAW TV
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION EMPLOYEES
FROM LOSING THEIR EXISTING.
HEALTH CARE A NO COST INSURANCE
RESULTING FROM A RECENT CHANGE
IN THE LAW THE EMPLOYERS PAY
THE INSURANCE WHICH IS RARE AND
VOLUNTARY AND REALLY MAKES THIS
PLAN. WORK FOR THIS GROUP OF-
CALIFORNIANS FREELANCE
EMPLOYMENT IS THE BACKBONE OF
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY'S
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES BECAUSE
FREELANCE FILMING CREWS ARE
HIRED ON A PROJECT BY PROJECT
BASIS MAY HAVE DOZENS OF
DIFFERENT PRODUCTION COMPANY
EMPLOYERS OVER COURSE OF THE
YEAR THEY HAVE NO MEANS TO
QUALIFY FOR REGULAR EMPLOYER
BENEFIT PLANS TO FILL THIS VOID
THE PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFITS
PLAN. A FULLY INSURED EMPLOYER
SPONSORED HEALTH PLAN WHICH
FORM PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
HEALTH BENEFITS AT NO COST TO
THE NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA W. TO
COMMON LAW EMPLOYEES OF THE
TELEVISION COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY HOWEVER DUE
TO A RECENT ENACTED LEGISLATION
THESE FREELANCERS ARE NOW IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING THIS
INSURANCE. SB TWO FIVE FIVE
WILL PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING BY ALLOWING THE P. H.
B. B. N. ONLY PHP BE TO
CONTINUE OFFERING THEIR
INSURANCE BUT ONLY IF IT MEETS
THE HIGH STANDARDS THAT THE NEW
LAW WAS INTENDED TO POLLS SB
TWO FIVE FIVE DOES NOT PASS
THESE EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
DEPENDENTS WILL LOSE THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE. WHICH IS NOW
VOLUNTARILY PAID BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS AND WILL BE FORCED TO
REPLACE IT WITH A SELF PAID
INDIVIDUAL COVERAGE AT A MUCH
HIGHER COST THAN THE EMPLOYERS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE A IN. LARGE
GROUP. AND I RESPECTFULLY. THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND ON THE PHONE I
HAVE SHOWN COOLEY. WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFIT
PROGRAM. AND BONNIE GOLDFARB
THE OWNER OF A BOUTIQUE
PRODUCTION COMPANY. AND A
COMMISSIONER ON THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION. IMPORTANT TO
MENTION AS WELL BEFORE I GO TO
MY TWO WITNESSES. THAT THE CREW
HAVE THEIR HEALTH BENEFITS PAID
FOR BY THEIR GUILDS. THIS IS A
SMALL SUBSET OF THE COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRY. THAT WOULD BE DENIED
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IF WE WERE
NOT TO PASS THIS BILL WHERE THE
CREW WOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE SO
THERE'S AN EQUITY ISSUE AS
WELL. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTING PLEASE GO TO MY TWO
WITNESSES. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINE TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEAN
COOLEY FROM PRODUCERS HEALTH
BENEFIT PLAN AND BONNIE
GOLDFARB- WITH THE-
COMMISSIONER ON CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION. MAKE NOTE THAT EACH
OF YOU HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES SO- MR
COOLEY IF YOU GO OVER THAT
TAKES AWAY FROM. FUNNY
GOLDFARB'S TIME- IF. YOU CAN
BRING THE MINE AND WE'LL START
WITH JOHN COOLEY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
SB TWO FIFTY FIVE MY NAME IS
SEAN COOLEY AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFITS PLAN
THE BILL'S SPONSOR. BOB WHAT'S
YOUR CHOICE BY OUR ACRONYM PHD
P. HE WAS STARTED AS A WAY FOR
EMPLOYERS AND THE TV COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
HELP AND ATTEMPTS TO THEIR FULL
TIME W. TWO FREELANCE EMPLOYEES
OTHERWISE NOT ELIGIBLE. FOR
EMPLOYER HEALTH PLAN. IT'S TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE PROVIDED FOR
HIGH. HEALTH COVERAGE AND
CURRENTLY IN SHORT TWELVE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA FREELANCERS.
WHILE PARTICIPATION IN THE
PRELIMS PROGRAM IS MANDATORY OF
ALL OF OUR TWO HUNDRED PLUS
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS.
OPTIONAL NON FREELANCE STAFF
COVERAGE IS AVAILABLE OF WHICH
38% OF OUR EMPLOYERS
PARTICIPATE. 70% OF OUR TOTAL
COVERED EMPLOYEES ARE
FREELANCERS. PGP INVALUABLE NOT
ONLY TO THE LIVES OF THESE
FREELANCERS BUT I BELIEVE TO
THE STATE AS WELL. FOR EXAMPLE
WITHIN A WEEK OF THE GOVERNOR'S
STATE HOME ORDERS THE PLAN
IMPLEMENTED A SERIES OF COPING
NINETEEN RELIEF MEASURES.
EXTENDING COVERAGE PERIOD FROM
TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN MONTHS
DURATIONS TO ENSURE NO ONE LOST
COVERAGE DUE TO THE INDUSTRY
SHUTDOWN CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC. WE WAIVED ALL OUT OF
POCKET FEES WHICH IS ALREADY
HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED
DEPENDENCIES. AND ISSUED A 20%
DISCOUNT ON ALL COBRA PREMIUMS
FROM APRIL FIRST THROUGH THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY. IF ANYONE
LOST COVERAGE IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS AFTER THE EXPIRATION OF
THE RELIEF MEASURES WE
SUBSIDIZE THEIR COCA PREMIUMS
BY ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. BECAUSE
IT HEALTHY RESERVES INCLUDING
GOVERNANCE THE PLAN WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE A LIFESAVING FINANCIAL
SAFETY NET TO ALL OF OUR
COVERED PROFESSORS AT NO COST
TO THE STATE. THIS EXAMPLE OF
OUR COMMUNITY TAKING CARE OF
ITSELF IS TYPICAL OF THE PHD P.
STORY. THERE'S NO SCENARIO IN
WHICH THE WORKER OR FOR THAT
MATTER THE EMPLOYER OR THE ONE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA. BENEFITTED THESE
FREELANCERS ARE FORCED TO
FAXING FORCED TO THE OPEN
MARKET TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
FOR. INSURANCE THE EMPLOYER IS
WILLING TO PROVIDE AND HAS
PROVIDED FOR FREE. FOR THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS HI- YOUR SUPPORT.
FIVE AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
LETS ME ON TO. A BUNGLED. THANK
YOU MISTER AND OF THE CREW- MY
NAY IS BONNIE CALLED I AM THE
OWNER OF. FILM AND A LOT BASED
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION COMPANY A
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER AND THE
PRODUCERS HEALTH BENEFIT PLAN
AND A BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION. I
AM A SECOND GENERATION
CALIFORNIAN NATIVE I AM THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GRADUATE
COLLEGE I ATTENDED UCSB. I
DON'T EMPLOYER AND A FORMER
FREELANCER I'VE SEEN THE MOST
POSITIVE IMPACT.
THIS PRODUCERS
HEALTH BENEFIT PLANETARIUMS. WE
HAVE THE BEST CRUISE IN THE
WORLD AND ONE OF OUR MAIN
CHALLENGES INCLUDES OTHER STATE
TRYING TO BUY FOR THE ANNUAL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
WE SPEND IN CALIFORNIA. ON
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION EACH YEAR
WE REALLY CANNOT RISK FORCING
OUR FREELANCE EMPLOYEES TO THE
OPEN MARKET TO REPLACE THEIR
CURRENT EMPLOYER FUNDED HEALTH
PLANS. A THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
AFFORD IT AND THOSE INCREASED
COSTS ARE GONNA BE PASSED ON TO
OUR CLIENTS WHICH WILL RESULT.
IN MORE PRODUCTION HEADING OUT
OF STATE. PHD P. AND DURING THE
RIGHT THING BY PERCOLATE
PROVIDING EMPLOYER PAID HEALTH
CARE TO COMMERCIAL FREELANCERS
IN PRODUCTION THAT REALLY
MATTERS I URGE YOU TO PASS SB
TWO FIVE FIVE TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS LIKE ME CAN CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT AND PROVIDE. FREE
EMPLOYER PAID HIGH QUALITY
HEALTH COVERAGE TO THE
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION
INDUSTRIES AMAZING FREELANCERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIVE FIVE AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
BEGAN PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ON A
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. SINGLE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. TWO FIVE
FIVE AGAIN IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
HENLEY IN GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE.
ENSURE WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT IN OUR QUEUE OKAY PLEASE
BEGIN. IT WILL BEGIN WITH
NUMBER TWO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CALAMP NOT JAIL I'M A P.
H. B. P. PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FIVE FIVE THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MATT MILLER ON MAY
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
COMMERCIAL PRODUCERS AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT
IS GOING TO BE NUMBER TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS GENDER COLOGNE I
REPRESENT ANOTHER PHD P.
pJUST CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT AT S. B. TWO
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SUE
ELLEN CLAIRE AND I AM ALSO A
PHD P. PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER
CALLING TO VOICE MY SUPPORT OF
BILL TWO FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER TWO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JASON
GROCERY MARKET LANCE PRODUCER
AND PARTICIPATING MEMBER OF PH
TV IN STRONG FAVOR S. B. THANKS.
THANK YOU SIGN. NEXT TWO TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS RACHEL I'M AT PH P. COVER
THREE ONE I NAMES PART OF AN
THE FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT TO THE NUMBER
TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO RAVEN PATTER I CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE PHD P.
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYER AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MODERATOR NOW WILL MOVE
TO THE WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES WILL BE
TESTIFYING LEAD OPPOSITION WE
HAVE YASMIN POLLUTED WITH THE
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND
FAITH FORGES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH WRITERS- AND OKAY AND
THOSE ARE THE TWO WHO ARE
SHOULD BE TESTIFYING AT BRETT
DAVIS THE ANSWER QUESTIONS
ONLY- SOAKING PLEASE. BRING A
YES MAN TO LEAD- AND SAFE FOR
JUST TO THE PHONE LINES AND
AGAIN TWO MINUTES APIECE
MAXIMUM FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN
BOTH OF YOU- AND- SO IF- HASN'T
PLAYED MUCH WHICH IS TO BEGIN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS YES
MEAN PILOTS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION. WE
ARE HERE TODAY REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FIFTY FIVE
WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE AUTHOR SPONSOR
AND COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THE AMENDMENTS. SB TWO FIFTY
FIVE WITH A GOOD EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS AND THE TELEVISION
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION INDUSTRY
FROM EXISTING LAW ON
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS. IN
THE SMALL GROUP INSURANCE
MARKET. THIS PART OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS
CHARACTERIZED BY SHORT TERM
EMPLOYMENT OFTEN A MATTER OF A
FEW WEEKS OR MONTHS. WELL HELP
ACCESS AS OPPOSED TO
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN BECAUSE
THEY LACKED BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. AND UNDERMINE. THE
SMALL GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET. WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR I HAVE
WORKED WITH US TO NARROW THE
BILL AND ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT
OTHER GROUPS AND INDUSTRIES MAY
ATTEMPT TO GET EXEMPTION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LAW. AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN THE
FUTURE. TAKING TODAY WILL
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS IN THE
TELEVISION COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY WILL HAVE
COVERAGE THROUGH AN ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS HAVE IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. INCLUDING
GUARANTEED COVERAGE REGARDLESS
OF PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS OR
HEALTH STATUS. COVERAGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS AND COVERAGE UNDER THE
COULD LEAD TO AT LEAST A
PLATINUM PLAN. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE MOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S BRING
ON FAITH FORTY SO I GUESS THAT
REALLY KIND OF OPPOSITION THAT
REALLY OPPOSITION BUT OKAY FOR
JUST FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STATE BORDERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS. THE LARGEST
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
INSURANCE AGENTS BROKERS AND
PROFESSIONAL. YOUR TO
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE TWO FIFTY FIVE AS IN
FRENCH HOWEVER LET ME BEGIN BY
EXPRESSING OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE THE SPONSORS.
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
GRACIOUSLY WORKING WITH US TO
FOR NAVIGATING ACHIEVING THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE OF MEETING
UNIQUE INDUSTRY NEEDS. AND OF
HOLDING HARD FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND H. P. REFORM.
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
AND EMPLOYERS HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE. QUALITY HEALTH
CARE ABOUT THE PORTABLE. WE
DIDN'T REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPERATOR WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
THE THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE. AND FEEL CONFIDENT
IT'S A BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN PRINT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
BILL'S AMENDED AND REMAIN
COMMITTED TO PARTNERING WITH
THE AUTHOR. I CAN'T COMMENDABLE
EFFORTS TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE. FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL CONSIDERED NFL AND
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WITH ME
ON THE LINE AND CALL THE
PRESIDENT ELECT AN INSURANCE
AGENT BRAD DAVIS WHO'S
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS SHOULD
THEY ARISE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
RIGHT THE SERVER L. MOVE ON TO
WITH AND ARE TO THIS BILL- AT
THE END ITS NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY THAT'S SB TWO
FIVE FIVE OPPOSITION WILL START
THE PUBLIC GALLERY SAYING NO IN
THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO
WITNESSES WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB TWO FIVE FIVE
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
AND LATER GERMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION SB. TWO FIVE
FIVE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN OUR QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR
LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY YES
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I AND I DO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD HI TO ME IT'S
REALLY CLEAR THAT THIS IS A
VERY NARROW BILL FOCUSED ON AN
INDUSTRY THAT'S PRETTY UNUSUAL-
YOU KNOW AS DISCUSS FROM SOME
OF THE SPEAKERS- WORK CAN BE
PROJECT TO PROJECT TEMPORARY
HOWEVER THIS NARAL BUILD
TAILORED TO THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY BRINGS HEALTH CARE
STABILITY. AND WHEN I HEAR
FREE- EMPLOYER PAID HEALTH CARE
TEN ME- IT'S IMPORTANT AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRY AND I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE WORK THE
AUTHOR DID TO REALLY TRYIN AND
NARROW IT AND MAKE A VERY
SPECIFIC TO THIS INDUSTRY AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT- OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT'S
ONE OF THE SPEAKERS SPOKE. UP
WANTING THE SAME THING BUT I
THINK IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE IT WORKS FOR THIS
INDUSTRY AND I WOULD ALSO BE
HAPPY TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT- CENTER. FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF. I
KNOW THAT HERE- AND SENATE
WE'VE WORKED VERY HARD TO
ENSURE THAT- PEOPLE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE HAVE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THEY NEED TO AND-
YOU CORPORATE INTO THE BILL-
JUST MORE BROADLY I KNOW WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
ROLE OF ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS AND HOW THEY CAN
UNDERMINE. THE MARKETER
DESTABILIZE THE MARKET I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT THIS PARTICULAR
PLAN WAS IN EXISTENCE BEFORE
THE ACA AND FORTUNATELY I THINK
THERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF
PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN SUBSEQUENT
TO THE EIGHTY OR MORE DESIGNS
TO. SENSUALLY TAKE HEALTHIER
POPULATIONS MOVE OUT OF THE
MARKET WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY. BE
A PROBLEMATIC AND ACTUALLY
RAISE HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER OR WHO
HAVE CHRONIC DISEASE AND SO
FORTH SO WE WANT TO BE SURE WE
DIDN'T. CAUSE THAT TO HAPPEN SO
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TAKING THE AMENDMENTS SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THOSE
PROTECTIONS BOTH OF THE PEOPLE
ARE COVERED BY THIS PLAN BUT
ALSO FOR THE OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE MARKET. AS WELL THE SMALL
GROUP MARKET THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET AND SO FORTH. AND I
CAN'T PASS BUT THEY KNOW THAT
OUR INDIVIDUAL MARKET IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL WE ACTUALLY KEPT
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS BELOW 1%
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS AND-
MAYBE THIS NEXT YEAR WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THE SAME BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE
EVERYONE. IN THE MARKET SO THAT
SAID THAT'S WHY THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT TO WE
DON'T TO STABILIZE THE MARKET-
BUT WITH THAT AT CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN A
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AN
ACCOUNT YOU KNOW. THANK YOU DR
PAN AND I DO APPRECIATE. YOUR
INTEREST AND DILIGENCE ON THIS
AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL. BECAUSE
YOUR BIG PICTURE CONCERNS ARE
EXTREMELY VALID WE DON'T WANT
TO DISRUPT THE MARKET. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU RECOGNIZING THE
SPECIAL NATURE IN THE PRE
EXISTING NATURE OF THIS HEALTH
PLAN AND- APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD AS IT PROGRESSES TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU- IS THERE
A MOTION ON THE BILL. THE BILL
OKAY SIR RUBIO THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO'S MOVE THE BILL
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I AM. DE EGGMAN. BY EGGMAN
ARROGANCE. HI AND SO I'D- GROVE
I HEARD. I RETIRED AYE LEYVA HI
LEYVA I. ROTH HI ROTH AYE RUBIO.
HI RUBIO AYE WIN. WINNER I. SO
CURRENT LOTUS ZERO BUT THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU AND THEN NOW
LET'S MOVE TO YOUR BILL WE HAVE
ITEM FOUR S. B. SIXTY TWO-
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS SB FIVE
SIX TWO WILL ELIMINATE
SIGNIFICAN ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS
IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS THAT
ARE PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING A BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM OVERSEE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT EARLY
CAN SHOW REMARKABLE PROGRESS.
THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROFESSIONAL AND
PARA PROFESSIONAL TO ENSURE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE CITY
SIX TELL US THAT ONE IN FIFTY
NINE CHILDREN BORN TODAY ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO
HELPING THESE CHILDREN LIVE UP
TO THEIR POTENTIAL. AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IS
CRITICAL NOT ALL CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM ARE THE SAME THEY
RESPOND TO TREATMENT
DIFFERENTLY CHILDREN NEED
TREATMENT TAILORED TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS PRESCRIBED BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN OR PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO KNOWS THEM BEST NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL TREATMENT THAT
MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
CHILD. EIGHT YEARS AGO SB NINE
FORTY SIX PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM IT HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS BUT OTHERS HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED FROM RECEIVING
ITS BENEFITS BECAUSE OF
DRAFTING ERRORS IN ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS NOT EVERY CHILD IN THE
RECEIVING. COVERAGE FOR THE
TREATMENT THAT THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER PRESCRIBES THEM
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED EVIDENCE BASED CARE
THIS COVERAGE IS THIS IS
COVERAGE THEY OR THEIR
EMPLOYERS HAVE ALREADY PAID FOR
ME SAY THAT AGAIN. THIS
COVERAGE HAS BEEN PAID FOR ITS
JUST BEING DENIED. FOR THESE
PATIENTS BUT TO INTO
MEDICATIONS THE PARENTS OR THE
STATE ARE LEFT TO COVER THE
COSTS OUT OF POCKET FOR THIS
CRITICAL CARE ADDITIONALLY FOR
MANY CHILDREN THERE IS A. SIX
TO TWELVE MONTH WAITING LIST
FOR THE ONE FRIEDMAN THAT
HEALTHY. WILL COVER TREATMENT
DELAYED HIS TREATMENT DENIED IN
A DEVELOPING MIND. BY EXPANDING
THE TYPES OF QUALIFIED ALREADY
STIRRED CERTIFIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ELIGIBLE FOR
COVERAGE THIS BILL WILL BOTH
ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL SHORTAGES
AND ALLOW FOR CHILDREN TO
RECEIVE THE TREATMENT THEIR
PHYSICIAN HAS PRESCRIBED. THE
BILL WILL ALSO ADDRESS
ROADBLOCKS THE COVERAGE FOR
PATIENTS WHO FOR REASONS OF
WORK OR FAMILY PRESSURE CANNOT
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
CHILD'S THERAPY SESSIONS OR
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE RECEIVED
SERVICES AT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
DAY CARE SETTING. THE SISTER
WEEKS THE SITUATION SHOULD NOT
BE PRECLUDED FOR COVERAGE. FOR
MEDICALLY MCGANN MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENTS AND WITH
SB FIVE SIXTY TWO THEY WON'T. I
HAVE WITH ME HERE TO TAKE TO
TESTIFY JIM LANDRY FROM THE D.
I. R. COALITION OF CALIFORNIAN
ALISON FAINT A PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH AUTISM. AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE OF. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO. MODERATOR WE ARE
MOVING ON TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON TO THE LINE ARE TO LEAD
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY JIM LANTRY
FROM THE A. R. FLOOR TIME
COALITION AND ALISON FEIGN. A
PAIR CHILD WITH ASD. COULD
BRING THEM ON THE LINE AS A
MAKE NOTE THAT WE DO HAVE ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE LINE- JOHN
LEWIS FROM CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM PEOPLE
OF QUESTIONS REGARDING. THE TO
BURKE ANALYSIS- SO WE CAN BRING
OUR TWO WITNESSES A REMINDER
AGAIN IT'S TWO MINUTES APIECE
MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES I'LL
GIVE A TWO MINUTE SIGNAL YOU
GET TWO MINUTES. AND THEN- THEN
YOU'RE TAKING UP THE OTHER
PERSON'S TIME. SO LET'S START
WITH JIM LANDRY. THANK YOU
GERMANTOWN SENATORS SITES CHEN
WENT THROUGH THE D. R. FLOOR
TIME COALITION A CALIFORNIA
COALITION PARENTS WHO PROVIDERS
SEEKING CHOICE TREATMENT. ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM
DESERVE THE BEST DOCTOR OR
PSYCHOLOGIST PRESCRIBED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THEM RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT CHILDREN RECEIVE
TREATMENT EARLY RESPOND BETTER
AND RESEARCH SHOWS THE
TREATMENT TAILORED TO THE NEEDS-OF THE CHILD IS IMPORTANT AND
RESULTS IN THE CHILD ATTAINING
HIS OR HER POTENTIAL. NO TWO
CHILDREN ARE ALIKE OF THE
SENATOR SAID WHAT WORKS FOR ONE
CHILD MAY ACTUALLY BE HARMFUL
FOR ANOTHER SO IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT A CHILD RECEIVE THE
TREATMENT PRESCRIBED BY THE
CLINICIAN WHO KNOWS THE BEST.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
MENTAL HEALTH THIRTY ONE NINETY
NINE IT ANTICIPATED THAT AUTISM
WOULD BE TREATED IN THE SAME
MANNER AS PHYSICAL AILMENTS
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN. THE TWENTY
ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SB NINE FORTY SIX WHICH
MANDATED THAT ALL PRESCRIBE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY EVIDENCE
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENTS BE COVERED BY HEALTH
INSURANCE AND AGAIN
UNFORTUNATELY THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN WHAT DID HAPPEN IS THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS COVERED ONLY ONE
FORM. OF BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT
ABA. AND THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH A B. X. THAT. SOME CHILL
NEED. ELSE AS A RESULT PARENTS
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM PRESCRIBE
A DIFFERENT FORM OF TREATMENT
FOR FACED WITH THREE OPTIONS.
FIRST WAS TO PAY FOR THE
PRESCRIBED TREATMENT OUT OF
POCKET EVEN THOUGH THEY OR
THEIR EMPLOYERS AND ALREADY
PAID FOR THE COVERAGE. FOR MOST
PARENTS PARTICULARLY SINGLE
PARENTS OF LOW INCOME PARENTS
THIS OPTION WAS UNAFFORDABLE.
SECOND WAS DANCE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO PAY FOR THE
TREATMENT IN SOME CASES
OCCURRED CONTRARY TO
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF MINE
FORTY SENATE BILL NINE FORTY
SIX. IN THE THIRD OPTION WAS
SIMPLY TO ACCEPT THE ONE FORM
OF THERAPY THAT WHAT'S COVERED
EVEN THOUGH IT MIGHT NOT EVEN
BE IDEAL OR EVEN BE DETRIMENTAL
TO THE CHILD. IT ALSO RESULTED
IN A LONGER TERM CARE COST
EMAILS FROM HEALTH INSURANCE
CARRIER MORE MONEY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY COSTING THE CHILD
TIME CAN NEVER BE RECOVERED.
THIS BILL RECTIFY THAT WOULD
FINALLY ACHIEVE THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
BILL SB NINE FORTY SIX. ONE
POINT OUT THE QUALIFIEDAUTISM
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS THIS BILL
ADDS ARE ALREADY CLASSIFIED AS
MENTAL HEALTH. PROVIDERS. THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN SENATE BILL.
SO BILL EIGHT FIVE. LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS MENDED THE MENTAL
PARITY BILL. HUNDRED SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO THESE QUALIFIED
SUPERVISE PROFESSIONALS WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE COVER TREATMENT
A LOT MORE CHILDREN RECEIVE
THIS ESSENTIAL PREFERRED. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ALISON FAIN YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND FORTY SECONDS. THANK YOU-
MY NAME DOLPHIN THING IN I'M
THE MOTHER OF A FOUR YEAR OLD
BOY THAT WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
AUTISM- JUST BEFORE HE TURNED.
AFTER I WAS DIAGNOSED EIGHT
EIGHT WITH THE ONLY BE THERAPY
TREATMENT. FOR ACQUIRE. COMPANY
AND WE WERE FOR THIRTY FIVE
HOURS A WEEK. WE DID ABA FOR
OVER A YEAR AND TIME I WOULD
HAVE TO PEACEKEEPING DAYS-
AFFECTING. AND SEVEN DIFFERENT
RB. OR TOWARD THE BRIDGE
REGISTER BEHAVIOR. WORKING ONE
ON ONE BUT I AND- SOME WORK
BETTER MEN WERE NOT AND FOR- WE
NOTED VERY LITTLE IN. AND ALLOW
A- BUT ABOUT. AND I WOULD SAY
OVER. THE EXPERIENCE WHAT KIND
OF. I HAD A INCREASE THE AMOUNT.
BEHAVIOR INCLUDING INCREASED
YOUR- FEARS AND ACROSS AND- AN
INCREASE. AFFECTED BE. HE WOULD
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN AND NOT WE
ARE NOT DURING HIS SESSION.
SOMEBODY AND HE WAS RUNNING TO
A GROUP. EVERY TIME I WOULD
EVEN IF BUT THE- THAT MEANT
THERAPY WHICH I. I EVERY STEP
TO THE ANSWER COMPANY AND FOR
OTHER OPTION THAT WOULD
RECOMMEND IT EVIDENCE BASED
DEVELOPMENTAL. HERE IN FRONT.
WELL THE PAPER WE DID ALL THE
DOLLARS WE TO PAY. AND LOOK AT
LENGTH WITH THE FAIR THAT WOULD
BE WORKING LIFE AND- WE EXCITED
TO GET STARTED. WHEN INSURANCE
TONIGHT SERVICES AT THE LACK
MINUTE. THE REASON WE WERE
GIVEN BECAUSE WAS NO EPA OVER.
NOW IT TO BE A AT THE FED. AGE
EIGHT FOR BASIC WE WERE DID NOT.
BECAUSE THAT WAS ABA. THERAPY
SAID ONLY ABOUT CYCLE POWER I'M
NOT A WATER. I'M SORRY PLEASE
WRAP UP YOUR OUT OF YOUR TIME'S
UP. AND OKAY SO I'VE BEEN
PROGRESS IN THE PAST YEAR WITH
THE THERAPY IS NOTHING SHORT OF
MIRACULOUS HE HAS IMPROVED
REGULATION WHICH APPLIES TO
EMOTIONAL FUNCTION AND IMPROVED
ENGAGEMENT HIGHER LEVELS OF
LEARNING. THANK YOU I'VE BEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT-
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
ONLY AGAIN THIS IS SUPPORTIVE
SB FIVE SIXTY TO MOVE THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SAYING ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. C. KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SIXTY TWO. HENLEY IN
GERMANY ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT- SB. FIVE SIXTY TWO.
AND AT THIS TIME I DO SHOW WE
HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY
PLEASE BEGIN. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NOTHING THE MORNING CALIFORNIA
AND I HIGHLY THE BILL THANK YOU
THE NEXT LINE. THE NEW. ANYONE
CAN BE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU MODERATOR
NOW WILL MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES MODERATOR
SECOND PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE
LINE MELISSA CORTEZ FROM THE
CENTER FOR AUTISM RELATED
DISORDERS AND NYCLU RECESS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS. COME AGAIN TWO
MINUTES APIECE MAXIMO FOUR
MINUTES FOR BOTH WITNESSES
TOGETHER. SO PLEASE BEGIN WITH
MELISSA CORTEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MELISSA CORTEZ THE GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING THE
CENTER FOR AUTISM AND RELATED
DISORDERS. WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE CHANGE IN THE
DEFINITION OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT THAT IS IN THIS BILL.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COVERAGE FOR ALL EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS I WANT TO GO BACK
AND EXPLAIN HOW THE ORIGINAL
MANDATE WAS DRAFTED WHY IT WAS
DONE THAT WAY. AT THAT TIME
DAMAGE THE NGO I HAD SIGNED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH THEM
THE LARGE HEALTH PLANS SH IN
THOSE AGREEMENTS THE PLANT HAD
AGREED TO SPECIFICALLY COVER
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS. AND
THIS IS ONLY AFTER VERY LARGE
VOLUMES OF DENIAL ROUTINELY
OVERTURNED BY INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW. BUT THOSE
SETTLEMENT DIDN'T COVER ALL
PLANTS AND THEY REQUIRED
TREATMENT BY LICENSED
PROVIDERS. AND CALIFORNIA ABA
PROVIDERS ARE CERTIFIED BUT NOT
LICENSED BY THE STATE THE
LEGISLATION WAS NEEDED TO CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE. TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN THAT LAW WAS BEING DEBATED
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WHERE
THEY'RE ASKING THAT FLOOR SIGN
THE INCLUDED. THEY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT NOR WAS THERE
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE AT THAT
TIME TO SUPPORT MANDATED
COVERAGE. BUT THE LEGISLATURE
DID NOT WANT TO CLOSE THE DOOR
TO EMERGING MODALITIES AND
THAT'S WHY THAT BILL WAS
DRAFTED TO INCLUDE ALL OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS THIS MEANS. THAT IF
AND WHEN THERE'S ENOUGH
RESEARCH TO FIND THE AN
INTERVENTION IT'S EVIDENCE
BASED. IT IS COVERAGE THAT
WOULD NOT A DRAFTING ERROR. BUT
YOU'RE PER REPORT ON THIS BILL
STATE THAT THERE'S INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF RELATIONSHIP BASED
INTERVENTIONS. AND THE EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT MORE TIME SHEPHERD
SAID THE BASED ON UNCONTROLLED
STUDIES WITH SMALL SAMPLE SIZES
SO WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT
MANDATED COVERAGE. FOR UNPROVEN
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
COULD HAVE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS
IF KIDS ARE MOVED INTO LESS
EFFECTIVE OR INEFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS. SO THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ADA VERSUS FOR TIME THIS
IS ABOUT PRESERVING A STANDARD
OF CARE THAT IS BASED ON
SCIENCE AND RESEARCH FOR THAT
REASON WE ORIGINAL ABOUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW SPRING ON
NYCLU RECESS. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS. THANK YOU MISTER
SHE AND MEMBERS WITH WITH THE
CAL. SO HOW PLANS. I'M IN A- TO
FIVE TWO WHICH EXPANDS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COVERAGE IN A
MANNER. THAT DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE EXISTING MEDICAL
LITERATURE AND BEST PRACTICES.
HEALTH PLANS APPLY EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACHES TO COVERAGE
DECISIONS TO HELP INSURE
ENROLLEES RECEIVE THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME IN THE
RIGHT SETTING. THE UNDERLYING
FOUNDATION OF THIS APPROACH IS
THE SYSTEMIC OR SYSTEMATIC
REVIEW OF EVIDENCE BASED
METHODS TO TREATMENT. FOR
AUTISM SERVICES APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS OR ABA- IS
RECOGNIZED AS AN EVIDENCE BASED-TREATMENT BOB SO ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
AND ITS PREDECESSOR BILLS- THAT
HAVE BEEN VETOED IN THE PAST.
I'M IS THAT IT ESTABLISHES A
SUB STANDARD SET OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROVIDERS BY
ALLOWING NON EEA TRAIN
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
AUTISM CARE. THIS WILL DECREASE
THE QUALITY OF AUTISM CARE
BECAUSE WILL RESULT IN A
DIMINISHMENT OF EVIDENCE BASED
CARE PROVIDED TO CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM DURING CRITICAL
DEVELOPMENTAL YEARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ALSO
ELIMINATES THE ABILITY THE
HEALTH PLANS TO REVIEW THE
TREATMENT PLAN AND EVALUATE THE
LOCATION OF TREATMENTS. OR TO
ASSESS WHETHER PARENTAL
PARTICIPATION- IS- BEING
PROVIDED- YOU. COULD YOU WITH
THE SERVICE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT. BOTH OF THESE THINGS GO
AGAINST THE CLINICAL BEST
PRACTICES. AND BECAUSE BEST
PRACTICE RESEARCH HAS PROVEN
THAT CHILDREN HAVE A BETTER
RESPONSE ST TO TREATMENT. THAT
MASTER SKILLS BETTER IT
BEHAVIOR MODIFICATIONS ARE
CONSISTENTLY APPLIED BY PARENTS
OR GUARDIANS. SO FOR THE
REASONS STATED. AB IS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES-IN OPPOSITION AGAIN NAME
POSITION. NAME OR EXIST
POSITION ONLY BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE ALL THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE TO WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE SIXTY TWO AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE SIXTY TWO. AND AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE TO IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK PLEASE BEGIN. AND
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TWO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRUSTING YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
WATCHING BAMBI HAVEN'T THE
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANKS
LINE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON- COLLEGE RIGHT BUT WE
THIS IS A WHITE FIELD WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF HAD A LITTLE
DIFFICULTY GETTING ON THE LINE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
DISABILITY RIGHTS AND SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT A LITTLE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TWO SB. FIVE SIXTY
TWO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR HERE THANK YOU
MODERATOR OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY NOT SEE ANY MICROPHONES UP-
CENTER PORTANTINO- SO I WENT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES- AND BY WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT THIS YOU'VE POINTED
OUT THERE'S- THAT- WHATEVER-
THAT. CARE THE- RECEIVE THE
CHILD RECEIVES ACTUALLY HAS TO
BE- PROVIDED AT THE DIRECTION
ARE ACTUALLY- DESCRIPTION OR
DIRECTION OF REFERRAL BY
EXPOSITION OR PSYCHOLOGISTS SO
IT'S NOT A FREE FOR ALL- BUT
PERHAPS YOU CAN IT. BE TOUCH ON
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNED AT THIS IS NOT
EVIDENCE BASED IN YOUR CLOTHES
BUT CERTAINLY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU DR PAN AND
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THAT TO
THAT POINT. FRANKLY THERE WAS
ONE THING THAT THE OPPOSITION
SAID THAT I COMPLETELY AGREE-
THIS IS NOT A BATTLE BETWEEN
ABA AND FOR TIME. THE BILL
DOESN'T SPECIFY. THE TYPE OF
TREATMENT IT SPECIFIES A
QUALITY OF TREATMENT. THE
EVIDENCE BASED AGAIN MANY OF
THE COMMENTERS WERE TRYING TO
DEFINE WHAT THAT IS THIS BILL
DOESN'T DO THAT- THIS BILL SAYS
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT IS
ELIGIBLE. BY A DOCTOR'S
PRESCRIPTION AS THE CHAIR.
MENTIONED THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE KIDS. IT'S NOT ABOUT. THE
FIGHT BETWEEN PARTICULAR
TREATMENTS- AND AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE OPPOSITION. FRANKLY A
LARGE PORTION OF IT WAS THOSE
WHO ARE GOING TO PAY FOR THIS.
WELL THE FAMILIES PAY FOR THAT
HEALTH COVERAGE. THEIR KIDS GO
TO A DOCTOR AND THE DOCTOR WILL
DECIDE WHAT TREATMENT. IS BEST
FOR THAT KID. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS DOES SO. THIS BILLS PASSES
COMMITTEE BEFORE I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR. AS A SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE BILL. STOP OKAY MOVE BY
CENTER EGGMAN RIGHT SO THE
BILLS A MOVE I CENTER EGGMAN
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
I AM MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I GREW-
TADO FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LEE MON. ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO.
SUTTER ROLLS EIGHT ZERO BUT THE
BILL IN CALL THANK YOU SAN
FORTINO RIGHT WOULDN'T- SEE
SARAH STERN C. ON THE
PARTICIPANT LIST FOR THE
REMOTE- ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT TAX CENTER STERN OKAY
SO WE ARE WE'RE FIRST GOING TO
GO TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT'S
SB THREE FORTY- SIR STERN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. BEGIN I WOOD
MISTER SHARE THANK YOU SO MUCH-
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK TO IMPROVE THIS
BILL WITH MY TEAM- I'LL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- I FEEL THAT THE
STEPS TAKEN HERE TARGET THE
APPROACHING REALLY MAKE SURE
THERE'S APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS
TO MAKE THIS BILL STRONGER. AND
BETTER ACCESS TO THOSE
INTENDING TO PROTECT- THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT BRINGING BETTER
INFORMATION INTO THE
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS WHICH
IS A VERY SENSITIVE AND IT AND
SERIOUS PROCESS THAT- INVOLVES
THOSE WHO WERE AS SO GRAVELY
DISABLED THEY- OFTEN CANNOT
MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES-
THERE'S- OTHER LEGISLATION ALSO
PENDING THIS YEAR THAT I THINK.
WILL HOPEFULLY PASS AND WORK IN
CONCERT WITH THIS LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE-
SUBJECTED THE CONSERVATORSHIP
PROCESS OR- OTHERWISE- ENGAGED
IN IN THIS WORK WILL HAVE.
ACCESS TO THE BEST POSSIBLE
INFORMATION- BUT ALSO THAT
THERE REPRESENTATION WILL BE
INDEPENDENT THAT THERE WILL BE
ADEQUATE PROTECTION SO THAT-
THEY CAN ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES TO- WE'VE TRIED TO
BALANCE THE INTERESTS HERE. OF
BOTH THE CRITICAL CIVIL RIGHTS
OF THE OF THOSE WHO MAY BE
CONSERVANCIES AND THE SAME TIME
LOOKING OUT FOR THE HEALTH OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE OUT
THERE TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
MEDICAL CONDITION- ISN'T JUST
ASSESSED ON THE SPOT BY THOSE
THEY INTERACT WITH- THROUGH
THERE. CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS
BUT ALSO THAT THOSE WITH
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE ESPECIALLY
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEIR
CONDITION CAN I GET THAT INPUT
INTO THE PROCESS. AND IN SO
DOING- GIVE A MORE ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR MEDICAL
CONDITIONS SO I HAVE WITH ME
TEAR GAMBLE EASTMAN HERE THIS
TIME BURGUM INSTITUTE TO
TESTIFY. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I. BOATS OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER STERN AYE TO CLEAR HAVE
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- DR
SHARON FROM DEPARTMENTS. FROM
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AS WELL AS TERRY COMEAU
EASEMENT FROM STEINBERG
INSTITUTE ARE BOTH TESTIFYING I
THINK WE'VE ONLY GOT STEINBERG
INSTITUTE OKAY ALL RIGHT JUST
CLICK FIVE OKAY. YUP MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING TERRIBLE EASEMENT
FOR THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE ON
TO THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROTESTS MAY
SUPPORT SB. THREE FORTY.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE KARAGANDA EASTON ANALYTICS
FEINBERG INSTITUTE WE'RE AN
INDEPENDENT NON PROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE WHO FOCUSES TO
ADVANCE SOUND PUBLIC POLICY.
AND INSPIRED LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE THE BRAIN HEALTH AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB
THREE FORTY. I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ECHO SENATOR STERN IN
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR COLLABORATION. ON TODAY
THEN AND THEN. THE DECISION TO
INVOLUNTARY HOLE CONSERVE ORGAN
TREATMENT FOR SOMEONE IT'S
INCREDIBLY PROFOUND AND
CONSEQUENTIAL AND THIS DECISION
SHOULD BE MADE WITH GREAT CARE
AND ONLY OF AN OPTION OF LAST
RESORT. TO ENSURE INVOLUNTARY
CARE IS ONLY USED WHEN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY THE
DECISION SHOULD ALWAYS BE BASED
IN THE MOST ACCURATE. AND
HOLISTIC PICTURE OF A PERSON
AND THEIR ABILITY TO LIVE
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY. I
THANK THEIR STARS SPOKE TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE OFTEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THEIR
LOVED ONES CARE WITH MANY
SERVING ARE CARE TAKERS. UNLIKE
DOCTORS OR THE COOLEY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS CAN CONTEXTUALIZE
THAT PERSON CURRENT CONDITION.
AND I EXPLICITLY STATING THE
RIGHT PROGRAM WITH THEM A
FRIEND TO REQUEST TO BE GETTING
LPS HEARING SHOULD BE THREE
FORTY CREATE A CRITICAL
MECHANISM TO ENSURE ANY
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT IS WELL
TARGETED. AND APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST IN ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WELL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITION WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FOR- WILL BE ABLE
TO PUBLIC GALLERIES NOT PUBLIC
GALLERY WITH THE ROOM. FORTY
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO. WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. PLEASE ONLY IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FORTY. AND AT THIS
TIME I DO SHOW WE HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN.
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HANKER FOR
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. THEN WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT THE LION KING
CALIFORNIA A STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANKS LINE. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SO WILL THAT TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BEGIN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SINGLE PUBLIC
ALLEY LET'S MOVE TO RUN TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ONE TWENTY FORTY.
BUT THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE FORTY AGAIN NAME OR
EXIT A POSITION ONLY. AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THREE
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
YEAH ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO
SB. THREE FORTY. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR CHECKING
MODERATOR NOW LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU I'D
JUST LIKE TO. THAT THANK CENTER
WIENER THUNDERSTORMS BEING
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- THIS IS
A REALLY AS HE SAID A VERY
TOUCHY AREA BUT IT ONLY MAKES
SENSE A- FAMILY. THE FAMILY
SYSTEM IS OFTEN IMPACTED MOST
ALWAYS IMPACTED WITH THESE
THESE CASES AND TO ALLOW THE
ABILITY. IT'S VERY STRUCTURED
TO ALLOW FAMILIES TO TESTIFY
DURING THE HEARING MAKES GOOD
SENSE I THINK FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILY SYSTEM AT A SPECIALLY
THE THEM THE PERSON THAT SO I
WOULD MOVE THIS BILL TO PROTECT
OKAY TO BILLS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER EGGMAN APPROPRIATE TIME
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD HE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I WORKED
A LOT ON THAT IDT COMMUNITY-
BILLS IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND. I
FELL IN LOVE WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT AND- IT WAS SOMETIMES-
WITHOUT HELP FROM THEIR FAMILY
IT'S HARD FOR THEM TO MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISIONS OVER THEIR
LIVES BUT IN OTHER WAYS.
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO MAKE EVERY
DECISION OVER THERE LIKE THAT
THEY WANT THAT'S WHAT THE
LETTERMAN PICTURE SET SHORT
ACT. WAS ABOUT. AND I THINK
YOUR BILL STRIKES A VERY GOOD
BALANCE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU- IT'S NOT OFTEN I GET TO
SAY THAT SENATOR STERN TO PAY
YOUR BILLS BUT I'M EXCITED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. OKAY A
DATA QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. NAY NONE OF US ARE
STERN OF FIRST OF ALL IT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS BILL
FOR TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO. TO
TESTIFY AND SHARE IN FOR THE
PORT INFORMATION ALSO YOUR WORK
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS- FROM
THE COMMITTEE- SO CERTAINLY
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COLLOQUY- STATEMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS AND I WOULD JUST.
CLARIFY MY CLOTHES THAT- FOR
THOSE WHO DO HAVE. CONCERNS
ABOUT- THIS PROCESS OR THE OR
THE USE OF THIS EVIDENCE IS
WEAK HOPEFULLY GOING TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. AMENDMENTS YOUR
COMMITTEES HELPED US WITH HERE-
I THINK REALLY STRENGTHEN THE
BILL'S POSITIONING. AS
RECOGNIZING IS CRITICAL A CIVIL
RIGHTS AN INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
PROTECTIONS BY. BY ALLOWING THE
COUNCIL THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXCLUDE THAT TESTIMONY. IF IN
FACT- FAMILY OR THOSE WITH
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE A BRING
FORWARD TESTIMONY THAT WOULD BE
DUPLICATIVE. OR ABUSIVE. OR
FRANKLY IRRELEVANT THE COURT
NOT ONLY HAS DISCRETION NOW
UNDER THESE AMENDMENTS TO
EXCLUDE. AN ADMISSIBLE
TESTIMONY BUT ALSO THE COUNCIL
THEMSELVES. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY DID TO DECLINE IF
IT WOULD HAVE THAT. THAT KIND
OF ABUSE OF AFFECT ON THE
CONSERVATIVE SOI SINCERELY
APPRECIATE. THAT DOES THOSE
PROTECTIONS BEING ADDED IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER
STERN SO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON. JUDICIARY CONSULT
THESE CALL THE ROLL. SAN HI CAN
I. MULLIN EGGMAN FIVE EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ HI SALAS I GROWTH
HI GROUP BY HER TADO. LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE LIMON HI LIMONEIRA
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER I. SO THE
CURRENT- VOTE IS NINE ZERO FOR
THE BILL ON ALL LET'S MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE OH
EIGHT CENTER STERN I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU WISH TO JUST MAKE A
STATEMENT ABOUT THIS BILL AND
WE Y. FOR JUDY OPPORTUNITY SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
RIGHT I APPRECIATE. THIS BILL
WAS. IT IS INTENDED. TO BRING
THE PRIVATE INSURANCE.
COMPONENT OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
TO BEAR IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS.
AND TRY TO FIND MORE EFFICIENT
WAYS FOR- LEDS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND- EDUCATORS TO BE
A THE INTEGRATE AND LEVERAGE
SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH- IT
HEALTH CARE RESOURCES. AMONG
PRIVATE INSURERS- INTO OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT- WE RECOGNIZE
THE COMPLEXITY AND THE LONG
TERM IMPORTANCE OF THIS KIND OF
STRUCTURAL REFORM AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO ADD PRECIADO BUT THE-COMMITTEES DILIGENCE AND YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE MISTER
CHAIR- BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
WORKING OUT FOR INSTANCE A
CONTRACTING MODEL OR
REIMBURSEMENT MODEL ACROSS
MULTIPLE PLANS. IN MULTIPLE
TYPES OF DISTRICTS RURAL URBAN-
YOU KNOW LARGER DISTRICTS- OR
SMALLER DISTRICTS THERE'S A
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF
VARIABILITY IN EXPERIMENTATION
GOING ON RIGHT NOW FOR HOW TO
BETTER MERGE BOTH OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM EDUCATION SYSTEM SO
WE MAXIMIZE- THIS SERVICE TO
STUDENTS WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF TRAUMA OUT THERE AND WE KNOW
THAT TRAUMA INFORMED CARE.
REQUIRES CONSISTENCY THAT
RELATIONSHIP. WITH STUDENTS IN
THE TRUST THAT'S BUILT THERE
YOU CAN'T DO MENTAL HEALTH AND
PROPER TRAUMA CARE WITH
STUDENTS IF YOU'RE OPERATING IN
FITS AND STARTS SO- YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY I KNOW THERE'S
BUDGET ACTION UNDERWAY THIS
YEAR ON ON THE PUBLIC INSURANCE
SIDE OF IT ON THE MEDICARE
OUTSIDE. AND I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON THOSE ISSUES SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT THROUGH SOME
OF THAT WORK IN FLESHING OUT
THOSE OPPORTUNISM THE PUBLIC
SIDE BUT ALSO BY LOOKING AT HOW
WE CAN GET DH CS I'M MORE
FOCUSED ON REALLY MAKING-
FINDING MODELS THAT WORK. THEY
WORK WITH ARE REALLY AS AN
IMPLEMENTBILLS LIKE SB ONE OH
TWO FROM BACK IN ELEVEN THAT WE
CAN- MAKE SOME PROGRESS THIS
YEAR SO I AM. YOU KNOW I WANT
TO MAKE THIS INTO YOUR BILL SO
WE CAN- DO THAT WORK BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE URGENCY OF THIS ISSUE AND
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
TIME AND COMMITMENT TO IT ALL.
THANK YOU CENTERS STERN US OF
THIS WILL BE TO YOUR BILL SO WE
WON'T FURTHER HERE AT- TODAY
BUT- I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP CENTER STERN LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU I
KNOW MY STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF. I THINK WE'RE
NOT DO WE NEED TO TIME TO
REALLY DO IT RIGHTS AND
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THAT AND CERTAINLY WE WILL BE
CAN TO WORKING WITH YOU TO.
HOPEFULLY MAKE THAT HAPPEN IN
HAVE AFTER TO PURSUE YOUR BILL
AND YEAR. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY-
PLEASE PRESENT PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU TO SHARE MEMBERS-
THIS BILL DEALS WITH THE
NURSING HOME SECTOR AND FRANKLY
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND YOU THIS PANDEMIC.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE BOTH
THE QUALITY OF THE SERVICE THAT
WE BRING TO THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE OFTEN TIMES ALONE AT
THE END OF THEIR LIFE IN THEIR
MOST VULNERABLE. STATE AND
OFTEN SUFFERING INDIGNITIES AND
EXACERBATIONS OF HEALTH
IMPACTS- FROM THERE SETTING-
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S
TREMENDOUS WORK GOING ON IN THE
CARE ECONOMY AND OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS IN NURSING HOMES ACROSS
pPUTTING THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND THEIR HEART ON THE LINE
EVERY DAY TO HELP PEOPLE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT PUBLIC
DOLLARS GO TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT ON THE FRONT LINES THE
PEOPLE WORKING THE PEOPLE
RECEIVING THE CARE SO THIS BILL
IS REALLY AN EFFORT TO BUILD
MORE TRANSPARENCY ON THE BACK
END OF THIS SYSTEM. TO ENSURE
THAT- WE HAVE ADEQUATE DATA ON
EXACTLY HOW THE CORPORATE
STRUCTURES ON THE PRIVATE SIDE
OF THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
INDUSTRY ARE OPERATING WE KNOW
THERE'S SOME COMPLEX BUSINESS
MODELS OUT THERE THIS IS A VERY
LARGE INDUSTRY AT THE BALL
FRANKLY OF THIS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY INDUSTRY. IS RUN ON
THE PRIVATE SIDE IN THREE
QUARTERS A CARE IN THE STATE IS
DELIVERED THAT WAY AND THAT
THERE'S REALLY NOT AN ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT BOTH AT THE STATE
LEVEL AS WELL AS THE LOCAL
LEVEL- OF THIS OF THE FOR
PROFIT SIDE OF THE INDUSTRY I
WE KNOW THERE'S VERY GOOD WORK
GOING ON OUT THERE BUT WE KNOW
THERE'S ALSO- THE RISK. IN SOME
OF THESE CORPORATE STRUCTURES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
RELATED PARTIES- WHERE MULTIPLE
CORPORATE ENTITIES- MAY HAVE A
HOLDING OPERATE A SUPPLY
COMPANY ACTUALLY DELIVERING THE
CARE ALWAYS RELATED INJURIES
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THOSE TRANSACTIONS ARE MADE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
WE CAN BE SURE THE CARE IS
REALLY BEING DELIVERED. TO
WHERE IT NEEDS AND IS NEEDED
BOTH STE- THIS BILL IS- DEBT HE
REALLY DOESN'T. CHANGE
FUNDAMENTA THE STRUCTURE THE
INDUSTRY AND IT DOESN'T ATTEMPT
TO DO SO IT'S MUCH MORE SO
ABOUT BRINGING THAT DATA TO
LIGHT AND HOPEFULLY WITH A BIT
OF SUNLIGHT- WE CAN HAVE MORE
TRUST IN THE PLACES THAT WE
SEND OUR PARENTS AND OUR LOVE
ONES TOO AND THAT. SOMEDAY WE
OURSELVES WILL WILL END UP
THERE SO I CONSIDER THIS A DOWN
PAYMENT- ON- A MORE TRANSPARENT
MORE CARING AT A MORE HUMANE A
PATH TO AGING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN GET INTO SOME
OF THE DETAILS ARE LOOKS LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT WORK BUT I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK. WE CERTAINLY ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS- AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU ALL AS AS THIS LESSON
LEGISLATION MOVES TOWARD ALSO
WANT TO THANK THOUGH THEY THEY
HEALTH FACILITIES A GOOD FAITH
EFFORTS IN WORKING WITH THIS
YEAR THEY THEY REALLY COME TO
THE TABLE EARLY AND I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT WEEK WE CAN
TALK THROUGH SOME OF THE
DETAILS IN COMMUTER GOING
FORWARD BUT I. I WANT TO SEND
THE SIGNAL THAT WE'RE OPEN TO
CONTINUING- THOSE DISCUSSIONS I
THINK WE'VE MADE REALLY GOOD
PROGRESS THOUGH HERE WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS AND OTHER BILL JUST
SO YOU ALL KNOW WHAT DIVERSE
COALITION THE FRONTLINE WORKERS
IT AS HE ARE YOU WORKING IN
THIS SPACE AS WELL AS A R. P.
CALIFORNIA. ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM IN A WIDE
RANGE OF OTHER GROUPS SO IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE RIGHT I'M HAPPY TO
DEFER ABSENCE TO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES HERE TONY CHICKEN
TELL OVER WHICH THAT CANDOR AND
TIFFANY WHITTON WITH SCID.
THANK YOU SENATOR AGAIN YOU FOR
WITH AN EX THEM NOW LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESS AND SO OF SB SIX
FIFTY SO TO THE WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT APLEY MATER
PLEASE BRING THE AT THE TWO
WITNESSES UNTIL LINE UP. TOOK A
TELL FROM THE CAL SAYS.
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME. AND TO WHAT. FROM
THE FCA CAL. AND AGAIN FOR BOTH
WITH. TO MINUTES. MAY FOR
MINUTES BE THE TWO YOU- THANK
YOU A TWO MINUTE WARNING FOR
THE FOR WITNESS. SO YOU KNOW
YOU'RE IN TODAY OTHER YOUR E.
INTO THE OTHER PERSON TIME- SO.
BRING A FIRST ALL TONY TICKET
TELL. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IF YOU DON'T MIND THAT
I THINK ANYBODY IF YOU DON'T
MIND GOING FIRST OKAY TIFFANY
WINDS COME FIRST OKAY LET'S
BEGIN THEN WITH TIFFANY WHITEN.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE WITH A PEER. ON BEHALF
OF OUR OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
YEARS. SO WERE CONFRONTED BEST
EXPECT THE ECONOMY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR STAFF FOR
THE MANY CONVERSATIONS ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS IN THE BUILDING.
AS THE OTHER DIMINISH THURSDAY
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND OTHERS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY. IN
NURSING HOME. ONE THING THAT WE
DO KNOW THAT THE CALL AT
NINETEEN HUNDRED HAD TO CLOSE.
LOSS ARSENAL BRACKETS THAT. IN
AN EQUITABLE PROPER GERMAN
INDUSTRY AFFECTED PARTICIPANTS
SAFETY AND THE LIKELIHOOD OF
WORKERS AND THE QUALITY OF CARE
FOR RESIDENTS. CROWDED
UNDERSTAFFED AND LACK OF
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT IN THE
COLD IN THE SYSTEM ARE AT THE
ROOT OF THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY WHICH IS WHY WOULD
BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT REFORMS.
THAT WILL MOVE OUR STATE
NURSING HOME SYSTEM TOWARDS ONE
THAT IS BUILT ON QUALITY CHAIR
CORPORATE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. SB SIX FIFTY
AND TO BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BILLIONAIRE
NURSING HOME OWNERS WHO HAVE
GROWN RICHER BY PROPERTY FROM A
NETWORK OF. INTER RELATED
CORPORATIONS THAT EXTRACT
PROFIT AT EVERY LEVEL RATHER
THAN INVESTING IN PATIENT CARE.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN KAISER
HEALTH NEWS ANALYSTS FOUND
THAT- YES WHICH CONTRACT WITH
RELATED PARTY. YOU WERE NURSES
AND AIDES FOR PATIENTS HAVE
HIGHER RATES OF PATIENT INJURED
AND INJURIES AND I'M BASED
PRACTICES AND THEIR SUBJECT. A
COMPLAINT ALMOST TWICE AS OFTEN
AS INDEPENDENT HOME. FACILITY
OWNERS HAVE USED COMPLICATED
OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES TO OBSCURE
OWNERSHIP AND OPERATIONAL
CONTROL LIMIT LEGAL EXPOSURE A
CONTRACT TO RELATE. TO RELATED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT INFLATED
RATE. SB SIX FIFTY IS ABOUT
ENSURING QUALITY RESIDENT CARE
BY PROVIDING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND AGAINST ALL
THE INDUSTRY FROM FROM PROFIT
CENTERS TO TRUE CARE CENTERS.
OUR MEMBERS KNOW FIRST HAND
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO NOT KNOW WHO
THE OWNER IS NOR WHERE THE
MONEY IS GOING BUT WHAT THEY DO
KNOW IS THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
WORKERS AND RESIDENTS. REPORTED
OF SB SIX FIFTY WILL BRING MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY TO THE
NURSING HOME INDUSTRY AND
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FUNDS FOR
MEDICAID AND MEDICARE ARE
DIRECTED TOWARDS THE QUALITY OF
CARE. PROVIDED TO RESIDENTS AND
FOR THE PROTECTION. FOR THE
WORKFORCE RATHER THAN
INTERCROPPING SHE IMPRACTICAL
BRING. ON NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS WORKERS MADE. ISSUES
THAT ARE IN THE INDUSTRY CAN NO
LONG BE A- I WOULD THINK FOR
YOUR- AND WAS. REQUEST I. THANK
YOU. TONY TICKETS- FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. OBVIOUSLY
THE LAST YEAR HAS BEEN BEYOND
HORRIFIC FOR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS AND STAFF AND THAT'S
WHY CANTOR AT THE ARE YOU A. R.
P. SENATOR STERN A LOT OF
OTHERS WANT TO TAKE ARE AWFUL
pFOR NURSING HOME REFORM SB SIX
FIFTY IS A CRITICAL PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PROTECT PLAN
A PACKAGE OF BILLS. AIMING TO
REPAIR BREAK DOWN THE LONG TERM
CARE PROTECTED SO THE RESIDENTS
AND STAFF FROM HARM THAT IN IT
THAT WAS REALLY ENABLE BY POOR
POLICY. MUCH OF THE NURSING
HOME INDUSTRY BROKEN. FOR SOME
NURSE HOMEOWNERS THERE. AND IS
NOT TO PROVIDE HIGH CALL CARE
TO MAKE. THERE'S A REASON WHY
WE CALL THEM FOR PROFIT.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
DRAMATICALLY UNSUCCESSFUL IN
ALIGNING QUALITY OF CARE WITH
PROFIT IN FACT WE HAVE NOT DONE
UPSIDE DOWN SYSTEM. WHAT THE
WORST NURSING HOMES CAN BE THE
MOST PROFITABLE. SINGLES ARE
INCREASINGLY USING RELATED
PARTY COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THEMSELVES. THEY
PAY THE RELATED PARTIES
INFLATED RATES AND TAKE TAKE
ITS PROFITS OFF THE BOOKS. THIS
IS THE PREDOMINANT WAY OF
OPERATING A FOR PROFIT NURSING
HOME IN CALIFORNIA. THE REALLY
BAD APPLES USE RELATED PARTIES
TO RUTHLESSLY STRIPPED MONEY
AWAY FROM CARE. THE REST USE
RELATED PARTIES TO HIDE THEIR
PROFITS TO JUSTIFY RENT SEEKING
FROM THE STATE EVERY FEW YEARS.
IT'S A RESIDENT TO BE A BRUNT
OF THE FINANCIAL GAINS. I'M NOT
SURE I CAN ADD. TO THE DISH.
WITH NO HOME AND TURN STUFF
AMONG RESIDENTS CERTAINLY. CO
GOOD. IN MANY WAYS THAT STAGE
FOR COVERT. SB SIX FIFTY
REQUIRE DECISION MORE. ABOUT
THE RELAY PART FINANCES- IT
REPORT WITH. REPORTING OF X.
WHICH RELATE PARTIES. THAT WILL
GO MUCH FARTHER WHAT WE
CURRENTLY GET. WE CAN NOW
BETTER FOLLOW THEM IN
ALTERNATELY BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH OF OUR DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT THE RESIDENTS
HOW MUCH ARE GOING TO BENEFIT
THE OWNERS. WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE- IN SB SIX FIFTY THANKS
AGAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FIFTY- YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SB SIX FIFTY AGAIN. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF B. SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT ON SB. SIX FIFTY. AND
AT THIS TIME ABOUT FIVE IN OUR
QUEUE RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER ONE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR TONY TO KERO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANTED TO BE ON
RECORD OF SUPPORT THAT SENATOR
STEARNS SB FIVE ZERO EIGHT.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU AYE
THAT'S NOW TO YOUR BILL BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT LET'S NOW AGAIN
WE'RE BACK TO SB SIX FIFTY-
PLEASE AGAIN ADDITIONAL OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY. NEXUS NUMBER TWO THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON NUMBER THE LIGHT CAME
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE TO LINE
TO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO
CASTRO ON BEHALF OF A RP
CALIFORNIA THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS IN THE STATE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX FIFTY
AM PROUD CO SPONSOR THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXUS NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CRACKED UP. BE ABLE A COUPLE
HEY TRYING TO BILL AND. FIVE
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW IN B.
FIFTY S. FIVE OH NOW EUROPE SO
YOU'RE ON THE LINE FOR FIVE OH
EIGHT- PLEASE. CALLED NEXT YEAR
I GUESS- WE WILL BE TO. JESTING
THAT NEXT YEAR- SO GET AGAIN
WE'RE S. B. SIX AN OTHER WITH
AND- OF SB. SIX FIFTY. WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CHUCK EDELMAN AND I'M
HEREREPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCEFOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FIFTY THANK YOU. EXLINE
AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHERIN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FIFTY-
FIRST WE HAVE- JENNIFER SNYDER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES- SO YOU
CAN PLEASE BRING HER ON THE
LINE AS THE PROPONENTS HAD FOUR
MINUTES- EVEN THOUGH SHE'S THE
SOLE OPPOSITION WITNESS WILL
FORD OR UP TO FOUR MINUTES
ALTHOUGH AGAIN YOU DON'T NEED
TO TAKE ALL THE TIME IF YOU
DON'T NEED TO- SILVA
COMPLAINING ON JENNIFER SNYDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JENNIFER
SNYDER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES. BUT WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB SIX FIFTY. FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY WERE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE. OF THE TIME AND
EFFORT THE AUTHOR HAD SPENT
WORKING WITH US. ON AMENDMENTS.
AND ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S STAFF. INTO THE
CHAIR- FOR. SENT TO THE TENSION
TO THE CONFLICT ISSUE. OF THE
BILL. LEGISLATURE THE CORE. I
DO THAT WERE MADE PROGRESS
TOWARD AMENDMENT ADDRESSED R.
P. AND- THE- IS VERY. OF THE
OFF. TO PROMOTE TRADE IN
REPORTING. THE LISTED BEFORE
THE OWNERS OF THE PARTY'S OR
OTHER BUSINESS. RELATED TO THAT
THE BODY SHOP. YET THE COURT
KNOWS THAT. ADJUSTED CONCLUDING
ARE- REPORT INTO. THE PARTY
FUTURE PASSAGE OF BILL. EIGHTY
NINE. THREE FROM A COUPLE YOU
AGO. WHERE ARE WE GONNA BE OF
THAT- COME TO LIGHT- IN THE
NEXT YEAR OR- STILL ARE
CONCERNED AROUND HE- YOU HAVE
REALLY. OVER THREE MAIN ISSUES.
WITH CLEAR SECOND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL IS NOT TO
OVERLY COSTLY BURDENSOME FOR
NURSING FACILITY SUCH AS
REQUIRING A FULL- CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT AUDIT-
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL FACILITY
OWNERS THAT DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND HOW. WE'RE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS- UNRELATED
PARTY- THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO REPORT PAYMENT- MULTITUDE OF
VENDORS THAT MIGHT BE AN
UNRELATED PARTIES COULD INCLUDE
WORK COMP KERRIER GARDENERS ARE
OTHER ANCILLARY CONTRACTS THAT.
ALREADY NEGOTIATED WITH HERE
WORK WITH THE WINNERS. AND
THIRD IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WHERE WE HAVE REPORTED IT IT'S
MEANINGFUL BUT JUST MAKING SURE
WE'RE NOT REQUIRING AN ENTITY
THAT IS NOT RELATED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DISABILITY OWNER OR
OWNERSHIP. INTEREST OR
OWNERSHIP TO FILE A CURRENT
CONSOLIDATED FINANCIAL RECORDS
OR OTHER TYPES OF EXTENSIVE
INFORMATION IF THERE IS A TEN
OR OR NON RELATED PARTY RELATED
TO THAT OWNER. SO WE ARE
DEFINITELY COMMITTED AND TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND HOPE TO FINALIZE
MUTUAL MUTUALLY AGREEABLE AND
THAT- BUT AT LEAST TODAY WE
STILL MUST MAINTAIN OUR COOKING
LESSON THAT THE POSITION. ON
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW GO ABOUT TWO
ADDITION WITNESSES AN OP- TO-
YES SB SIX. OF WILL BE WITH A
GALLERIES ON THE OUR LET'S FROM
THE ROOM TO FORTY SAY NO ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR. PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX FIFTY AGAIN THAT'S
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION SB.
SIX FIFTY. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NOW TO THE COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS A QUICK COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EIGHT SEE
ACTUALLY SEE CENTER GROVE
FOLLOWED BY CENTER ROCKS AS
IMMIGRANTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST HAVE A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR- BRIEF STORY WHEN
THE PANDEMIC FIRST STARTED-
AND- EVERYBODY WAS TRACKING AND
WE CHECKED THE FATALITIES NOW
BUT WE WERE CHECKING THEM. VERY
VERY- IMMEDIATELY ONCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED BACK IN MARCH-
AND- THE MAJORITY OF AT THAT
TIME IN MARCH AND APRIL
POSSIBLY MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY.
THE MAJORITY OF THE FATALITIES
BECAUSE OF CODE CAME FROM- ONE
SKILL THEIR FEEDS A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IN MY
DISTRICT- ANOTHER SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IN INTO LARRY.
AS WELL AS BAKERSFIELD- ERA OF
COURSE I JUMPED ALL OVER MY
POOR THE CALVET FASIR TELLING
HIM TO GET IN THERE FIX THIS
WHAT'S GOING ON HOUSING GETTING
IN THERE HE KNOWS WHERE IS IT
COMING FOR AND THAT KIND OF
THING. HIS RESPONSE TO ME WAS
IS THAT IT WAS- HE HAD NO
JURISDICTIONAL AUTHORITY
BECAUSE IT WAS THIS THESE
FACILITIES ARE. REGULATED AND
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO- I GUESS IT'S A
BROAD QUESTION WHAT IN THIS
BILL IS GOING TO- HELP. ADDRESS
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAD AN- NEED
TO SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
FATALITIES IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY WHEN THEY'RE
REGULATED BY THE STATE AND WHAT
IS GOING TO HELP THE STATE
OPERATE BETTER SO THAT THESE
FACILITIES- AT. HAVE LESS I
DON'T SEE THIS BEING I DON'T
WANT ANOTHER PANDEMIC BUT LESS
FATALITIES ARE LESS ISSUES WHEN
THEY'RE CARING FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
CENTER STERN MONTROSE THAT
THROUGH THE CHERRY YEAH I THINK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK
YOU CENTER GROVE AYE AYE. I
WENT THROUGH A SIMILAR
SITUATION- RIGHT IN MY OWN
FAMILY ACTUALLY IT SAID
ANDERSON HOME- IN MY DISTRICT
AND- THAT WAS PART OF THE
BEGINNING OF MY JOURNEY INTO
THIS ISSUE AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. YOU KNOW WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING- I THINK SHE LOST
HALF HER FLOOR AND IT'S ONE OF
THE PREEMINENT. SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN LA. PUBLIC
NONPROFIT BUT NEVERTHELESS LIKE
HOW DO WE STOP THIS. PART OF
THE PART OF THE CHALLENGES THIS
STRAIN WE'VE PUT ON. THE WORK
FORCE SIDE OF THINGS AND THE
LIMITATIONS THAT WE'VE GOT-
INABILITY TO SORT OF CONTAIN
QUARANTINE MANAGE THESE THINGS
WHEN YOU HAVE A WORK FORCE IS
BEING SO HEAVILY IMPACTED. AND
SO WHEN NOT ENOUGH THERE'S NOT
REALLY ENOUGH DOLLARS IN OUR
MEDICAL SYSTEM RIGHT NOW TO BE
ACTUALLY FUNDING. THOSE WHO
WORK IN OUR CARE ECONOMY TO
DELIVER THE SERVICES THEY NEED
HENCE YOU SEEN ALL THESE
WAIVERS OF THE RATIOS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
NUMBERS ARE DISMAL- YOU KNOW
YOU'LL SEE ONE NURSE ON THE
FLOOR FOR TWELVE. YOU KNOW
PATIENTS AT A TIME WHO ARE
SEVERELY IN NEED AND YOU GET
BAD THINGS HAPPEN WHEN YOU
STRING THE SYSTEM THAT WAY THE
IDEA OF THIS BILL IS IF THERE
IS. FACT IN THE SYSTEM IF FOR
LACK OF BETTER WORDS THERE'S IF
THERE ARE TRANSACTIONS
OCCURRING WHERE ARE RELATED
PARTIES ARE NOT NECESSARILY
GIVING THEMSELVES LIKE THE BEST
MARKET RATE THAT THERE'S ANY
INSULATION IN THESE
TRANSACTIONS AND THIS IS. YOU
KNOW WE KNOW ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OR SO HAVE BEEN
SPENT IN THIS AREA- BY FOR
PROFIT UNIVERSITY ED FACILITY
SO WE'RE DOING A VERY LARGE
ECONOMY HERE SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF TRANSACTING
BUT IF THERE'S- IF EVEN HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF. THAT
SPENDING WAS INAPPROPRIATE-
THAT HALF A MILLION DOLLARS NOW
GETTING TO THE FRONT LINES
BUSINESS WE THINK THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO RADICALLY
IMPROVE CARE WITHOUT US HAVING
TO INCREASE TAXES OR GO AFTER
OUTSIDE FUNDING IN THE GENERAL
BUDGET BUT JUST TO MAKE THE
PUBLIC. DOLLARS WORK BETTER SO
THAT'S MY I ATTEMPTING YOUR
CALL. THANK FOR YOUR CONCERN
THANK YOU SIR I APOLOGIZE
THEY'RE CALLING ME BACK TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE I'M KINDA
DOING DOUBLE DUTY HERE- SO LIKE
YOU I DO UNDERSTAND THAT AND-
YOU KNOW THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY IN THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WERE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED. IN AND THE SITUATION
WE HAD IN TWENTY TWENTY- I JUST
AND I REALLY DO WANT TO
SOLUTION I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE INFECTED DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY GO BACK INTO
THESE FACILITIES- AND- IN
EFFECT GREATER NUMBERS OF THE
POPULATION IN THOSE FACILITIES.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THIS BILL
THAT I DO WANT TO SOLUTION I
REALLY DO- BUT I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS BILL OF FIXES THAT AND-
YOU KNOW MOST THIS
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE LIKE
FOURTEEN CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
FOR MEDICARE PATIENTS AND-
HELLO ALTHOUGH I DO KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF LARGE FACILITIES-
THAT DO HAVE OPERATE IN THAT.
PROBABLY THAT MILLION BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT. THERE ARE A LOT
OF SIX BUT FACILITIES THERE ARE
A LOT OF- YOU KNOW AND- HUNDRED
THAT DISABILITIES FIFTY BUT
FACILITIES. THAT DON'T OPERATE
IN THAT MANY STANDARD AND THEY
ARE- IN IN ADEQUATELY
REIMBURSED I GUESS ON THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID IT'S LIKE FOURTEEN CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR TWELVE AT TWELVE
DOLLARS A DAY FOR A BED. ON A
MEDIC CAL THERE'S ME YOU CAN'T
EVEN PAY SOMEBODY ONE HOUR'S
WORTH OF WORK- WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE OF ONE
PATIENT AND SO- THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION THOUGH
BECAUSE I REALLY THINK WE DO
NEED A SOLUTION FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE.
THANK YOU. SENATE ROTH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY THIS IS A
COMMON BY THE WAY NOT A
QUESTION. EFFORTS TO IMPROVE-
TRANSPARENCY WITH REGARD TO THE
OPERATION OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN THE STATE. TO
DRIVE AS MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE
DOWN TO DIRECT PATIENT CARE WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO DO THAT AND
THE AUTHOR'S CORRECT AND THE
OTHER ONE- COLLEAGUES ARE
CORRECT IN. NOTING THAT THERE'S
FRANKLY NOT ENOUGH MONEY. IN
THIS AREA OF HEALTH CARE TO
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL CARE THAT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE. TO
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE I DO HAVE SOME
ISSUES IN SOME CASES SOME
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES OR WITH THE
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN DESIGNED-
TO OBTAIN VISIBILITY OVER THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE ENTITIES THAT
DO BUSINESS WITH. THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE BASED ON WHAT I WAS
ABLE TO READ IN THE AMENDMENTS
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN FLYING BACK AND
FORTH. TO THE CREDIT OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE CHAIR- UP
UNTIL SHORTLY BEFORE THIS
HEARING STARTED- BUT AS DRAFTED
THE BILL APPEARS TO BE A BIT
TOO BROAD. OF FRANKLY IN THAT
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO THOSE OTHER
ENTITIES CONTROLLED CONTROLLED.
BY THOSE WHO CONTROL THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
BECAUSE FROM MY EXPERIENCE IT'S
THE CONTROL OF THOSE AFFILIATED
BUSINESSES BY OWNERS OF THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES THAT
ALLOWS MONEY TO BE DIVERTED OR
SIPHONED AWAY FROM THE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE OF RESIDENTS ARE
PATIENTS IN THESE FACILITIES.
AND CONTROL IS NOT 1% CONTROL
IS NOT 5% CONTROL IS CONTROL.
OF THE AFFILIATED BUSINESSES
CLEARLY IF WE'RE GONNA BE
IMPOSING REQUIREMENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WE ST OUT TO
ACHIEVE AND SO. I OF FRANKLY
BILL LANGUAGE IS IMPORTANT AND
I THINK THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON THIS BILL I'M I'M
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT I INTEND TO VOTE AYE ON
THIS BILL TODAY AND I SIMPLY
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. AND THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL OF WORK
ON THOSE CONTROL ISSUES AS THIS
BILL HOPEFULLY MOVES FROM THIS
COMMITTEE TO APPROPRIATIONS
EFFECT FOR HIS NEXT AND THEN TO
THE FLOOR SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY WILL E VOTING
AYE BUT I WOULD ASK THAT THOSE
ISSUES. BE ADDRESSED- PRIOR TO
COMING BACK TO THE FLOOR IN MY
HAVING TO VOTE ON IT AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I GUESS I WILL
JUST- ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE AND THIS. AND THAT-
WE WANT THIS BILL TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND I ALSO IT WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND-
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
BECAUSE IT IS PERSONAL TO MANY
PEOPLE THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
SOME HARDSHIPS. IN PARTICULAR
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL-
CLOSELY RELATED TO ALWAYS GOING
ON- IN IN A NURSING FACILITY
BUT- I JUST WANTED TO SAY I YOU
KNOW I DID ACCOUNTING WORK FOR
FIVE YEARS AND SO I DO. THINK
WHAT'S BEING ASKED HERE AND TO
ASK THE SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE
STATED IT'S- WE JUST NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AND LANGUAGE AND I ALSO HEARD I
BELIEVE IT WAS THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENT SAYING THAT THEY'RE
ALMOST THERE AND THEY'RE-
MAKING PROGRESS. AND I JUST
WANT TO COACH THE OTHER TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS IS
JUST TOO IMPORTANT. NOT TO COME
TO A SOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
K. C. NONE- S. R. STERN. I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND THE SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH ME AND THE
STAFF- I KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW.
THAT THERE IS STILL STILL SOME
MORE WORK TO DO- AND- SO FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE- FINANCIAL.
AUDIT ISSUE I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO ACT OF
FINANCIAL INFORMATION AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT SPONSORS SAID
THAT. THEY AGREE THAT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS BE SURE THEY'RE
ACCURATE AND THAT THEIR MEETING
FOR EIGHT AND SO WHAT KIND OF
GUARDRAILS OF SOME OF THOSE
DETAILS WE STILL HAVE TO WORK
OUT. I THINK WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON BUT CONCEPTUALLY WE
ALL IN IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOU AND- THE
SPONSORS WORKING WITH- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND DO YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS TO GET US
THAT DIRECTION I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL. THAT- WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO. DO SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK TO FINE TUNE
THIS BUT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS AND WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO BECAUSE AGAIN WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE. FUNDS THAT
WERE PUT IT ACTUALLY TAXPAYERS
ARE PAYING FOR THE MEDICAL
SIDE. YEAH AND BEING DIVERTED
AWAY FROM ACTUAL PATIENT CARE-
THAT'S BEING PROVIDED BY A
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES SO.
WITH THAT AGAIN WILL BE SAID
THANK YOU WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL- AND- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I WOULD TAKE YOU
MISTER CHAIRED WITHOUT CALM. AB
MEMBERS- I'M JUST. TOO FACTUAL
POINTS NOTE MY CLOTHES AND THEN
I'LL I'LL I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- YOUR AYE VOTE- WHEN
IT COMES TO THE- QUESTION OF
THE AUDITOR THE NATURE THE
FINANCIAL REPORTING GOING
FORWARD. WE'RE VERY INTERESTED
IN- CLARIFYING THAT AND MAKING
SURE THAT'S- FEASIBLE THE BILL
DOESN'T EXPLICITLY ACTUALLY
CALLED FOR AN AUDIT IT'S A
CONSOLIDATED FINANCIAL REPORT-
BUT- THERE. THERE SEEMS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF AMBIGUITY ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING ASKED FOR-
SO I WOULD LOVE TO GET. CLARITY
ON THAT BEFORE THE FLOOR THEN.
SENATOR ROSS POINT AS WELL-
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
DEFINITION. OF RELATED PARTY-
AND THE COMMON OWNERSHIP
DEFINITION NESTED IN THEIR- WE
MAY HAVE. CONFUSE THINGS A
LITTLE BIT BY NOT JUST CITIN
TO THE CODE. THE CODE OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THE CFR THE
DEFINITION IN THE BILL RIGHT
NOW ACTUALLY JUST MIRRORS THE
CFR- SO AS WE GO FOR JUST KEEP
THAT IN MIND AND BUT WE WANT TO
KEEP WORKING THROUGH THAT JUST
FORGET WHERE IT MAKES SENSE TO
ACTUALLY DEPART FROM THE
EXISTING FETTER. FEDERAL
DEFINITION AND NOT- SO THANKS
FOR LET ME GO INTO THE WEEDS A
LITTLE BIT ON THE ON THE
CLOTHES THERE BUT- THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT DETAILS AS YOU ALL
RIGHT WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT OUR OWN CONSCIENCE. ABOUT
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE PAYING TO
CARE FOR THOSE WHO ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE ACTUALLY GETTING
WHAT THEY PAID FOR WHICH IS
SOME SEMBLANCE OF DIGNITY FOR
THE PER PEOPLE WHO SERVE THEM
AND FOR THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN. LANGUISHING ALONE FOR THE
LAST YEAR I OFTEN IN SILENCE SO
THANK YOU FOR IN ADVANCE FOR
SPEAKING UP FOR ALL OF THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER STERN-
ACTUALLY STORE MOTION ON THE
BILL. OKAY CENTER GONZALEZ HAS
MOVED THE BILL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE AND SALAS HI SALAS I GROW
HER TADO LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
LIMóN AYE LIMóN AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- AND MAKE
NOTE THAT SERETIDE IS NOT IN
THE CHAMBER AT THE VERY MOMENT
SO- SIR EGGMAN ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT YOUR BILLS- DO A
PRESENT YOUR DESK. I CAN I WAS
ALSO GOING TO PRESENT THE
CENTER TAUGHT US IF YOU'D LIKE
OKAY- I THINK SHE MAY BE
RETURNING LATER. YEAH KAY ALL
RIGHT OKAY IF YOU WISH TO THAN-
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD AND-
PRESENT CENTER TOWERS BUILT UP
OUR NEXT ITEM THEN IS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT IF I SAW HER TADO IS
PRESENTED BY CENTER EGGMAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THAT THIS HAVING
TO DO WITH ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR EVERYONE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MENTAL HEALTH. FOR OUR CHILDREN
THIS HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY TRUE
THEY WERE CUT OFF UNEXPECTEDLY
FROM THEIR FRIENDS THEIR
TEACHERS THEIR COACHES THEIR
TEAMMATES. IN SOME CASES THEIR
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS. THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEMS FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS. WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES THE TOUGH QUESTION
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THIS WAVE OF
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
CONTEXT OF TRAUMA. THAT WE'RE
ALL EXPERIENCING. EXPERTS HAVE
WARNED THAT THE CURRENT CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS A
TRAUMATIC STRESSOR THIS
DRAMATIC STRESSOR MAY LEAD TO A
WHOLE GENERATION. OF CHILDREN
WHO HAVE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE. IT'S BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT EXPANDS THE ABILITY OF
PROVIDERS TO SCREEN PATIENTS
FOR ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES OR ACES. IT
REQUIRES COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
TO PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR CASES
SCREENING. RECENT RESEARCH HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE LINK BETWEEN
ACES AND A DECLINE IN THE
INDIVIDUALS LONG TERM HEALTH
OUTCOMES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES CURRENTLY
REIMBURSES PHYSICIANS WHO TAKE
A SUS TRAINING. WILL PROVIDE A
SCREENING TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT FOR COMMERCIAL
PAYERS TO COVER A SCREENING.
THANKS MANY COVERAGE OF A
SCREENING NOW DOCTORS WILL BE
ABLE TO MIGRATE WITH. MITIGATE
WHAT MAY HAVE BECOME A
COMPOUNDING TRAUMA IN THE
FUTURE. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
TODAY JOINING US REMOTELY DR
MARTY BOMB A PEDIATRICIAN WHO
PERFORMS A SCREENING AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. AND DR JOSIE BAINES
AS PHYSICIAN FROM DIGNITY
HEALTH FOUNDATION MEDICAL
GROUP. RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN. MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON TO THE LINES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT- DR MARTY BOMB AND DR
JASMEET BAINES. CONFLICTS BRING
THEM ON THE LINE YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
TOGETHER- SELF THEY'LL GIVE A
TWO MINUTE WARNING FOR THE
FIRST TEST OF FIRE WHEN YOU HAD
TWO MINUTES SO YOU KNOW THAT
YOU'RE TAKING TIME FROM THE
NEXT PERSON. SO WE HAVE- MARTY
BOMB CAN WE PLEASE. HAVE
MARTABAN BEGIN. HELLO THANK YOU
HONOR ROLL DR RICHARD PAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE I'M DOCTOR
MARTY BONTA SPEAKING AS A
PEDIATRICIAN AND TRUSTEE OF THE
BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HELLO I'M A
PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN AND A
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CLINIC SERVING SIXTEEN THOUSAND
PATIENTS PER MONTH AND THIS IS
A TRAINING CLINIC FOR THE
RESIDENTS FROM LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY. OUR PATIENTS HOMES
ARE IN THE CENSUS TRACTS WITH
THE HIGHEST SOCIAL
VULNERABILITY INDEX DEFINED BY
THE CDC IN A CAMERA DINO
COUNTY. OUR CHILDREN HAVE JUST
UNDER 25% CHRONIC ILLNESS RATE
WHICH IS IMPACTED BY
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. LACK OF
EDUCATION IN THE HOME AND JUST
BASIC FOOD AND SECURITY. THESE
ARE THE CHILDREN THAT A
FEDERALLY QUALIFIEDHEALTH
CLINIC OF CALL TO TAKE CARE OF
THESE ARE THE CHILDREN THAT
MEDICAID FUNDING FOR TAX BY
SECURE AND CONTINUED HEALTH
CARE. JUST AS YOU SCREAM FOR
SHORTNESS OF BREATH- OF DOMINO
PAIN WE NOW SCREEN FOR ACES.
THIS SCREENING IS EVIDENT
INFORMED ACTIVITY SCREENING FOR
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
CREATE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROVIDER TO ADDRESS MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES OF THE CHILD
FOUNDATION OF HEALTH. DATA
SECURE SAFE ENVIRONMENT TO
THRIVE. ASIAN ISN'T A UNIQUE TO
TRUST ROLE FOR THIS CONGRESS TO
THE BAILEYS TO RESOURCES AND
REFERRALS AND MOVE A FAMILY OF
RISK TO A FAMILY OF RESILIENCE.
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WILL
FINALLY SLINK AWAY AND ARE JOB
DISPOSITIONS IN THE FIGHT WILL
DIMINISH HOWEVER WE ARE LEFT
WITH THE VULNERABLE GENERATION
OF CHILDREN. THAT WILL BEAR THE
EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC THESE
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE THAN
INVISIBLE POPULATION THAT IS
OUR NEXT RESPONSIBILITY TO
IDENTIFY AND HELP HEAL. A
SCREENING BEGAN IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE ARE JUST
FIFTEEN MONTHS INTO SCREENING
EXPANSION OF SERVICES AND
GAINING MOMENTUM. THE IMPORTANT
OF ADVANCING THIS TO ALL HEALTH
INSURANCE ENTITIES IS THAT
THERE ARE NO PHYSICAL SIGNS OF
ACES IN CHILDHOOD IT'S A FAMILY
HAS A COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION. THAT
THERE IS NO RISK OF ACES.
CLEARLY WE KNOW THAT IS NOT
TRUE THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
CALL TO EQUITY AND ELIMINATION
OF BIAS. THE BEST MONIES TO
URGE A SCREENING AND A SAFETY
NET BY PASSING BILL. FOR TWENTY
EIGHT TO PROTECT ALL CHILDREN.
THANK YOU NOW BRING ON- DOCTORS
MEET BAINES. GOOD EVENING THANK
YOU DOCTOR PAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR JUST ME
BEING PHYSICIAN LOCATOR CONTROL
VALLEY CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE TO GET TV OPEN FOR
PRESIDENT KERN REGIONAL CENTER.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC I
THOUGHT EFFECTIVE YEARS OF
MENTAL TRAUMA IN MY KIDNEY
CLINIC MANIFESTING AS SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
PAULINE OVERACTIVITY LOW
PERFORMANCE IN SCHOOL AND EVEN
DEADLY SUICIDE. AS A CONDITION
I CHALLENGED AS LONG AGO BY
CREATING POP MUSICAL EDUCATION
AROUND CHILDHOOD TRAUMA AND HOW
TEACHERS CAN ABOUT THE DATA BY
YOU CAN SEND THEM TO ME AT THE
CLINIC URGENT EVALUATION. THE
FIRST STEP HE CHANGED AS
IDENTIFYING THE PROBLEM AND
INCREASING SCREENING AND
EDUCATION. IS A MAJOR PROPONENT
OF. EVEN WHILE THE POUNDS I'M
OVERSEEING THE KEREM. CHILDREN
PPP HOW TO INCLUDED ELEMENTS OF
THE LATE THEY WERE WITH THAT
YOU. REGIONAL TO HELP THE- I
WOULD SEE MANY AROUND AGE OF
TWO NOT SPEAKING IN WHEN I
FURTHER INTO THE HIS I WOULD OF.
STORIES THAT THE SPECTER SEXUAL
PHYSICAL. WHICH WERE ALL TOO
COMMON A PUNK QUESTIONING OF
THE CURRENT. I WOULD HEAR EVEN
MORE STORIES OF THEIR OWN
TRAUMA. THE FURTHER I DUG
FURTHER I FELL INTO A NEVER
ENDING BLACK HOLD NORMALIZED
TRAUMATIC. BUT BEGAN TO SEE THE
AFFECTS OF THE SOCIETY THAT CAN
UNDERSTAND CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
BECAUSE IT WAS CONSIDERED
NORMAL TO THEM THAT DOT DOT
DRUNKEN WITH THE WITH THE WITH
THE BELL OF HOPE SOMEONE PASSED
OUT. THERE IS A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN OUR COUNTRY AND IT
WASN'T BUILT IN A DAY THIS IS
THE DIRECT RESULT OF YEARS AND
YEARS OF A PRESS PROBLEM OF THE
AND- INADEQUATE SCREENING AND
TO THINK THAT LACK OF ACCESS TO
CARE. NINE AFFECTING LATER ON
WITH YOUR MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS
CALLED TO HELP HER EXPECTANTLY.
STUDIES PROVE THERAPY EARLY ON
PREVENTIVE HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
COMPLICATIONS LATER AND I BEGIN
TO TELL YOU HOW MANY PATIENTS I
HAVE ON A DAILY BASIS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE. STORY THE
PUBLICATION'S ADMIRING VIçT
ONLY TO LATER FIND OUT ABOUT
THE CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. DANGER
AND WE'RE PROUD. INCREIBLE
TRINA. AROUND THE IS A NAY.
FIRST GOT TO IT. ADDRESS THAT I
YOU WITH THIS QUOTE. NO THE NEW
I NEED YOU TO WRAP UP KNOWING.
WHAT YOU MEAN TO TRONG I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WITHOUT TO A- WHAT. INTO IT'S A-
OF AS FORTY EIGHT BEGIN WITH.
GALA SCENE PUBLIC MOVED TWENTY.
SING ROOM FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LAW TO. WHO TO
TESTIFY AND SO. OF SB FOUR
TWENTY. NAY OR EXIT POSITION.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO THE TEST
IN SOME OF S. FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO TIME. AGAIN ONE FORCE. OF
S. FOR EIGHT. WE DO HAVE A
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE RIGHT PLEASE
BEGIN. IT WILL START WITH
NUMBER ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS NEAR MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
FINE. ACTUALLY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KATIE
AND YOUR CHILDREN NOW CO
SPONSORS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHOP AFTER MARKET
COLLEGE OBGYN S. DISTRICT.
COURT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS AN APPLICATION OF THE
KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN COURT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. SIX BILLION THE
NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS A REMINDER FROM
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXUS NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS K<c.cyan></c>
LAYTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOUNG NEXT LINE. NEXT TO NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MODERATOR OF A NOW
NEWS MOVED TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT- THERE'S NO FORMALLY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION SO
WE'LL MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY PROVISIONAL WITNESSES
SAY NONE AND- PUBLIC ALWAYS
MOVED TO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY.
DOES NOT INCLUDE TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. AND NOW
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
IN THE QUEUE RIGHT. PLEASE
BEGIN. LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE OKAY AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR CHECK ALL RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH THOUGH THIS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
CENTER RUBIO. I KNOW RUNNING AT
A TIME SO TRY. TRY TO TALK
FAST- FOR SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I JUST
WANNA SAY I WE TALK ABOUT-
ADVERSE. CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT WE KNOW THAT IT HAS EXISTED
FOR DECADES AND GENERATIONS AS
A TEACHER I THOUGHT. EVERY
SINGLE YEAR IN MY CLASSROOM ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER AND I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE AS WE GO BACK INTO
SOCIETY WE COME OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. THIS IS GOING TO
BECOME EVEN MORE IMPORTANT SO I
WILL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND I WILL ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER RUBIO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR. COMMENTS OKAY SO
NONE. AGAIN I ALSO AT PRETTY
SHE TEST TAUGHT OVER THIS BILL.
THAT WE CAN GET THIS SHOULD BE
SOMETHING WE DO ROUTINE ACROSS
FOR ALL TO. ARE JUST FOR TO WHO
ARE CMS CAL I WOULD SAY UNDER
THAT THERE THE DOCTOR DID SAY.
HAD PLANNED TO EXCLUDE THAT
ACCOUNT CARE PLAN- AS WOULD
ACTUALLY- URGE HER NOT TO DO
THAT- WITH THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE CENTER I WOULD JUST.
APPRECIATE ARE ARE A- ESTEEMED
LONG TIME TEACHER. AT AND THANK
YOU HER. AND BEHALF OF. CENTER
HURTADO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I'VE THANK YOU OKAY SO
THE- AGAIN SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHTHS FOR MOVED BY. AT CENTER.
THE MOTIONS PASS A RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE UP. CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE- PAN HI CAN HI
MELINDA. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS ON A
GROVE HER TADO. LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE LIMON. LIMON AYE ROTH AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. SO THE CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE S. BEFORE 65% OR
EGGMAN SIR EDMUND. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR- WELL
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF. BILLS TALK
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH RECENTLY
I'M UP FOR IT THIS ONE A COUPLE
MORE- TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
FOUR SIXTY FIVE AND ONE ACCEPT
THE CRIPPLING AMENDMENTS LAID
OUT THE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE FOR
HELPING. OVER CODE WE'VE BEEN
DESPERATELY LOOKING AT JUST ALL
KINDS OF WAY OF LOOKING AT.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
AND WHAT KIND OF WASTE WHAT
COULD WE DO TO IMPROVE IT WE
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF FUNDING
IN THEIR- AND SOMETIMES WERE
FRUSTRATED WITH THE- WAY IT
MOVES AND SO. WE THINK THIS
BILL ADDRESSES. TWO ISSUES THAT
WILL WILL HELP THINGS. FIRST
THIS BILL. TO FOR SERIOUSLY.
DISTURBED TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY. FOR MENTAL. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDED
SERVICES FOR KIDS. THIS BILL
SPLITS OUT TWO CRITERIA THAT
ARE REQUIRED IN COMBINATION
CURRENT LAW AND MAKES THEM
DISTINCT. M. IN OTHER WORDS
BEFORE WAS THERE TOGETHER AND
WE'RE GONNA SEPARATE THOSE OUT
THAT SHOULD BE CALLED AS HE
DEAR SERIOUSLY EMOTIONALLY
DISTURBED UNDER DISORDERED THIS
UNDER THIS BILL ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE FUNDS AT HER WOULD STILL
REQUIRE ADDITION DIAGNOSIS AND
DEMONSTRATE BEHAVIORS
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THEIR AGE THE
CONCERN NOT FORCING YOU TO BE
INAPPROPRIATELY LABELED UNDER
THIS BILL IS CERTAINLY NOT OUR
INTENT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
CLARIFY THAT WITH THE AMENDMENT
TODAY. AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE DO NOT INCLUDING THIS
BILL ANYTHING TO FURTHER-STIGMATIZE OR HARM YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WE SIMPLY
WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO GET SERVICES
UNDER THE MEDICAL HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT THE SECOND
PIECE OF THIS BILL THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH ARE A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE PUT INTO
EVERY SINGLE YEAR- UNDER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDS THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
PROGRAMS THAT EMBODY THAT
WHATEVER IT TAKES APPROACH TO
HELP THOSE DEALING WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESSES. SOME COUNTIES
HAVE ALREADY STARTED LOOKING AT
HOW THEY CAN IMPROVE THE
SERVICES. AND TWENTY NINETEEN
THE FRESNO COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH REQUESTED. TO
APPROVE A MULTI COUNTY A
PROJECT TO RE FRAME. FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS AROUND AN
OUTCOME ORIENTED APPROACH THAT
REMAINS CLIENT CENTERED.
ADDITIONALLY L. A. COUNTY HAS
STARTED TO WORK ON A PROJECT
WITH THIRD SECTOR TO FACILITATE
AN AGENCY WIDE SHIFT. TO AN
OUTCOME ORIENTED IT. AN WAY.
THIS BILL FOLLOWS THAT LEAD
FOCUSING ON HAND HOW THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS-
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE MOST
DIRE OUTCOMES FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL ILLNESS.
CRIMINALISATION HOSPITALIZATION
AND HOMELESSNESS. AS BEFORE
SIXTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION TO REPORT ANNUALLY
TO THE LEGISLATURE. ON THE
SERVICES AND OUTCOMES FROM THE
F. FS PEACE. WITH A FOCUS ON
PREVENTING INCARCERATION
HOMELESSNESS AND
HOSPITALIZATION. IT ALSO
REQUEST RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVING THESE OUTCOMES. I
THINK THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
pAHEAD OF US IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS WE'RE LOOKING AT MAJORLY
OVERHAULING A LOT OF THINGS BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ALREADY DO. AND THAT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW THE OUTCOMES OF IT.
I THINK THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I HAVE
RENTAL HAGAR AND JIM GROSS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE PSYCHIATRIC.
POSITIONS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON TO THE LINE RANDALL HAGER
FROM THIS PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIAN
LINE CALIFORNIA AND JIM GROSS
ALSO THE SAME- EACH OF YOU HAVE
UP TO TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES. IF YOU DON'T KEEP IT
SHORTER THAT WOULD BE BAD
EITHER- SO- PLEASE- BEGIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS RANDALL
HAGER CREDIT PSYCHIATRIC.
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS
IS MY SHORT TESTIMONY SO. HOW
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE MORE COST EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE AND FOCUSED USE. OF
AN HSA FUNDS PARTICULARLY
PROVIDING MAYBE EVEN BETTER
UPSTREAM CARE- EARLY
INTERVENTION PREVENTION FOR YOU
BUT ALSO MORE FOCUSED INTENSIVE
TREATMENT FOR HOMELESS
POPULATIONS. AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO ARE UNFORTUNATELY
INCARCERATED WITH- IN HIGH
NUMBERS. TO HAVE. AND NOW IS MY
TESTING WE THIS BILL HERE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NOW SPRING ON GROSS. BIG JIM
CROCE'S STANDING BY IN CASE
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OKAY SAYS
NO FOR THE TESTIMONY THEN ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO DIGITAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE PUBLIC GO TO PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE KNOWN PUBLIC
ALLEY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
SIXTY FIVE NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. HENLEY'S
JUDGMENT ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE TEN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MATURING TO. WE HAVE NO FORMAL
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR SIXTY FIVE SO GO TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SIXTY
FIVE- THERE ARE NONE IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY I SEE MOVE ROUND
TWENTY FOURTEEN IS NINE FROM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB.FOUR SIXTY FIVE NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. NOW IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION THIS BEFORE. SIXTY
FIVE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER RUBIO.
I JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BILL AND I WANT TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD THINKING SOME OF
WHEN APPROPRIATE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER RUBIO AT THE PERFECT
TIME IS THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. SIR EGGMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WE'RE TO MY STAFF AND
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. TO
ADDRESS A ONE OF THE ISSUES-
BUT DID DEFINITELY A BILL THAT-
IS EXCELLENT BILL AND- AGAIN
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT WHICH I
CLOSE. WHICH EXPECTS WE ASK FOR
YOUR OF THE STATE THANK YOU SO
THE AGAIN THIS IS- BILLS AND
MOVE BY CENTER RUBIO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS SIDE
GROVE. HER TADO LEYVA. LEYVA
AYE LIMóN. HI LIMON AYE ROTH
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER. THE KERN SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL ON. LET'S NOW MOVE TO
I'D NUMBER TEN SB FIVE SIXTEEN
AGAIN BY AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I. SAY THIS BE THE FOR
MIDDLE BILL TODAY I THINK
THERE'S MORE COMING BUT THIS IS
JUST FOR TODAY- I THINK CENTER
ALONE IS GOING TO TAKE US IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION BUT TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SB FIVE SIXTEEN
A BILL THAT I THINK HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACT AS A NARROW.
AND SPECIFIC IMPROVEMENT TO OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. UNDER
CURRENT LAW A PERSON
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS CAN BE HELD FOR
TREATMENT INVOLUNTARILY IF THEY
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA DANGER TO
THEMSELVES. OTHERS WERE UNABLE
TO FIGHT PROVIDE FOOD CLOTHING
SHELTER. TYPICALLY WE THINK
ABOUT THIS IS A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
OR SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD.
PEOPLE CAN BE RELEASED. AT THE
END OF TO BE TWO HOURS OR
HEARING CAN BE HELD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT
CONDITION REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
INTENSIVE TREATMENT. THE COURT
TO RECONSIDER STILL WHETHER
THAT PERSON. IS GRAVELY
DISABLED THE INITIAL CRITERIA
THAT PEOPLE. THEM WERE
EVALUATED UNDER- IT ENTERTAINER
IF THEY'RE ABLE TO ACCEPT
NECESSARY TREATMENT THIS CALL
THE FIFTY TO FIFTY OR
CERTIFICATION REVIEW UNDER THIS
YEAR. THIS CONDEMNED SOMEONE TO
BE HELD FOR UP TO. TWO WEEKS
GENERALLY OR LONGER IF
INDICATED. UNDER THIS BILL A
HEARING OFFICER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER
INFORMATION REGARDING A
PERSON'S MEDICAL CONDITION AS
WELL AND HOW THEIR CONDITION
BEARS ON THE CERTIFICATION OF
WHETHER THEY ARE A DANGER TO
SELF OR GRAVELY DISABLED WHEN
DETERMINING. WHETHER TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD A PERSON FOR
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT AFTER THAT
INITIAL SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
CURRENT CURRENT LAW FAILS TO
ADDRESS THIS PART ABOUT IT IS
YOUR MEDICAL CONDITION
INTERFERE WITH YOUR ABILITY. TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. HOW DO WE
HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE LANGUISHED
ON THE STREETS WITHOUT ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE WE'VE
ALL SEEN THEM WE'RE DRIVING BY
WE SEE PEOPLE ISSUES WITH THEIR
FEET OR SHOES WITH THE CUTS-
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY GOING ON
AND THAT DEEMED THEM EVEN
FURTHER. AT RISK AND FURTHER IT
WILL FIND PEOPLE IN A HOSPITAL
PERHAPS LOSING A LAMB AND
PERHAPS EVEN DYING OR IN A LONG
TERM FACILITY OR- GUARD AB. IF
YOU FROM JUSTICE FACILITY FOR
WAY TOO LONG. I KNOW THESE ARE
TOUGH ISSUES THAT WE CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT WE ARE NOT TRYING
TO GET MORE PEOPLE INTO THE
SYSTEM WE ARE TRYING TO MORE
ADEQUATELY TREAT. THOSE THAT
ARE ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM AND
CONTINUOUSLY EVOLVE THROUGH
THAT SYSTEM. I'VE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DISARRAY
STAFF- TO BILLS AMENDMENTS
ABOUT WHAT A MEDICAL CONDITION
IS AND WE'RE BACK HERE TO
HEALTH- TO BE CLEAR NOTHING IN
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR MANDATED
MEDICAL TREATMENT AND ONLY
SEEKS TO RESTORE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CAPACITY TO CARE
FOR THEIR NEEDS- THIS BILL I
BELIEVE CAN HELP PEOPLE AND I
THINK IT. STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN. PROTECTING PEOPLE'S
PERSONAL RIGHTS. AND MAKING
SURE THEY STAY SAFE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY. IS
AGAIN. RANDALL HAGAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AND JIM GROSS IF
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE IS OR WHAT THIS IS A
SUPPORT- RANDALL HAGAR AGAIN
FROM THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND JIM
GROSS OF THE SAME- BRING THE
HUNGER PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LEVEL ACRE CAMPUS
IN THE PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS
APPLY CALIFORNIA- THE DOCTOR
EGGMAN TO REALLY GOT IT RIGHT
THERE ARE VERY INCONSISTENT
CERTIFICATION DETERMINATIONS
BECAUSE SOME HEARING OFFICERS
IN COURTS. DO AS SOME OFFICERS
GO ACCEPT EVIDENCE OF A MEDICAL
CONDITION AS FURTHER EVIDENCE
OF GREAT DISABILITY THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL FIXES AND IN DOING SO
IT HELPS US TO PREVENT. OR
TREAT HEALTH CONDITIONS THAT
PEOPLE ARE UNFORTUNATELY
SUFFERING FROM ON THE STREETS
AND IN SOME CASES DYING- WE
CAN'T LET PEOPLE WHO ARE
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL BLACK THE
CAPACITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND ALSO HAVE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS- WE CAN'T
LET THEM FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS WE CANNOT. AFFORD T LET
THEM MOVE THROUGH THE SYSTEM
THAT THEY- WITHOUT TREATMENT IF
THEY DO SO THEY WILL RETURN AND
I'LL BE WORSE IN BOTH RESPECTS
AND ARE MENTAL HEALTH AND THEIR
HEALTH CONDITIONS SO WE- ARE
BRING THIS- IN THE HOPES THAT
WE CAN MAKE. THIS VERY SMALL
CHANGE THAT WOULD MAKE A VERY
LARGE. DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IT'S THIS MR GOING TO BE
JIM GROSS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
YES THAT IS CARE GIVE ROSA
BEHALF OF I CAN'T- DIGITAL IN
CALIFORNIA AND- HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU RIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIXTEEN WILL
GO TO THE PUBLIC GALLERY SINGLE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH UNTIL THE FORTY SEEN ON
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. FOR
WITNESSES WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE SIXTEEN
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI.
FICCI TEAM PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND AB FIVE SIXTEEN SB. FIVE
SIXTEEN FOR THE SENATE YES WE
DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU PLEASE BEGIN. I WILL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIAN AND ONLY AFTER
DECEMBER EACH YEAR IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SIX. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANKS VERY MUCH-
THERE'S NO FORMAL- REGISTERED
TONNAGE OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE SIXTEENTHS WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE NORTH PUBLIC
OUTLETS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROOM TO A FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE.
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE SIXTEEN AGAIN NAME OR EXIT
A POSITION ONLY. AND NOW HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND ONE ZERO PROPOSITION. SB
FIVE SIXTEEN. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT PLEASE
BEGIN. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TO WHITE PM ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND WE DO REGRET TO
INFORM YOU THAT WE ARE- OPPOSED
TO SB FIVE FIFTY FIVE SIXTEEN-
WE- HOLDEN THE BILL MOVED IN
DIRECTION CONTRAVENTION OF THE
STATE AUDITOR'S INDINGS ON THE
LPS STATUTE. AND DOES SO BY
CLEVERLY DISGUISING AN
EXPANSION OF THE DANGER TO SELF
OR OTHERS OR GRAVELY DISABLED
STANDARD AS AN EVIDENTIARY
REQUIREMENTS AND AT THE
DIRECTION TO THE COURT. TO
CONSIDER THE EVIDENCE OF
MEDICAL CONDITION- WE HOLD THAT
IT DOES SO IN A PIECEMEAL
FASHION MOREOVER THE BILL MAKES
THAT EXPANSION AND EXACTING.
AND PRECISE WAY. THE MEDICAL.
DANDER IS. GOD- THAT VIRTUALLY
ANY HELP COULD FALL WITHIN ITS
CURRENT PARAMETER I'M NOT
SUBJECT TO MEDICAL REVIEWER
STATUTORY LIMITATION UNTREATED
HEALTH CONDITIONS SHOULD NOT BE
A BASIS FOR INVOLUNTARY HOLDS
FOR RESTRICTIONS UNLESS THERE
ARE CLEAR STANDARDS TO LIMIT
THE AUTHORITY AND NOT OTHERWISE
DEPRIVE INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS TO I TONYA B.
AT THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THE
STATED INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ENACTING THE
LPS. ACT WAS TO PROVIDE. PROMPT
EVALUATION AND TREATMENT TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND TO
SAFEGUARD PERSONAL RIGHT TO
CONSISTENT STANDARD. SANDERS IN
THIS BILL NOT MEET THOSE GOALS
FOR THE THREE THREE THINGS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT SHE
WOULD OPPOSE SB FIVE SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. OKAY I DID GIVE YOU
LATITUDE TO ESSENTIALLY
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T HAVE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY IN THE NOTE
RECOGNIZING THE POSITION OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS SAYS- AS
SOMEONE BUT- I HOPE IN THE
FUTURE PLEASE REGISTER WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT YOU'LL BE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION SO WE
CAN. APPROPRIATELY- SCHEDULE
YOU ARE PLACE YOU IN THE-
TESTIMONY ORDER SO- BUT AS
THERE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PEOPLE AND DITION A WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SIXTEEN AND SHOULD BE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR
CHEN K. THANK YOU. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS. ANY QUESTIONS I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IS OUR MOTION
ON THE BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER LEYVA- SO CENTER EGGMAN-
YOU CAN APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE-
DANCING WITH THE BILL AND WHAT
SPONSORS- IT CERTAINLY WHY
RECOGNIZE WHAT DISPLAY RIGHT
SAID BUT SAME TIME I ALSO. THIS
ADDRESSES AN ISSUE WHERE. THE
BRAIN IN THE BODY ARE NOT
CONNECTED AND SO- THERE ARE WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE
LINKAGES THE- AND THAT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE.
CONSIDERED IN A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT- YOU KNOW THE BRAIN IN THE
BODY TOGETHER THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH- THEY
DIDN'T THEY ARE LINKED THEY
AFFECT EACH OTHER AND I THINK
THIS IS THIS BILLS IMPORTANT
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THAT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
EGGMAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR AND- AND
JUST SAY IT AND TO AGREE WITH
YOU YES AND I THINK THE AMOUNTS
WE TOOK IN JUDICIARY OF AN
ADDRESS THAT EVEN FURTHER- AND
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TO HELP US TREAT.
THE WHOLE. PERSON IN A MOST
EFFECTIVELY THANK YOU. HEY
THANK YOU SO. AT SPEED SIXTEENS
AND MOVE BY CENTER LEYVA THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAND BY PANTAI MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HIGH GROWTH I
HER TADO LEYVA. ALL RIGHT LEYVA
AYE LIMON. LIMON AYE ROTH HI
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. THE VOTERS CARLY EIGHT
ZERO WILL HOLD THE BILL ON CALL
ALL RIGHT NEXT ITEM S. SO I AND
NUMBER LIVES ON CONSENT NEXT
ITEMS I'M NUMBER TWELVE SEVERAL
OF MY OWN SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON SAID I'M GONNA
TAKE YOU IN SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION IN THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT. HAVE BEEN RECENTLY SO
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO LEAVE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AVAILABLE
FOR TESTING THAT IS DEEMED
EXPERIMENTAL OR
INVESTIGATIONAL. BROADENED THE
DEFINITION OF BIOMARKERS TO
INCLUDES UNEDITED. PHENOTYPIC
EIGHT. AND APPLY THE BILL TO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE. SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE STREAMLINES THE
BIOMARKER TESTING PROCESS BY
PROHIBITING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FOR BIOMARKER TESTING IN
PATIENTS WITH ADVANCED OR
METASTATIC STAGE THREE AND FOUR
CANCER. BIOMARKER TESTING LOOKS
AT PATIENTS GENE MUTATION
DRIVING THE CANCER TO HELP
MATCH THEM TO EFFECTIVE
INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENTS
TREATMENTS TARGETED AT THE
GENETICS OF A PATIENT'S CANCER
IMPROVE SURVIVAL RATES AND
QUALITY OF LIFE BOTH THE
MYERBERG- TEST AND TARGETED
THERAPY ARE EACH SUBJECT TO
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION BY HEALTH
PLANS AND BOTH MUST BE
SEPARATELY APPROVED BY THE PLAN
FOR THE PATIENT TO GET ACCESS
TO THE TARGETED THERAPY. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION CAN CAUSE DELAYS
ANYWHERE FROM A FEW DAYS TO A
FEW WEEKS WHICH IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO TREAT PATIENTS
WITH THE APPROPRIATE TARGETED
THERAPY FOR SPECIFIC BIOMARKER
TESTING THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO TREAT THEIR DISEASE SLOW
RECURRENCE OR PROGRESSION AND
LEAD TO A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE. MANY OF US UNDERSTAND
PERSONALLY THAT PATIENTS AND
FAMILIES SUFFERING FROM CANCER
ESPECIALLY IN THE LATER STAGES
DESERVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT. THIS BILL
HAS RETREAT IS RECEIVED STRONG
SUPPORT LIST IN THE ANALYSIS
AND- ALSO AS- SORRY IS RECEIVED
AS STRONG SUPPORT WAS LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS- AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT ARE HAVE NOT BEEN INCLUDED
IN THE ANALYSIS TODAY AT WE
HAVE DOCTOR STEPHEN WONG FROM
UCLA HEALTH SYSTEMS AFFILIATE
AND KRISTEN SANTIAGO WITH LONG
LAUNDRY TIVITY. ADHERE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
CEREMONY ALIGNMENT AND MIGHT
HAVE MISSED IT ARE YOU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS ARE THE
COMMITTEES OFFERING YES OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR LAMONT.
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON TO
THE LINER TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- THAT'S DR STEPHEN WONG
FROM THE UCLA HEALTH SYSTEMS A
PHILLY AT AND KRISTEN SANTIAGO-
FROM PUBLIC POLICY INITIATIVES
LONGEVITY. ON WHENEVER HE- SO
CAN BRING THEM ON THE LINE I
BELIEVE DOCTOR WONG IS THE
FIRST ONE TO BEGIN AND AGAIN
IT'S TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES SO I GIVE A
TWO MINUTE WARNING THAT MEANS
YOU'RE STARTING TO EAT INTO THE
OTHER PERSON'S TIME. SO DOCTOR
WONG. CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES.
PLEASE BEGIN HELLO OKAY VERY
GOOD. RESEARCHER MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOCTOR STEPHEN ONE. I'M
AN INDEPENDENT USUALLY TRAIN
ONCOLOGISTS AND FORMER
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE
UROLOGY UCLA. WHO CO AUTHORED A
PUBLISHED A MAJOR DISCOVERY OF
BREAST CANCER AND THAT IS THE
THIRD TO LOGGING WHICH
IDENTIFIED A VERY AGGRESSIVE
DISEASE. IDENTIFICATION OF THIS
GENE INVOLVING INTO A VERY
IMPORTANT BIOMARKER I CURRENTLY
WORK IN SEVERAL ONCOLOGY
PRACTICES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA. SB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE ADDRESSES A- VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE ONCOLOGY CARE
THAT IS A DELAY IN PATIENT
TREATMENT CAUSED BY PILOT
THURSDAY SHOULD PROVIDE A
MARKET TESTING. WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT GENES SUCH AS THE HER TWO
AND MANY OTHER BIOMARKERS IN
MANY CANCERS MUST BE IDENTIFIED
FOR MOST OPTIMAL MANAGEMENT
RESULTING IN. IMPROVED PATIENT
HEALTH AND SURVIVAL. THERE'S NO
A PLETHORA OF BIOMARKERS
NECESSARY FOR OPTIMAL
MANAGEMENT FOR BEST OUTCOMES IN
CANCER. AS A PRACTICING
ONCOLOGIST I PERSONALLY HAVE.
EXPERIENCED DELAYS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND GETTING
BIOMARKER TESTS APPROVED FOR
PATIENTS. TO HEALTHCARE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS. BUT
STILL IT CAN VERY FROM HEAT IS
THE FUTURE YOU'VE HEARD.
DEPENDING ON THE PATIENT'S
HEALTH INSURANCE AND OTHER-
BARRIERS IN SOME CASES THE
PATIENT NEVER RECEIVED ABOUT
MARKETERS BECAUSE THE POSITION
DOESN'T HAVE THE STAFF OR
RESOURCES OR MOTIVATION TO DEAL
WITH THE PROCESS. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION PAPERWORK AND
SUCH ABANDON THE PROCESS THIS
COOL IN THE SPORT CARE. FOR ANY
CANCER PATIENT ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO HAVE STAGED REPORT CANCER
METASTATIC CANCER. DIESEL IS
GETTING THE BIOMARKER TESTS
PROVED. MEANS A DELAY IN
STARTING APPROPRIATE TREATMENT.
THE ARGUMENT THAT COST WOULD BE
EXORBITANT OUTWEIGHED BY THE
EXPERIENCE AT INSTITUTING THE
MOST APPROPRIATE THERAPIES THAT
MOST ACOSTA. BERICHTETE I HAVE
SEEN CANCER PATIENTS WITH
ADVANCED AND METASTATIC CANCER
START INAPPROPRIATE THERAPY
BECAUSE- THEY CAN'T GET THE
BIOMARKER TESTS APPROVED IN
TURN. LEADING TO SUBOPTIMAL
CARE OF THE PATIENTS. AND
POTENTIALLY REDUCE OVERALL
PATIENT RESPONSE AND SURVIVAL.
AS A COLLEGES WE WANT TO
PROVIDE OUR PICNIC. OUR
PATIENTS THE BEST TREATMENT
POSSIBLE ELIMINATING THE NEED
FOR THIS PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
FOR BOND MARKET TESTING FOR
PATIENTS WITH CHANGE THE REPORT
CANCERS IS ONE. AND VALUABLE
STEP FOR. HELLO AND THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STERN MON ARGUES SUPPORT THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH OF THIS NOW MOVES TO
KRISTIN. HE EXACTLY TWO MINUTES
YOU HAVE TO MAKE. PERFECT THANK
YOU CHAIR AND OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK CENTER LIMóN FOR INTER
THE LETTER LIKE THAT IN MY- I
AM CHRISTMAS. AND I WORK FOR
THE LONG TIME FOUNDER HARD TO
SAY- BUT IT'S A LONG VACATION
AT. OR LUNGEVITY HAS SUBMITTED
FOR CHILD DOCTOR WITH DATA Y.
AND HAS AS CRITICAL FOR CAN'T
PATIENTS. AND THE BEST TO MY
ROLE WE ONE JOB I ALSO THE TO
AND I WHO IS A LIVE TODAY
BECAUSE HAD TIMELY. TO BUY
MARKER TESTING. AT BOTH
DIAGNOSE AND PROGRESSION. THAT
CASTING IDENTIFIED HER AS EACH
YEAR TIME ONE CANCER. AND FROM
THERE SHE WAS ABLE TO BE PUT ON
THE MOST OF. AND EFFECTIVE. MY
ON AND ARE FAMILY ARE LAW. THAT
SHE HAD PUSHED AND TO BUY
MARKET. WITH DELAY DO TO PRIOR
AUTHOR. WHICH WOULD LIGHT CARE.
AND FOR NOT EVERYONE IS SO
LUCKY AND THAT IS WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. ALL PATIENTS SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO TIMELY GUIDELINE
DAYS BIOMARKER TESTING
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE
OR WHETHER THEY RECEIVE THEIR
CARE IN A LARGE ACADEMIC
MEDICAL CENTRE OR IN A SMALLER
COMMUNITY SETTING. I AM A
PROTECTING IS STANDARD OF CARE
FOR MANY TYPES OF CANCER AND
SAVE LIVES. THIS BILL WILL HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY SICK AND DO
NOT HAVE THE LUXURY TO WAIT FOR
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION TO BE
COMPLETED. BEFORE THEY RECEIVE
BIOMARKER TESTING. CLINICAL
GUIDELINES RECOMMEND BIOMARKER
TESTING TO IDENTIFY APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT OPTIONS. ANYTHING
THAT DELAYS BIOMARKER TESTING
WILL DELAY WHEN A PERSON CAN
START. THEIR INDIVIDUALIZED
TREATMENT. PRIOR OFF. PROVIDE
TESTS. PROCESS TO CAUSE FROM
PAUL DELAY FOR PAY. HI
AUTHORIZATION BY MARK TESTS
WHICH IS- ENOUGH THAT SORRY
PRIOR PROVIDE HAS- IT IS GOES
AGAINST STANDARD OF CARE
REQUEST RIGHT STANDARD OF CARE
WE FOLLOW GUIDELINE- AND IT'S
AN EXTRA STEP THAT IS NOT
NEEDED AND CAN LEASE RIGHT.
PEOPLE DELAYS YEAH I'M DONE
BASIC IT'S NOT IT'S NOT NOT FOR
POPULATION. THANK YOU THANK GOD
THAT. THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE NOW LET'S MOVE
TO THIS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY. MOVED TO THE GALA
SCENE ON PUBLIC OUR LET'S MOVE
TO RENTAL A FORTY C. ON ROUTE
FORTY. PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
WITNESS WHICH IS IN SUPPORT AS
FIVE FIVE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST MY NUMBER IS NINE TO
FORTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. TWENTY FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERSALEX CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT. I
DO NEXT LINE. AFTERNOON THIS IS
NICK CHAPPIE WITH THE DE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION I THINK OUR SUPPORT
FOR XP FIVE THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE TO
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK TO
THIRTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND MOVING ON TO LINE. TO
FIFTY FOUR NINE TWO FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TWO FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND MOVING ON TO LINE. TWO TO
TEN NINE TO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHRISTY BOY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLINICAL LABORATORY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTED Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE- BRING THEM
ON TO THE LINE NICK LOUISE SAYS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS AND PRESTON
YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. SO ONCE
YOU'RE ON THE LINE AGAIN FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL TWO MINUTES PIECE
AGO TWO MINUTE WARNING POINT
TWO MINUTES SO LET'S BEGIN WITH
NICKEL RECESS. SO ONCE
NECKLACES ONLINE PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
THIS IS NICHOLAS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS AND- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. AS IT IS IN PRINT
TODAY OBVIOUSLY THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BENEFIT MANDATES IT IS
VERY WELL INTENTIONED AND I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE GOOD
CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAVE HAD
WITH THE OTHER STATUS. OF ANY
COMEDIANS OUT AS WELL HOWEVER
IT IS A BENEFIT MANDATE AND WE
GENERALLY OPPOSE THEM BECAUSE
EITHER INCREMENTALLY OR
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE
PREMIUMS. ON INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND EMPLOYERS. I FELT
VERY CALM EFFECTIVE THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS RELATIVELY
MODEST BUT WE DO HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE COLLECTION OF MANDATES
BEING PROPOSED COMPREHENSIVELY.
WITH RESPECT SPECIFICALLY TO SB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE OF THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT 1100% OF ENROLLEES
OF HEALTH INSURANCE DO YOU HAVE
BENEFIT COVERAGE FOR BIOMARKER
TESTING. ACCORDING TO THE
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR YOU PROGRAM. THE
ISSUE THEN IS WHETHER THESE
TESTS ARE COVERED BECAUSE THEY
ARE COVERED. THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE BILL IN PRINT
IS THAT IT CHANGES THE WAY THE
COVERAGE FOR BIOMARKER TESTING
IS REVIEWED. IN A MANNER THAT
WOULD COMPEL COVERAGE. OR
MENTAL OR NERVOUS. CONTEST THAT.
REALLY WANT TO BE PAID FOR
THEIR PRODUCTS THAT THEY
DEVELOP BUT ACCORDING TO OUR
HEALTH PLAN MEDICAL DIRECTORS.
SOME OF THE GENETIC BIOMARKER
DATA SAID INTO THE MARKET ARE
NOT BACKED BY THE EVIDENCE OR
MEDICAL LITERATURE. I KNOW THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY- ARE TO
TEND TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WITH SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE AND WE
WILL DEFINITELY REVIEW THEM. TO
SEE IF THEY WORK. ON AND GET
BACK TO BE OFFERING COMMITTEE
OF ABOUT WHETHER THE IMPACT.
OUR POSITION MOVING FORWARD. SO
YOU MIGHT. TO WERE DIRECTED
TOWARD THE BILL IN. THAT WE
HAVE SOME MORETO DO REAL THE
MEN TAKE TODAY. WE WILL DO
NOTIFY AUTHOR UP AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUDGET WE DO
READ REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO
THE- YOU KNOW IMPRINTED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO
SPRING ON PER. YOUNG FOR THE
CAN CHAMBER. AFTER MR IN
COMMITTEE PRESS FOR YOUNG THE
CAL CHANGE OF COMMERCE I'D LIKE
TO ASK OF THE CENTER MISTER
LOUISA AND EXPRESSING- FOR THE
STATE OF THE ARE IN WE'RE WITH
THE- WE WILL ALSO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE MEN. AND HOW THEY IMPACT
OUR ON THE BILL AS THE BILL IS
TODAY WERE STILL IN OUR BECAUSE-
OBVIOUSLY SB FIVE FIVE IS A
WELL INTENTIONED BILL BUT IT
BECAUSE- SOME CONCERN INTO
AFFECT ONE OF PRIOR OFF. WAIVER
AND THE OTHER BECAUSE IMPACT
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE ON EMPLOY
AND EMPLOYEES SO THAT FIRST CAN
BY A MORE TEST THE NEW A-
PERSONALIZED. THERE'S LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF CAPITAL HAND ACT
DICTATE TREATMENT. BIOMARKER
TESTING. HOPE TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL SO THAT CONCERN NUMBER ONE
AND THEN THE SECOND CAUSE FOR
CONCERN OF THE JUST MENTIONED
THE COST IMPACT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE. BASED ON THE
SUBURBAN HOUSES OBVIOUSLY THE
COST IMPACT- THAT NEEDED TO BE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS INCREASE PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND THAT'S NOT HUGE
INTERNET AT ALL HOWEVER. IF YOU
DO LOOK AT THIS IN CONTACT WITH
ALL THE OTHER BENEFIT MANDATES
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED THIS
YEAR. THE COLLECTIVE- IMPACT
THAT THEY WILL HAVE ON EMPLOYER
PREMIUMS. IS- FAIRLY DRAMATIC
INTO LOOKING AT THE
SPECIFICALLY FROM AN EMPLOYER
BASED PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
EIGHTEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT HAVE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
THROUGH AN EMPLOYER PLAN. AND
THE AVERAGE ANNUAL PREMIUM FOR
FAMILY COVERAGE OF OVER TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS SO- IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THIS HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT
YEAR FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
A BIG PART OF THAT STRUGGLE
BEEN AFFORDING HEALTHCARE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES SO. AGAIN SB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE AS WELL
INTENTIONED CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THE SENTIMENT AND- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE. THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE GOING THROUGH A
TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT TIME IN
TO BE COGNIZANT OF THAT FACT
WHEN WE DO- APPROACH IS THAT
MANDATES SO AGAIN LOOK. TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS. SAID
IN. GETTING I ON THE AND- WHAT
DIRECTION GO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FREE TIME OPPOSED TODAY. THANK
YOU THAT'S NOT MOVE ITS ON
ADDITIONAL. AND OF BILL- SO
LET'S MOVE TO THE GALA SAID ON
THE PUBLIC OUR LET'S MOVE ROOM
TO FORTY. SAN ANDREAS FORTY- I
PLEASE OPEN THE- TO WITNESS
WHICH IS. IN OP. TO SB THIRTY
FIVE. IT'S NAME OR EXIT AND
DOES ONLY. THANK MISTER AND LAY
AND IF YOU TO SPEAK AND
OPPOSITION OF B. THIRTY PM
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE AT THE
TIME. MIND TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THE ONE ELEMENT PLEASE. OF
MINE TO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO NINE TWO TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT THE
ONE IS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
TODAY HAVE BEEN OPPOSED BUT
LOOK FOR TO RECEIVING AND THEN
IT IN ABOUT ANY OPPOSITION
GOING FOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT I. I DON'T. COME IN Q.
OKAY THANKS FOR MUCH OF. NOW OF
COURSE OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBER.
OKAY SENATOR. THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR- I AM AMONG YOU
TELL ME WHAT THE CAR OF THIS IS
I AM IT BE. MINIMAL TO DO
TESTING FOR CANCER TREATMENT OR
CAN'T SEE IF YOU ARE THE CANCER.
S. CELLS. THE SO I THE OVER
COST OR THE PER TEST IT DID I
MEAN THIS IS INDIVIDUALIZED
TREATMENT SO IT DEPENDS AND I
THINK AS ONE OF THE OPPOSITION-
INDIVIDUALS TESTIFYING IT
STATED THIS IS OUR IT'S COVERED-
FOR FOLKS IT WHO WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO IT AND I ALSO WANT TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT THE COST.
OF THE BILL IMPRINTED VERSES
THE COST OF THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK AT THE
BEGINNING- COULD ALSO DIFFER
BECAUSE WE DID TAKE BE
AMENDMENTS TO LEAVE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR TESTING THAT
IS DEEMED EXPERIMENTAL OR
INVESTIGATIONAL. SO I DON'T
HAVE A CLEAR ANSWER FOR YOU.
OKAY SO BASED ON THE ANALYSIS
THAT I HAVE THE ESTIMATE IS
BASICALLY TWO CENTS PER MEMBER
PER MONTH YES- THAT SUBURBAN
HOUSES CORRECT THAT IS THE
ANALYSIS TO CENTS PER MEMBER
PER MONTH- TO HAVE THIS.
EXTRAORDINARY TESTING THAT
WOULD GIVE YOU AN INDICATION IF
YOU HAVE CANCER. AND DO YOU
CONSIDER THAT. TOO MUCH. DO I
CONSIDER TWO CENTS PER. I DO
NOT CONSIDER TO SENSE NEITHER
DO I MA'AM SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE BANK TO. OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER GROVE I WILL MAKE
NOTE THERE IS A SUBURBAN NOW IS
SO WE HAVE A SOME OF THAT AND
THE ANALYSIS BUT- TERMS OF THE
COST AND THAT THE TWO CENTS PER
MEMBER PER MONTH WAS.
SPECIFICALLY CALPERS HMS. OKAY
ARE THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THREE MEMBERS. OF THE-
SO. OKAY SO THIS. OCTOROK LIKE
TO MAKE A BOMB- ACTUALLY THE
QUESTION AFTER TOWARD YOU
DOCTOR SO. IF THERE'S A
DIRECTED YOU WE BRING YOU ON TO
THE- ALL RIGHT DANNY OTHER. ARE
COMMON FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NONE BEEN BILL BY
SERRA ROCK. SERVER AT YOU SOME
FOR WORK FOR THE CA AND TAKING
THE AMENDMENT. I WILL MAKE NOTE
THAT PART OF THE CHALLENGE
TRYOUTS. THE LATE THAT'S WHAT
WE FROM YOUR WITNESS- FOR IF
THERE WERE. ANY AND THAT WOULD
BE OF AN A BUT WE KNOW THAT
WHAT WE DO WANT TO DO. AND- IS
HAVE SOME DIAGNOSED CANCER.
AND- NOT ABLE TO ACCESS TO BY
OMAR TESTS ARE HAVING A DELAY
EVEN WHEN OF. AT THE LATE SO
THAT IT ACTUALLY. DID THE
OPPORTUNITY TREATING. AND AGAIN
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE FOCUS AGAIN
ON PEOPLE STATE STREET FORCE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SEVERE.
FORMS OF CANCER WHERE IT'S CAN
BE LIFE OR DEATH SO I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE AS
WORRIED BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER LAMONT. I
RESPECTFULLY FOR AND I HAVE A-
THANK YOU CENTER LAMENTS IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SERRA TO MOTIONS
TO PASS AENDED. TO THE
COMMITTEE OF. SECOND PLEASE
SORRY CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PAN. HI CAN I AM A ONE
IS EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I GROVE GROWTH BY
GREW I HEARD TALK. LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LIMA. HI LIMON ROTH. ROTH I
RUBIO. HI RUBIO AYE WE. WE AYE.
SO THE CURRENT NINES BUT THE ON-
WE DO HAVE A MEMBER WHO NEED TO
LEAVE I KNOW HAVE CERTAIN
GLAZER BUT WE'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY DO THE CONSENT LOW THE
CALL SO THAT THE VOTES CAN BE
TAKEN CARE OF INTO THE
TESTIMONY KEEPS KNOW GOES BE
THE TIME WHICH NUMBER CAN
REMAIN- SO- NUMBER CAST ALL
THEIR VOTES SO IS SO THE COUNT
WE HAVE ITEM ON THE CAN CAL.
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER LOW SP 20%
OF AND ITEM THE FOURTEEN BY B.
SB EIGHTY NINE BY SIR IS A
MOTION ON THE CENTER THE NEW BY
SEN LEYVA AND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND CONSENT. PAN HI CAN I.
MULLIN. EGGMAN EGGMAN I CAN
SELL. HI AND- I GREW. FOR TARO
LEYVA LEYVA AYE LIMA I THE NEW
AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO WIENER OUR YOU THERE ARE
OKAY- I. THE. EIGHT ZERO. OKAY
SO THE KERN ROLES EIGHT ZERO
FOR THE CONSENT LEAVE THE BILL
AT THE CONSENT TELL ON. THE NOW
MOVE A EITHER NUMBER S. B. ONE
BY SIR WE- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE OF AB MEMBERS MULLIN.
GROW HER TADO LIMóN HI LIMON
HI. OKAY SO THAT BILLS EIGHT
WILL THE BILL ON CALL TO MOVE
TO ITEM THE TWO S. THREE TH
NINE BY CENTER- CANCEL PLEASE
CALL THE THAT SOME. GROW ME MON
HI LIMóN I. NINE NINE ONE.
NINE ONE RIGHT THE CURRENT OF
IS NOT ONE WILL NEED TO BE A
BILL ON CALL. THE ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I NUMBER THREE
SB 22255% IMPORTANT. CONSULTING
CALL THE ROLL MEMBER MELENDEZ.
LIMON I. ONLY NINE ZERO THE
THAT BILL ON CALL- LET'S NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE FORTY BY CENTER STERN-
THIS CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ
HER TADO. OKAY ACTUALLY- RIGHT
NEXT- NEXT BILL IS AT AYE
NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY- BY
CENTER STERN- CANCELED THESE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ GROVE HER TADO. WINNER.
ZERO SIX- FIVE. WIENER AYE OKAY-
THAT IS. EIGHT OF LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SP FOUR TWENTY A BY CENTER TADO
I CAN CALL THE ROLL THAT
MEMBERS MULLIN GROVE HER TADO
WE I WIENER AYE PAY THE BILLS
CURRENTLY A ZERO WILL BE THE
BILL ON CALL AT I'M NOT NINE IS
SIX FIVE A AG. SIX CONSULTING'S
GO ROLLED UP MEMBERS MULLIN
GROVE HER TADO WIENER I WIENER
AYE OKAY BILL'S EIGHT WILL BE
THE BILL ON CALL- ITEM NUMBER
TEN S. B. FIVE SIXTY BY CENTER
EGGMAN- CAN CALL ROLLED UP TO
MEMBERS WELL MELENDEZ HER TADO
WIENER. PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT- SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR TODAY AND FOR THE TIME
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF
SPENT ENGAGING WITH ME ON AN
ISSUE THAT I KNOW WE ALL TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY. AS WE STAND
HERE TODAY. WE ALL HOPE THAT
THE WORST OF THIS PANDEMIC IS
OVER. WE LOOK TO THE COMING
SUMMER WITH HOPE AND OPTIMISM.
BUT AS WE DO. WE SHOULD PAUSE
AND GIVE AND GRIEVE OVER THE
LIVES OF MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND OF OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN CUT
SHORT BY COBIT NINETEEN. THIS
INVISIBLE BUT DEADLY VIRUS THAT
HAS BROUGHT US SO MUCH MISERY
IN OUR STATE. WE SHOULD BE
ESPECIALLY MINDFUL THAT MOST OF
THOSE WHO THAT WHO HAVE DIED.
WE'RE AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR SOCIETY. EITHER BY
VIRTUE OF BEING POOR. FOR
ELDERLY ARE CHRONICALLY ILL FOR
BECAUSE THEY WERE AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO RISKED THEIR LIFE.
TO HARVEST OUR FOOD TEND TO THE
SICK OR KEEP US SAFE. AS WE DO
LOOK BACK ON ALL THOSE LIVES
LOST WE SHOULD ALSO ASK
OURSELVES. WHAT COULD WE HAVE
DONE DIFFERENT. AND IF GOD
FORBID SOMETHING LIKE THIS EVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. WHAT COULD WE DO
BETTER. ULTIMATELY STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF THE HIGHLY INFECTIOUS
VIRUS COMES DOWN TO HUMAN
BEHAVIOR. A VIRUS SPREADS VIA
ACTIVITY THAT COMES SO
NATURALLY TO ALL OF US AND
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US CRAZY
SIMPLE HUMAN INTERACTIONS WITH
OUR FAMILY WITH OUR FRIENDS HI
EVEN WITH STRANGERS. PREVENTING
THE SPREAD REQUIRES PEOPLE TO
CONTAIN ALL OF THAT
INTERACTION. AND AT TIMES
UNPLEASANT AS IT MAY BE IT
REQUIRES OUR GOVERNMENT TO TAKE
STEPS TO PREVENT HUMANS FROM
INTERACTING WITH ONE ANOTHER.
IF WE ARE TO DO THIS AND IF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE ANY
CONFIDENCE IN THE DECISIONS
THAT GOVERNMENT MAKES IT A TIME
OF SUCH STRESS IN PERIL. IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT OUR DECISIONS BE
BASED ON DATA. AND SCIENCE. AND
THAT WE SHARE THE INFORMATION
THAT POWERS THOSE DECISIONS
WITH THE PUBLIC. THINK OF HOW
MANY TIMES. YOU HAVE BEEN ASKED
OVER THIS PAST YEAR TO EXPLAIN
THE DECISIONS THAT THE STATE
HAS MADE. WHY ARE SOME SCHOOLS
OPENED AND SOME CLOTHES. WHILE
I WAS OUTDOOR DINING BAND WHILE
INDOOR MALLS WERE OKAY. ARE WE
TOLD THAT FRESH AIR AND
VENTILATION WERE KEY BUT WE
SHOULD STAY INSIDE OUR HOMES
WHY CAN'T I GO OUT AND GET MY
HAIR CUT OR EVEN STYLED IF I
WEAR A MASK WHY CAN'T MY KIDS
PLAY SPORTS. OUTSIDE IF YOU ARE
LIKE ME YOU WERE ASKED THESE
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. AND WERE UNABLE TO
ANSWER THEM BECAUSE WE WERE
NEVER SHOWN THE DATA THAT
BACKED UP THOSE DECISIONS. THIS
LACK OF PUBLIC DATA HAS LED TO
A LACK OF CONFIDENCE IN
NATIONAL STATE AND LOCAL
POLICIES. THAT HAVE LED TO A
LACK OF ADHERENCE TO THESE
GUIDELINES. THAT WILL LEAD TO
MORE INTERACTIONS WERE
INFECTIONS. OR HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND SADLY MORE DEATHS. TO DO
BETTER WE NEED IF YOU WILL
NORTHSTAR THE NORTH STAR TO
GUIDE NOT JUST OUR PUBLIC
POLICY BUT OUR PERSONAL
DECISIONS SOMETHING WE CAN ALL
HAVE FAITH IN. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE TO COLLECT AND MAKE
AVAILABLE MORE DATA. ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF INFECTIOUS
RESPIRATORY DISEASES IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. WE ARE
MORE THAN A YEAR INTO THE CODE
NINE PANDEMIC WE STILL HAVE
VERY LITTLE SCIENCE SUPPORTING
OUR BELIEF ABOUT THE HEIL THE
HOW THE VIRUS IS SPREAD AND
WHICH MEASURES ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN SHOWING INST
SLOWING OR STOPPING THAT SPREAD.
IN THE FUTURE PANDEMIC WHICH IS
THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL. WE NEED
MORE THAN INTUITION AND
ANECDOTES WE NEED SCIENCE AND
GOOD SCIENCE DEPENDS ON GOOD
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA. NO
MATTER WHERE YOU STAND ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE DIVIDED
CALIFORNIANS THIS PAST YEAR
OPEN CLOSE OPEN CLOSE. EVERYONE
SHOULD WANT TO HAVE THE KIND OF
DATA THAT CAN GROUND THESE
DECISIONS. WHILE THE STATE IS
COLLECTED AT LEAST SOME DATA ON
NEARLY FOUR MILLION CASES VERY
LITTLEOF THAT INFORMATION IS
SEEING THE LIGHT OF DAY.
CURRENTLY THE STATE PROVIDES A
STATEWIDE SUMMARY OF
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA INCLUDING AGE
SEX AND ETHNICITY. BUT LITTLE
ELSE. AND EACH COUNTY THERE
HAVE BEEN. GUIDELINES ON
DISCLOSURES. BUT IT REALLY HAS
COME DOWN TO RUBIK'S CUBE OF
SCRAMBLED INFORMATION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
PROTECTING PRIVACY AS A GOAL
THAT WE BOTH SHARE. I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. IF ENACTED
IMPROPERLY IMPLEMENTED. IT WILL
GIVE BONA FIDE RESEARCHERS
BETTER AND QUICKER ACCESS. TO
DATA THAT TAKEN THAT CAN FUEL
THEIR STUDY THAT COULD SAVE
LIVES. UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO COME TO A SIMILAR
pAGGREGATED DATA. THAT WOULD
HELP POLICY MAKERS CRAFT BETTER
DECISIONS AND HELP THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND THE RELATIVE RISK OF
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES. BUT EVEN
WITH THE MODEST EXPANSION IN
THIS BILL AS AMENDED. WE WILL
STILL BE PROVIDING FAR LESS
INFORMATION AND SO MANY
JURISDICTIONS. ROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE NEW TAUGHT US I JUST ONE
EXAMPLE THE STATE DISCLOSES
SUMMARY DATA THAT SHOWS WHETHER
COVERT PATIENTS WERE INFECTED
BY KNOWN CONTACT PROVIDE
COMMUNITIES SPREAD AND WHETHER
THERE'S A SUSPECTED EXPOSURES
OCCURRED AT HOME IN A SOCIAL
SETTING A WORKER FROM TRAVEL
THERE'S NO REASON CALIFORNIA
CAN'T DO AS MUCH FOR OUR
RESIDENTS OR MORE. AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
OTHERS IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS
AHEAD TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. MEMBERS WE HAVE AFTER
GROCERY CLERKS ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS OR TEACHERS ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND OTHERS TO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO HELP
US GET THROUGH THIS AWFUL AND
HISTORIC TIME. WE'VE ASKED OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS TO
SHELTER IN PLACE FOR MORE THAN
A YEAR. TO STAY SAFE. YET THEY
HAVE ALL PUT AT FURTHER YET
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN PUT AT
FURTHER RISK BY THE DATA DESERT
THAT KEEPS POLICYMAKERS AND THE
PUBLIC. FROM KNOWING AS MUCH AS
WE SHOULD AND AS MUCH AS WE
COULD ABOUT THIS DISEASE. WE
HOPE THAT WE WILL NOT SEE
ANOTHER PANDEMIC IN OUR
LIFETIME OR IN OUR CHILDREN'S
LIFETIME. THAT EVEN AS SOME MAY
FEEL A SENSE OF RELIEF. AS
VACCINATIONS RATES GO UP. LAST
WEEK THE PLANET SET A NEW
RECORD FOR THE NUMBER OF COBIT
CASES DIAGNOSED. AND OTHER
STATES IN OUR COUNTRY OR SEEN
RENEWED SURGES. THE MORE THE
DISEASE LIVES ON THE MORE
VARIANCE IT PRODUCES IN THE
GREATER THE RISK THAT EVEN
CALIFORNIA COULD SEE ANOTHER
SEARCH. FINALLY MEMBERS IMAGINE
IF YOU COULD GO BACK TO JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE BEGINNING
OF THIS PANDEMIC. AND YOU WERE
AND WE HAD TO DO IT ALL OVER
AGAIN. WHAT WOULD YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY TO TRY TO SAVE AS
MANY. AS POSSIBLE OF THOSE
SIXTY THOUSAND LIVES WHAT COULD
WE DO DIFFERENTLY. THE SINGERS
THAT SINGLE THING THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS HAVE MOST IN OUR
CONTROLS INFORMATION. IN A
PANDEMIC INFORMATION SAVES
LIVES AND WE HAVE THE POWER TO
GATHER IS TO USE IT AND THE
SHERIFF. IF IT WERE AVAILABLE.
AND IF IT WERE AVAILABLE THAT
WOULD BE A DIFFERENT. MATTER
AND WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY AS WELL MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZIER- I WANT TO BE JUST VERY
CLEAR BECAUSE YOU MADE A
STATEMENT BUT I WANNA BE SURE
THE MEMBERS IS COMMITTEE
UNDERSTAND. HOW HE DID NOT
ACCEPT ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT COMMITTEE- RECCA ASK YOU
TO TAKE. I HAVE A COPY OF THE
DOCUMENT FROM YOUR CONSULTANT
HERE. THAT HAS YOUR RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THEM AND IN TOTAL. SO YOU'RE
ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING THE REMOVAL AND SO I
JUST WANNA BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE- YOU'D INDICATE
YOU ARE NOT ACCEPTING- SO- SOME
OF THE AMENDMENTS RELATED
PARTICULARLY TO THE PUBLIC
REPORTING BECAUSE THAT ADDRESS
THE PRIVACY ISSUES SO I WANT TO
BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU HAVE AN
EMAIL FROM YEARS. CHIEF
CONSULTANT LAST NIGHT I HAVE
COPIES OF IT HERE THAT HAS THE
VENDORS THAT YOU REQUESTED THAT
I ACCEPT AND ACCEPT THEM. YEAH.
FIVE TWENTY COPIES HERE IF
YOU'D LIKE THEM TO BE HANDED
OUT OKAY SO- TO BE FAIR TO THE
MEMBERS SINCE YOU HAD NOT
ACCEPTED THEN WE DO NOT PROVIDE
THEM TO THE MEMBERS- SO I WANT
TO SPEAK AGAIN I WILL BE FAIR
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WHO ALL HAVE TO CAST VOTES ON
ON THIS BILL BEFORE YOU SELL AS
FAR AS I KNEW- I'M HEARING YOU
NOW SAY YOU ARE COMMITTING TO
TAKE ALL THE AMENDMENTS THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECKONED HAS- ASK
YOU TO TAKE. RIGHT NOW AND THEN
WE SHOULD PROBABLY PROVIDE
COPIES OF THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
THE MEMBERS AND I APOLOGIZE TO
THE MEMBERS THAT YOU DO NOT
HAVE THEM IN ADVANCE FOR
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE I KNOW
SOMETHING YOU KNOW THAT MEANS
THE STAFF HAS A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT THOSE. THE AMENDMENTS WERE
PROVIDED TO ME FROM YOUR STAFF
APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING THIS
COMMUNICATIONS ON THAT HAVE.
COPIES HERE FOR PEOPLE TO
REVIEW IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO.
OKAY AT CENTROLEGAL YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN ASK A QUESTION- YES
SIR YOU RECEIVE PROCEDURAL
QUESTION AND IT'S TOTALLY
PROCEDURAL CORRECT QUESTION
CENTER GLAZER YOU AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION LAST NIGHT AND YOU
WERE TAKING ALL THE AMENDMENTS
EXCEPT ONE THE ONE THAT YOU
WERE NOT TAKING HONEST WITH YOU
LAST NIGHT ARE YOU INCLUDING
THAT IN THE AMENDMENTS TODAY
THE DIFFERENCE AS I MENTIONED
IN MY REMARKS WAS ABOUT-
AGGREGATED. THE PUBLIC RELEASE
OF AGGREGATED DATA. AND THAT IS
NOT PART OF THE MAN IS THE
PROPOSAL THAT CHAIRMAN. OKAY
OKAY SO. I FEEL LIKE YOU ARE
NOT AN ON WORDS BUT- BECAUSE WE
TALKED ABOUT AGGREGATED DATA
BUT YOU ALSO SPECIFICALLY SAID
YOU WERE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
EXCEPT FOR ONE WHICH HAD TO DO
WITH AGGREGATED DATA AND THAT I
TOLD HER I COULDN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL IF YOU DID THAT BUT NOW
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE ACCEPTING
ALL THE AMENDMENTS SO TO ME
THAT WOULD FIT YOUR ALSO
ACCEPTING THE ONE THAT I ASKED
ABOUT LAST NIGHT. WELL THAT
THAT AND APOLOGIZE AGAIN FOR
ANY MISUNDERSTANDING THE
DIFFERENCES WAS NOT A PART OF.
ANYTHING HE WAS PROPOSING. SO
THE DIFFERENCE WAS AN AD THE
ISSUE THAT I HAD WAS TO ADD.
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA. GATED
DATA TO WHAT HE WAS PROPOSING
WHICH IS SOMETHING HE WAS NOT
WILLING TO ACCEPT. SO IT'S SO
YOU'RE NOT ACCEPTED OKAY SPACEX
I WOULD JUST RATE UNDER LEYVA
MISTER CHAIR- THROUGH YOU YEAH
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOURS IF
YOU'RE SUPPORTING THE BILL OR
NOT I WILL BE FOLLOWING YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR LEYVA- SO I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT. SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
SOMETHING EVERYTHING THAT I
ACCEPT THE LET'S MOVE ON TO
CENTER GROVE YES ARE GROSS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND ARE.
WE WAIT ALL THE TIME AND- DATE
STAFF CAN DISTRIBUTE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUSLY WE GET IT ON
THE FLOOR AND WORK BILLS. IS
THERE A WAY WE CAN GET A COPY
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
AUTHOR IS WILLING TO ACCEPT.
LIKE RIGHT NOW. SO I WILL POINT
OUT THAT YES WE CAN CERTAINLY
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. AND THAT DOES NOT
MEAN YOU'RE NOW REINVENTING I
I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CENTER PLACE YOUR
BECAUSE SOUNDS LIKE. YOU'RE NOT
ACTUALLY TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AS WE ARE PROPOSING BUT SOMEHOW
YOU ARE NOW SAYING THAT THERE'S
A DISH DOES ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT YOU'RE ADDING ON THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW. WE ARE. YEAH
BECAUSE- THE- DOCTOR. DOES NOT
CORRESPONDING TO WHAT WE KNOW
OUR AMENDMENTS ARE. AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO SEND AN ON THE RECORD
MR CHAIRMAN THAT I WILL ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU SHE-
SHARED WITH ME I HAVE THEM HERE
THAT YOU'VE- SHARED WITH ME AND
MY STAFF LAST NIGHT. I ACCEPT
THE MEN IN TOTAL. PERIOD SO
OKAY. IDIOTS COME MOVING THE
BILL FOR. OKAY IT'S ON THE
CONDITION I'VE X. IN TOTAL
WITHOUT ANY CHANGE. THE YOU-
I'M GOING TO SUGGEST AND
APOLOGIZED THE MEMBERS HERE-
TAKING A BRIEF RECESS SO WE CAN
CLARIFY EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DEBATING BECAUSE I
WANT TO BE FAIR TO THE MEMBERS
IS COMMITTEE WHO WE CASTING
VOTES THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE VOTING ON. THANK YOU- SO
WILL- TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS
INCIDENT LASER YOU A NINE
ACTUALLY HAVE STAFF THAT WITH
MY STAFF WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU COURSE.
THANK YOU. OKAY SO. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AGAIN FREESHEET
THE MEMBERS- SO I IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AND DO YOU CAN
JUST. CONFIRM YES- CENTER
GLACIER THAT- YOU HAVE
COMMITTED TO TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS. WE MAY ACTUALLY
BECAUSE THE MECHANICS- THEY MAY
ACTUALLY FORMALLY BE TAKEN UP
IN JUDICIARY BECAUSE- BUT YOU
ARE COMMITTING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS. AS AS THE COMMITTEE
HAS PROPOSED AND TOTAL- AND-
THAT CORRECT. YES OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER GLACIER. THAT IS-
APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY WITH THAT
IF THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT
PROCEDURE. LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- SO THE
WITNESSES IN THE PORT WE HAVE-
DR JEFFREY KLAUSNER- FROM. THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHECK SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. AND SAID RAMBLE- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING THEM ON TO THE LINE AND-
THEY WILL. EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. TOTAL FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM. AND
WILL WITH DOCTOR. HELLO MY NAME
IS DR JEFFREY KLAUSNER
DEMOCRATS PRACTICING INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PHYSICIAN MEDICAL
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND PROFESSOR OF
PREVENTIVE MEDICINE WAS
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR
WHICH WOULD ADD NEW DATA
ELEMENTS T KEEP MEDICAL
RESPIRATORY DISEASE REPORTS
REQUIRE THE STATE TO SHARE DE
IDENTIFIED DATA IN IT MEANS
THAT WOULD ALLOW NON STATE
PARTIES TO PERFORM AT THE
CUMULATIVE ANALYSIS. FIFTEEN
YEARS I SERVED AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER RESPONSIBLE FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE
INVESTIGATION PREVENTION AND
CONTROL WITH THE US CDC AND A
SITTING COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE THE CALL THE
NINETEEN HAS BEEN AN ABJECT
FAILURE. WITH NEARLY SIXTY
THOUSAND US WHICH OVER TWO
THIRDS WHEN DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS OF COLOR ADDITIONAL
ASPECTS OF THAT FAILURE OR THE
CONTINUED SCHOOL CLOSURES AND
SEVERE ECONOMIC LOSS AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS YOU
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THE FAILURES
IN THE POOR USE OF
EPIDEMIOLOGIC DATA. INABILITY
OF THE STATE TO USE DATA TO
GREATER RISK BASS RESPONSE TO
TARGET RESOURCES AND
INTERVENTIONS TO LIMIT THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE CAUSED BY
BROAD BASED STATEWIDE POLICIES
BECAUSE OF DECADES OF FUNDING
CUTS TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE STATE IS
LIMITED CAPACITY TO ANALYZE
COLLECTED DATA. FOR THE MORE
THE DATA COLLECTED INCOMPLETE
AND INSUFFICIENT TO CREATE A
SIGN PLEASE RESPONSE EXAMPLES
OF THAT FAILURE WITH THE
INDISCRIMINATE CLOSURE OF
OUTDOOR SPACES PLAYGROUNDS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF UNFOUNDED
INTERVENTIONS LIKE DEEP
CLEANINGACTIVITIES. ON THE
FLIP SIDE THE LACK OF GOOD DATA
USE RESULTED IN AN ECLECTIC
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THE
FAILURE TO IMPLEMENT TESTING IN
THE WORK FORCE WHICH COULD HAVE
PREVENTED THE FURTHER SPREAD OF
INFECTION SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY FOUR WILL BE A STEP
TOWARD RIGHTING THE STATE'S DEL
PUBBLICO SYSTEM BY ADDING.
RELEVANT EXPOSURE ELEMENTS- TO
COMMIT TO ARE. FURTHERMORE BY
MAKE THE I. D. DAY FELL FOR. TO
NEW THE NEW RESEARCH AND PUBLIC
HEALTH IS A- WITHIN THE- THAT
COULD BE. BY X. TO WHICH
EXPOSURES AND SETTINGS TO TRULY
PUT CALIFORNIA AT RISK. AND
SHE- THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO- SETS BRAMBLE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRAMBELL PERCY TA IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY FOUR. EXCUSE ME NO ONE
WANTS TO BE BACK IN OUR
CLASSROOMS WITH THEIR STUDENTS
WHERE WE KNOW THAT THEY LEARN
BEST MORE THAN EDUCATORS. FROM
CTA SEEKS TO MAKE DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS WITH SAFETY AT THE
FOREFRONT DURING THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AN URGENT
NEED DURING THIS KINDA MAKE IS
TO IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE DISEASE'S TRANSMISSION AND
PREVALENCE IN THE WORKPLACE
SHORTCOMINGS IN OUR DATA
COLLECTION HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
FOR A MORE COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM
TO TRACK AND MAKE PUBLIC. THE
INFORMATION ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN THIS IS DATA WE CAN
USE TO DETERMINE WHEN IT IS
SAFE TO OPEN A SCHOOL OR
WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE A NEED
TO REVERT BACK TO DISTANCE
LEARNING DURING AN OUTBREAK. WE
DON'T HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
CORONAVIRUSES SCHOOLS AS PART
OF A PUBLIC DATABASE THE
EDUCATORS PARENTS AND STUDENTS
CAN ACCESS MAKING SCHOOL VIRUS
DATA PUBLIC WILL HELP ESTABLISH
PUBLIC TRUST AROUND THE SAFETY
OF OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES. WE
NEED MORE DATA SO WORKERS CAN
BUILD TRUST WE NEED BETTER DATA
SO THAT PARENTS CAN BUILD TRUST
THAT THIS IS A CRUCIAL NEED FOR
GOOD DATA ON THE SPREAD OF THIS
INFECTIOUS DISEASE TO HELP
INFORM PUBLIC POLICY THAT
MINIMIZES RISK. TO TEACHERS AND
ALL VULNERABLE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY
FOUR WILL BE HELPFUL AS IT WILL
EXPAND ON THE DATA THAT THE
STATE IS COLLECTING AND RELEASE
AS MUCH OF THAT INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE TO HELP INFORM PUBLIC
POLICY. BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT RELEASING DETAILS THAT
WOULD ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL TO BE
IDENTIFIED WE SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT TO IMPROVE OUR DATA
SYSTEMS AS WE SEEK TO RECOVER
FROM ONE OF THE WORST DISASTERS
EVER FACED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TIMES LIKE THESE
CALL FOR EXTRAORDINARY. ACTION
AND WE ARE AT YOUR ARTICLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW WILL MOVE
ON TO. IT IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR- WILL BEGIN
WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN
ON ROOM TWENTY FORTY- WE'RE NOW
MOVES TO THE TELLING.
CONFERENCE LINE- SO LOTTERY-
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR AGAIN IT'S NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
TEN MILLION GERMAN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
BEGIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
SB. SEVEN FOUR FOUR. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE RESEARCHER
THANK YOU NOW MOVES TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR WE HAVE TO
LEAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
KEEP IN MIND WE'VE NOW TAKEN
SAID COMMUNITY SAID OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE LEAD
TN- FROM THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND
CATHERINE TO BURKE FROM DAY
HEALTH OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. HOUSING BRING THOSE
ON THE LINE I'LL BEGIN WITH OF
THE TEN OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. TWO
MINUTES APIECE BOB. THANK YOU
TALK TO YOUR DOCTOR PAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CONNOLLY
CHALLENGES PLATED DIRECTOR PUT
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION- HI MY STATEMENT
TODAY IS GONNA BE ABOUT THE
VERSION IN PRINT BECAUSE-
FRANKLY WE HAVE NOT SEEN. BUT
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT AMENDMENTS
THE AUTHOR ACTUALLY HAS
ACCEPTED TODAY WE DO APPRECIATE
TEARS UP TO WELL TO BRING
PRIVACY BEFORE- AND WE HOPE TO
WOULD WORK. LATER ATTACHED
SPEND WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO SO
RIGHT NOW WE REMAIN OPPOSED
POSITION. SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
AS AMENDED REQUIRES THE STATE
PUBLISHED INDIVIDUAL AND WHAT
WILL BE THE- ONLY GUARD RAIL TO
MOVE OUT BY LUCIAN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE IDENTIFICATION WONDER
HYPOCRITICAL. BUT THAT DOESN'T-
GUARD RAIL PROTECT THE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION THAT
SEVEN SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR IT
LIKELY TO PUBLISH TO THE WALL
WITH MODERN TECHNOLOGY YOU CAN
LINK THAT DATED BACK TO
SPECIFIC POSITIONS. ABU
CLOTHING LOTS AND THEN IT IS
BETTER SEVERAL STUDIES THAT
EXPLAIN THE POWER. OF THE
IDENTIFICATION. FOR EXAMPLE.
BASICALLY INCREASE THE WE ARE.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND TEN I CAN'T
WORK MISS TEN WE CAN'T WE WERE
HAVE TROUBLE YOU CAN YOU SPEAK-TO YOUR MICROPHONE PLEASE- YEAH
HAVE A CLUE. HELLO THANKS RIGHT
NOW THEIR OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE
HOLD UP ALL RIGHT. SO- WHAT I
SAYING IS. SB SEVEN FORTY POINT.
THE INDIVIDUAL IN WORKPLACE
WINTER MAY FORTY A TRAP ST.
WILL BE VERY WE- I. POLITICS
SHE HOW. WILL KNOW ABOUT. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH MISSION ARE
PROJECTED PROBLEM NATION.
CONFIDENTIAL STATUS UNDER IT
BUT ONCE AND TO PUBLIC CALL. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS FOR
HELP. AFTER THE STATE PARTNERS
BIG TECH COMPANIES. WELCOME
INTO THE CAST CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO DRIVE. IN SPITE OF THE-STATE CHECK RIGHT ESPECIALLY IN
THIS TIME OF UNPRECEDENTED
CRISIS. ONE CRISIS HAPPENS
DECISIONS ARE PASSED WE AREN'T
ALWAYS ABLE. TO PROTECT PRIVACY
WE SHOULD. TRANSACTION THE YOU
BUT NOW LET'S PLEASE BRING ON-
ACT KATE THAT KEPT BURKE FOR
THE HEALTH OFFICER SAYS HE
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU
HERTZBERG WITH THE HELP OF
CONSERVATIVE IF YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE PHYSICIAN HELP
OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA THREE
THIRTY AND FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED BAKER FOR HIS HEARTFELT
WORDS ABOUT THE PANDEMIC AND IF
THEY CAN THANK YOU-
UNFORTUNATELY HERE. TO TELL AND
GREAT YOU CAN'T LOOK LIKE WE
GET THE MESSAGE WELL- OUR
GREATEST CONCERN IS THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH WE WANT TO CUT THE
PUBLIC SECTOR NEVER PUBLISHING
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA ON THE
LAST WEEK OR SPOKE ABOUT THAT
SO I'M GOING TO CONCENTRATE ON
THE REQUIREMENTS EXCEL. PLACE
ONE MEDICAL PROVIDERS. THANK
YOU CAN REPORT FOR TWO WEEKS.
TO THE RECORDING. ACTIVATION IN
OUTLOOK HEALTH. L. LAW REQUIRES
PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL TO WORK
TO THE LOCAL HELICOPTER WHEN
THE A PERSON WITH A OF ABOUT
ONE OF ABOUT NINE O'CLOCK. AND
THAT HOW WE MONITOR HEALTH OF
OUR- AND HELP. HELPING. FORTY
MAKE SURE THAT PROVIDERS AT
EVERY TO REPORT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT DIDN'T WANT TO CRY. SIMPLE
AND COME. I BUT THAT THE
PROVIDER MUCH. WE NEED TO SET
THE TEACHER FROM AND THAT WE'VE
ALL WITH THE WHITE THE MEDICAL
NOT MORE WE ALREADY WITH
GETTING PROVIDER THROUGH THE
COURT. ALL THESE QUESTIONS
ABOUT TRAVEL HE CONTACT ME THAT
THE FIRST CON. I'M NOT GOING TO
THE LOCAL DEPARTMENT LEVEL NOW
MEDICAL YOU MAY NOT TRAIN YOU
ARE. A QUESTIONS. AND IT-
ACTIVEBETA AND IT USUALLY NOT
ABOUT AT LEVEL DATA SET- BUT I
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE A- BECAUSE
ACCORDING THEIR AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WOULD QUICKLY NO BURDEN
MEDICAL AND. IF YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER WITH
ADDITIONAL T AND TO SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR WILL BE WITH- THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SO ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY OR MOVE ON TO THE- FROM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON TO TWENTY-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR- NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. AND
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN FOUR
FOUR. AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
THREE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
PLEASE BEGIN. IT WILL BE A
NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. NEXT TO NUMBER
TWO FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE MEDIA ALLIANCE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
OAKLAND PRIVACY IN A POSE I'M
NOT THE MAN TO PHYSICIAN MANY
TIMES YOUR MEDIUM AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NEXT THE NUMBER TO
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER THEY
DURING HONORED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO PRESENT A MANDATE-
LOOKING FORWARD TO READING
DETAIL AMENDMENTS IN CIRCLING
BACK WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
DOCTORS AT THE TIME HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR. OKAY ALL
RIGHT OKAY THE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE- LET'S NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MADE BEFORE
WE BEGIN- MAYBE I JUST WANT TO
COULD GO OVER WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE I KNOW YOU JUST
GOT HANDED DOWN BUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WHICH IS- AGAIN
WHAT THINGS THAT- WE WANTED TO
DO IS- ACTUALLY INCREASED THE
DATA DATA FIELD SO WE HAVE. SO
THERE'S MORE CONSISTENT
COLLECTION OF DATA-
PARTICULARLY IN RELATION TO
AGAIN HOUSING YOUNG PEOPLE MAY
ALSO THINK THAT YOU WOULD GET
ACTUALLY FROM CONTACT TRACING-
SO IF YOU'RE OF CONDUCTING
CONTACT TRACING YOU IT IS
INFORMATION THAT YOU DO HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THEY
LIVE SIDETRACKED HOUSING YOU'D
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
WORKPLACE YOU HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT TRAVEL HISTORY BECAUSE
THEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONTACTS AND SO FORTH. UPDATED
YOUR NUMBER OF PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH- I
THINK THAT'S THE INTENT OF THAT
SO THAT THE STATE CONNECTION
COMPILE THIS DATA ACROSS
DIFFERENT COUNTIES I DO KNOW
THAT DEMANDED TO TALK ABOUT
HEALTH PROVIDERS I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME QUESTION
ABOUT THE LIMITATIONS ON HEALTH
PROVIDERS ACTUALLY COLLECTING
THIS DATA AND TO THE DEGREE
THAT PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO
ANSWER THIS ACTUALLY THIS IS A
CHALLENGE THAT- THAT I THINK
CENTER WIENER AND I WORKED ON
AND TRY TO COLLECT SOME DATA
REGARDING. FOR EXAMPLE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND JUST FOR HAVING
TO FIELD ACTUALLY GETTING THE
DATA ON THAT THE OTHER PART
THAT WE DID IS THAT- WE DID
CREATE A MECHANISM BY WHICH
RESEARCH BUT A FIGHT
RESEARCHERS AND- YOU TO PROTECT
PRIVACY COULD ACTUALLY OF
ACCESS TO DATA BUT THEN HAD TO
KEEP COULD NOT RELEASE
INDIVIDUAL DATA AGAIN TO
PROTECT PRIVACY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ALSO DONE
WITH OTHER DATASETS AS WELL- SO
THEY'D HAVE TO DO IT ONLY UNDER
A BONA FIDE EMMA YOU. AND THAT
WE DID DELETE IT- TURN THE
PARTS THAT CALLED FOR-
ESSENTIALLY PUBLIC YEP BOB.
PUBLIC CATION. MANDATED PUBLIC
REPORT- UNDER DISCUSSION INCOME.
OF DATA TO ENSURE. WE IN.
REQUIRED A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO RELEASE. DATA IN
A WAY THAT COULD COMPROMISE
PRIVACY RECOGNIZING I THINK
IT'S A MENTION BY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT. EVEN IF THIS
QUOTE UNQUOTE D. INDEMNIFIED.
IT SOMEONE COULD READ DEPENDING
ON THE NATURE OF WHAT THE
REPORT IS YOU CAN REVERSE
ENGINEER IT TO FIGURE OUT LIKE-
IT'S CERTAIN NUMBER CASES IN
CERTAIN OCCUPATIONS SO FORTH.
SO AGAIN TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAVE THAT
DISCRETION. SO JUST ONE AGAIN
GO OVER WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
WERE INVOLVED- SO WITH THAT I
SEE A CENTER WIENER HAS THIS-
MICROPHONE UP YES. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL- CENTER GLAZER-
AND THAT'S CHAIR MENTIONED THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT. WE WORKED
ON. WE REALIZED EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC THAT DATA WAS NOT
BEING COLLECTED. ON THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND COVERED IMPACTS
AND SO WE- WE DID PASS
LEGISLATION IS HERE WORKING
WITH US OUR LAST YEAR WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE- TO
REQUIRE- DATA COLLECTION AROUND
COVE AND OTHER REPORTABLE.
REPORTABLE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES RELATING TO SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY I
DO JUST WANNA STAY HUMBLE
STATUS AGAIN. THOUGH WE STILL
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA BACK BILL
HAS BEEN IN THE FACT THAT LAW
HAS BEEN THE FOCUS OF HIS
URGENCY. FOR I WON'T USE ANY
SWEAR WORDS RIGHT NOW WITH
THEIR SWIRLING AROUND IN MY
HEAD BUT FOR SEVEN YOU KNOW
WHAT MONTHS. SEVEN MONTHS THAT
HAS BEEN THE LAW OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE STILL DO
NOT HAVE THAT T. C. PH HAS
LIMITED DATA ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING. BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUAL
COVERT TESTS WE DO NOT HAVE
MORE THAN VERY SPORADIC
INCONSISTENT DATA. AND WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS YOU KNOW I'VE
SIGNIFICANT FRUSTRATIONS WITH
CDPH AND THEIR IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT THERE'S ALSO ISSUES OF HOW-
HOW LIVES REPORT RESULTS SINCE
THE DATA GETS COLLECTED AND
THEY GOT STRIPPED OUT. BECAUSE
THE NATIONAL. LAB STANDARDS
DON'T INCLUDE THOSE FIELDS SO
THIS WILL APPLY TO THESE FIELDS
AS WELL THE NATIONAL STUDENT
LAB STANDARD SETTING
ORGANIZATION. WON'T HAVE THESE
FIELDS AND SO THEY'LL THEY'LL
ASK A WHEN YOU GET YOUR BLOOD
WORK. BUT THEN IT'S GOING TO
GET STRIPPED OUT SO IT'S IT IS
ABSOLUTELY MADDENING AND I'VE
ENORMOUS FRUSTRATIONS. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR NOT DEALING WITH
THIS FOR NOT WORKING IT OUT FOR
NOT FINDING A WAY TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING- THE STATE AND I
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR. THAT WE
HAVE A AND MORE FORTUNATELY WE
SEE THE LIGHT AT THE END OF
MORE MOVING CLOSER TO THE LIGHT
AT THE END OF TOWN. TOWN OVER
THIS PANDEMIC. BUT IT'S BEEN A
HUGE LOSS OPPORTUNITY FOR A LOT
OF DATA COLLECTION- AND I KNOW
CENTER CABALLERO HAD A BILL IN
THIS COMMITTEE WHERE I THINK
THAT CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BETTER. DATA COLLECTION BY IT
IS A STRUCTURE ALL ISSUE IN OUR
HELL CARE SO- AND ASSIST X. AND
BECAUSE HARM IN A CALL HARM.
DURING THE SPEND. ON SAUDI HI I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT INFORMATION I'M GLAD
THAT THE ISSUES AROUND PRIVACY
DISCLOSURE WORKED OUT THIS DATA
WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE TO
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO.
RESEARCHERS AND I AGREE WITH
THE AUTHOR THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO GET
AGGREGATED DATA- CAL IN A WAY
THAT IS USABLE- TO- TO REALLY
HELP PEOPLE AND TO AND TO FOCUS
RESOURCES. BUT BOY DO WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO BECAUSE IT'S
A COMPLETE MESS I'LL BE HONEST.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BUT YES THERE ARE
LENDERS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
SO FIRST I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR GLAZER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I KNOW
THIS- PROBABLY WAS A TOUGH
PUSH- GIVEN ALL THE CHANGES ARE
TAKING PLACE IN THIS BILL BUT-
FIRST YOU KNOW. WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CHANGES TO THIS BILL
JUST DURING THIS HEARING THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN MADE AWARE OF IN.
WE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION IN
THE SUPPORT PRIOR TO YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ANNOUNCING WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS WERE IN KIND OF
EXPLAINING WHAT WAS TAKING
PLACE AT THE BILL SO I'M JUST.
EIGHT CONCERNED THAT. PERHAPS
THEIR OPINIONS OF CHANGE OR
PERHAPS THEY HAVE SOME INPUT-
NOW THAT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE AS AS DO
ALL OF US IN OUR I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
WE'VEALREADY HEARD FROM THEM I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE STILL ON
THE LINE BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY- SHARES MY CONCERN BUT
I THINK. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HEAR IT HASN'T CHANGED HER MIND
OR ARE THEY NOW OKAY WITH THAT
OR ARE THEY REALLY OPPOSED TO
IT NOW I DON'T KNOW BUT I THIS
IS A TOUGH SPOT FOR US TO BE IN
DO YOU HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS I
NEED MAYBE PERHAPS- GET. THIS
SHIP IT IS TRY TO AND I DON'T
SPEAK FOR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS-
TRYING TO STAND IN CRAFTING
THESE AMENDMENTS- WE DID WE
DID- SHARE THEM WITH- THE
PEOPLE AT PRIVACY CONCERNS AND-
THEY WERE. BOB YEAH SO THE
DEALER OF AMENDMENTS AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY WE TRY TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS I'LL
TELL YOU THE HEALTH OFFICERS
AND HEALTH EXECUTIVES THERE
CONSISTS YOU FRY HEARD THEIR
CONCERNS ISN'T JUST ON THE
PRIVACY OTHER THEY HAD THOSE
CONCERNS THEY ALSO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ON THE DATA COLLECTION
AND THE WORKLOAD AND STABILITY
TO GET THE DATA ITSELF- SO DIED
EXPECT THEY WILL REMAIN OPPOSED
BECAUSE WE ARE CALLING ON THE
LINE THAT'S ON THE MIDDLE PART
OF THE BILL IS CALLING ON THEM
TO ACTUALLY COLLECT AND ARGUE
AND MAINTAINED- MORE DATA SO
THAT YOU HEARD THEM. BASS PARTY
OPPOSITION WAS THEIR CONCERN
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
GET THE STATE- AND SO FORTH BUT
WERE CALLING ON THEM THAT NO
YOU NEED TO TRY HARDER TO DO
THAT. SO THEIR OPPOSITION
PRICES UNCHANGED BECAUSE OF
THAT. OKAY AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT- IT'S I WILL TELL YOU I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD A HARD
TIME HEARING THEM AND
UNDERSTANDING THEM BUT I
CERTAINLY DID THE PHONE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON THE PHONE
LINE SAY OR IF IT'S THEIR PHONE
LINE BUT- I HEARD AND- MAYBE
HALF OF WHAT THEY SAID TO THAT
TO FRUSTRATION TO IT JUST
WASN'T VERY CLEAR- SO. THEN I
IF I COULD MOVE TO- PERHAPS.
PERHAPS POSING A QUESTION TO-
THE AUTHOR JEREMY. ASSISTANCE
IS WILLING TO ANSWER YES. I
THANK YOU- SO SENATOR GLAZERS-
AND THIS IS HOW I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND THE
SUBSEQUENT AMENDMENTS IS THAT-
ESSENTIALLY. ABOUT THE BALK AT
THE CONTACT TRACING IS NOW
BEING PUSHED DOWN TO HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS- IT IS THAT
WOULD YOU SAY THAT'S A FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE BILL-
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW THE-
BROADER STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT
TO EVERY COUNTY FACES THIS IS
NOT MY INTENTION TO DO- WHITING
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT I
WANT TO ROBUST CONTACT IN
TRACING OPERATION IN EVERY
COUNTY AND SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE'S STRUGGLE TO BE ABLE TO
DO. THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC THE
STATE COLLECTS THIS INFORMATION
TO DIFFERENT WAYS THROUGH THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER AND THEN
TO CONTACT TRACING HOPING THAT
THAT COMMUNITY COORDINATED SO
THAT THAT THAT INFORMATION CAN
BE DONE IN A IN A IN A IN A
SYNCHRONIZED AWAY SO WE I DON'T
WANT DUPLICATION AND I WANT TO
FISH AND SEA AND SO THAT'S THE
GOAL HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OUR WONDERFUL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS ON THAT ONE
PART OF THE OBJECTION TO SEE IF
WE CAN FIND A PATHWAY. THROUGH
THAT I HEARD THEIR CONCERNS.
OKAY BECAUSE- JUST WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT THE FIRST TWO.
PARAGRAPHS HERE OF THE
AMENDMENTS IT LOOKS AS THOUGH.
I MEAN AREN'T WE KNOW WHEN
INFORMATION WE WANT TO BE
SHARED BETWEEN THE COUNTY THE
LOCAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS BUT
IT LOOKS AS THOUGH- WE ARE
ASKING THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO COLLECT THIS
INFORMATION GIVE IT TO CD PH
WHICH IS. LOOKS LIKE IT'S
INFORMATION THAT. PRIOR TO THIS
POINT WAS INFORMATION THAT CDPH
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE GATHERING IN
IN THE PROCESS OF THEIR CONTACT
TRACING PROGRAM IT DO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY. YES
SIR BUT SO BASICALLY IT'S
POSSIBLE IN THE PROCESS OF
INTERVIEWING SOMEBODY ELSE
DOING THE EXAM AND SO FORTY MY
COLLECTED SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION BUT I- NOT A
REQUIREMENT HE ALSO BE
COLLECTED THROUGH CONTACT
TRACING THAT USUALLY IT'S DONE
BY THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
RIGHT OKAY GETTING BUT WHAT I'M
GETTING AT IS IT'S NOT THE
POSITIONS THEMSELVES WHO ARE
COLLECTING THIS DATA- REQUIRED
TO COLLECT NOT CONSISTENTLY NO
OKAY THANKS I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT BECAUSE EVEN
WHEN WE HAD. GREAT EVEN WHEN-
YOU KNOW WE HAD THE INCIDENT
LAST YEAR. AS YOU RECALL WHERE.
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS- HAD A
MEMBER WHO CONTRACTED CODED.
NONE OF US WERE CONTACTED BY
LOCAL COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER. TO DO ANY CONTACT
TRACING. WITH CLEARLY SO I
THINK THAT MARK SURE POINTS
THAT THERE'S A BREAKDOWN IN
COMMUNICATION BUT I UNDERSTAND.
THAT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
SAYING. YOU KNOW WE'RE SO
WANTED TO BEGIN WITH AND BEING
ABLE TO COLLECT THIS DATA AND
THEN GET IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
PUBLIC HEALTH IS. A LITTLE MORE
THAN WE CAN BEAR- BUT I AGREED
THAT WE'VE GOT AND COORDINATE
THIS EFFORT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
WORKING I MEAN. THE CONTACT
TRACING JUST IS NOT WORKING SO-
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
I APPRECIATE THAT. HELLO RIGHT
BILL'S BEEN BILL BY SERRATORE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY
SAYING NONE- SYSTEMS LATER
FIRST OF ALL- I KNOW WE'VE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
BILL I HOPE I HAVE EXPRESSED
AND GENERAL SUPPORT OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. I
WILL JUST HAVE TO EXPRESS THAT
IS CHAIR OF A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED THAT- YOU WAITED
UNTIL LITERALLY WALKED UP
THERE- TO NOTIFY US YOU DID
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS IN FACT THE
LAST WE HEARD YOU WERE NOT SET
UP TO GET APOLOGIZE TO THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THE CONFUSION THAT THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE THEN OF COURSE ALSO
MAKES A LITTLE CONFUSING FOR
THE PEOPLE TESTIFIED AS WELL SO
I HOPE THAT WE CAN NOT REPEAT
THAT IN THE FUTURE TALK ABOUT
THINGS GOING TO FUTURE BUT I
ALSO THINK THIS BILL DOES
ADDRESS SOME VERY IMPORTANT
THINGS WE NEED TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. SO WITH THE FACT THAT
YOU TOOK THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL- AND ALSO
I THINK DEAL WITH IT HE SAID
THAT- PERHAPS WE CAN ALSO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK TO FINE
TUNE IT- BUT- WITH THAT- IT
WILL. HELP WE'LL LOOK GET IT
OFF THE- OF. YOU CAN TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS. AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO THE MOTION IS- SUCH A
MOVE BY CENTER ROCK THE MOTION
IS. DUE PASS- SECTOR.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FACTORIES IT SHOULD BE DO PASS
AND ESTARá IT'S TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SORRY I WANT TO BE
THANK YOU FOR. CATCHING ME ON
THAT THE PAST REFER TO CAN BE A
JUDICIARY. CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AND
MELENDEZ AYE MELINDA'S AYE
EGGMAN. GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
GROW BY GROVE I HER TADO AYE
TITLE AYE LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
LEóN ROTH HI ROTH AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
ZERO THE BILL'S CURRENTLY NINE
ZERO- WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
RIGHT NOW PLEASE. OKAY SO- SO
THE SERGEANTS PLEASE- NOTIFY
ANY OF THE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
ADD ON WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIFTING THE CALL ON BILLS. WELL
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALLS-
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. P. ONE TEN BY
CENTER WIENER. CANCELED PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ. FOR ITEM ONE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. I KNOW I THOUGHT
ABOUT ALL THIS IS ARI. OF ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB ONE TEN SO WE
DECIDE ON THE ORDER HERE.
MELENDEZ HI MELINDA'S HI GROVE
HI GROUP I HER TADO. OKAY THAT
BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO. NEXT
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE BY CENTER WIENER
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT SOME MEMBERS GROW. GROVE
NO. NINETY NINETY OKAY THE VOTE
IS NINE TWO THAT BILL IS OUT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB 22255% OR PORTANTINO-
ITS OWN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ HI OKAY THAT BILL IS
OUT ELEVEN ZERO. NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOR SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO BY CENTER PORTANTINO
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ AYE
MELINDA'S AYE GROVE HI GROUP I.
THE BILL IS OUT ELEVEN ZERO.
NEXT BILLS I'M NUMBER FIVE BY-
SB THREE FORTY BY CENTER STERN.
TOLD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ AYE HER TADO. HI THE
TITLE BY THE BILL IS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY OUTSIDE BY
YES SB FIVE OH IT IS A TO YOUR
BILL NOW ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
SIX FIFTY. CONSULTANTS CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS STILL ITEM
FOR WEIGHT SORRY I'M SORRY I
HAVE ITEM SEVEN IS FOR TWENTY
EIGHT IS THAT BECAUSE YOU. I
DON'T KNOW OKAY. NO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS SB SIX FIFTY SIX FIFTY
COMMERCENTRE STORY. OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. MELENDEZ
NOW LINDA'S NO GROVE GROVE NO
HER TITLE. ET OKAY THE VOTE IS
EIGHT TO THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANKS ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT BY
SIR HER TADO CONSULT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ AYE GROVE
GROVE I HURTADO AYE PRETEND
AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. BEFORE SIXTY FIVE I
CENTER EGGMAN. CONTROLLED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME
MEMBERS MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ
AYE GROVE GROVE HIGH HER TITLE
I TOTALLY THAT BILLS OUT ELEVEN
ZERO. EXCITEMENT I'M NUMBER TEN
SB FIVE SIXTEEN BY CENTER
EGGMAN CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT'S MEMBERS
MELENDEZ. HER TADO I HER AYE.
THAT BILL IS L. TEN ZERO. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE BASE OUR LOAN
BECAUSE ALL THESE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ AYE
MELINDA'S AYE HER TADO HI TôI
THAT BILLS OUT ELEVEN ZERO-
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR BY
CENTER GLACIER. THE CONCERN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS EGGMAN. LIMON OKAY THAT
BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO FINALLY
WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LAST SOLD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT'S MEMBERS WITH SEN
CALENDAR. MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ
AYE GROVE AYE GROVE AYE HER
TITLE I TITLE II OKAY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS. OUT ELEVEN
ZERO OKAY THIS CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA ON THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE STAFF AND THE- TECHNICAL
STAFF TO HELP MAKE EVERYTHING
HAPPEN HERE TODAY FOR THOSE
WITNESSES WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TESTIFY UNDER TELEPHONIC LINE
OR IN PERSON. PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WEB PAGE ON
ANY OF THE ITEMS THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY AGAIN- AGAIN WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION.